support for households and businesses
and the nhs with patients being able to
get a gp appointment
patients are my top priority
and i will be their champion
focusing on the issues that most affect
them or their loved ones
most of the time patients have a great
experience
but we must not paper over the problems
that we face
we expect backlogs to rise before they
fall
as more patients come forward for
diagnosis and treatment after the
pandemic
and the data shows sadly
that there is too much variation in the
accessing care people receive across the
country
the scale of the challenge
necessitates a national endeavor
as we work together to tackle these
immense challenges
i will be proactive
not prescriptive in our approach
as we apply a relentless focus on
measures that affect most people's
experience of the nhs and social care
today we are taking the first step in
this important german journey by
publishing our plan for patients which i
will lay in the libraries of both houses
it sets out a range of measures to help
the nhs and social care perform at their
best for patients
the plan will empower and inform
patients to live healthier lives
place an intensive focus on primary care
the gateway to the nhs and most people
use prevention to strengthen resilience
in the health of the nation and improve
performance and productivity
to succeed
we will need a true national endeavor
supported by making it easier for
clinical professionals to return to help
the nhs as well as drawing on the energy
enthusiasm of the million people who
volunteer to help during the pandemic by
opening opportunities for them to help
in different ways
that could be by becoming a community
first responder or by for example
strengthening good neighbor schemes
across the country
and we will also be exploring the
creation of an ambulance auxiliary
service
mama deputy speaker the plan sets out
our work on the abcd of priorities that
affect most people's experience of the
nhs and social care
first ambulances
i want to reduce waiting times for
patients and apply a light focus on
handover delays so ambulances get back
on the road and to patients where they
are needed most
our analysis shows that 45 of the delays
are occurring in just 15 hospital trusts
that is why the local nhs will be doing
intensive work with those trusts to
create more capacity in hospitals the
equivalent of seven thousand more beds
by this winter through a combination of
freeing up beds with a focus on
discharge and people also staying at
home and being monitored remotely
through the sort of technology that
played such an important role during the
pandemic
in addition when patients call 999
speed of answering is critical so we
will be increasing the normal number of
call handlers for both 999 and 111 calls
next madame deputy speaker the backlog
where the waiting list for planned care
currently stands at about seven million
exacerbated by the pandemic
this summer we announced that we have
virtually eliminated weights of over two
years
and we we remain on track
to reach the next milestones in our plan
to boost capacity
we are accelerating our plans to roll
out community diagnostic centers as well
as new hospitals and we will maximize
the use of the independent sector to
provide even more treatment for patients
as well as capacity we are also getting
more people on the front line making it
easier for people to work in and help
the nhs
we know that people are leaving the
workforce for a variety of reasons
we have listened and we are responding
addressing a number of these reasons for
instance currently pension rules can be
a disincentive for clinicians who want
to stay in the profession or to return
from retirement and help our national
endeavor
but we will correct those pension rules
relating to inflation we will expect and
just trust to offer pension recycling
and we will extend until 2024 measures
that will allow people to stay or return
to the nhs
today mr speaker madam deputy speaker i
can announce that we will be extending
the operation of the emergency registers
for health professionals for two more
years this is of course on top of
commitments to boost the health and care
workforce like our manifesto pledge to
recruit 50 000 more nurses by 2024 and
that will sit alongside the design and
delivery of our forthcoming workforce
plan
c is for social care at the moment one
of the key challenges is discharging
patients from hospital into more
appropriate care settings to free up
beds and help improve ambulance response
times
to tackle this i can announce today we
are launching a 500 million pound adult
social care discharge fund for this
winter
the local nhs will be working with
councils with targeted plans on specific
care packages to support people being
either in their own home or in the wider
community
this 500 million pounds acts as the down
payment in the rebalancing of funding
across health and social care as we
develop our longer term plans
i know also there is a shortage of
carers across the country
we will continue to work with dwp on a
national recruitment campaign
and in addition since last winter we
have opened up international recruitment
routes for carers
we will support the sector with 15
million pounds this year to help employ
more care workers from aboard
we're also accelerating the rollout of
technologies like digitized social care
records which can save care workers
about 20 minutes per shift freeing up
time for carers to care
finally madame deputy speaker
d for doctors and dentists
i'm determined to address one of the
most frustrating problems faced by many
patients
getting an appointment to see their
doctor
or getting to see a dentist at all
starting with doctors there are five
steps that we are taking to help make
that happen first setting the
expectation that everyone who needs a gp
appointment can get one within two weeks
second
opening up time for more than a million
extra appointments so patients with
urgent needs can be seen on the same day
third making it easier to book an
appointment for publishing performance
by practice to help inform patients
and fifth requiring the local nhs to
hold practices to account providing
support to those practices with the most
acute access challenges and to improve
performance
clearly clinicians are best placed to
prioritize according to clinical need of
their patients
in july 44 of appointments were same day
appointments
but too few practices were consistently
offering appointments within a fortnight
now to help free up appointments we will
ease pressures on gp practices by
expanding the role of community
pharmacies
and i'm pleased to announce that today
we have agreed a deal for an expanded
offer over the next 18 months
pharmacists will be able to prescribe
certain medications rather than
requiring a gp prescription
as well as other measures involving
community pharmacists we estimate that
this will free up two million
appointments
we are also changing funding rules to
give freedoms to gps to boost the number
of staff to support their practice
we estimate that this measure could free
up a million gp appointments
for patients we will make it easier for
them to contact their practice
both on the phone where we are making an
extra 31 000 phone lines available this
winter followed by further deployment of
cloud-based telephony and online
particularly via the nhs app
and as i set out to house earlier we
will also correct pension rules so our
most experienced gps can stay in
practice
and by extending the emergency register
we are creating opportunities for people
other than gps to undertake tasks like
vaccinations
now on dentists
there are too many dental deserts
that is why we are setting out an
ambition that everyone seeking nhs
dental care can receive it when they
need it
we've already started changing the
dental contract to incentivize dentists
to do more nhs work and take on more
difficult cases and i would like to pay
tribute to my predecessors in this role
for their success in beginning to tackle
this long-standing issue
we will also be streamlining routes into
nhs dentistry for those trained overseas
so they can start treating patients more
quickly
and we will make it a contractual
requirement for dentists to publish
online whether they are taking on new
nhs patients maddening jessie speaker
these measures across a number of
important areas at the start
not the end of our ambitions for health
and care
they will help us to manage the pressure
that health and care will face this
winter and next
and improve these vital services
for the long
term my priorities
are patients priorities and i will
endeavor through a powerful partnership
with the nhs and local authorities to
level up care and match the expectations
that the public rightly have
whether you live in a city or a town in
the countryside or on the coast
this government will be on your side
when you need care the most
madam deputy speaker i commend the
statement to the house
shadow secretary of state west street
[Applause]
uh thank you madam deputy speaker i
welcome the secretary of state and her
team to their new post and thank her for
advanced site of her statement but if
there were any evidence needed that this
is a government and a party that is out
of ideas out of times and out of a clue
as to scale of the challenge facing our
country it is this statement
the nhs is facing the worst crisis it
has ever seen patients waiting longer
than ever before in a e stroke and heart
attack victims waiting an hour for an
ambulance
378 000 patients waiting more than a
year for an operation and that was the
summer
we've gone from an nhs that treated
patients well and on time when labor
were in office 12 years ago to an annual
winter crisis and now a year-round
crisis under the conservatives but don't
worry madame deputy speaker the health
secretary has got her grip on the key
issues she's not got an answer on the
workforce but she's sorted out the
oxford comma i'm sure the whole country
is breathing a sigh of relief about that
she promised a digital revolution
in the nhs well conservative health
secretaries have promised the digital
revolution 17 times since 2010 she
apparently she didn't say that she's not
promoting a digital revolution well
that's good news because i don't think
the staff slogging their guts out in the
most difficult conditions uh in in
history will be particularly impressed
by the introduction of new cutting-edge
modern technology the telephone the nh
the nhs can finally act the carrier
pigeon and step into the 20th century
i'm sure they are absolutely delighted
madden deputy speaker these measures
will not come close to ensuring patients
who need to be seen can be seen within
the time scale set out they will have
minimal impact on fixing the current
problems that general practice is facing
over the winter not my words but the
verdict from the nhs confederation on
the secretary of state's plans isn't
that the truth
she says that patients will be able to
get a gp appointment within two weeks
her party scrapped the guarantee of an
appointment within two days that labour
introduced when we were in government
and she made it clear this morning this
isn't a guarantee at all merely an
expectation and what is the consequence
if gps don't meet her expectation well
as we heard on the radio this morning
her message to patients is get on your
bike and find a new gp a patient's
supposed to be grateful for this and who
will deliver these appointments she's
promising the 6 000 gps her party
promised at the last election but won't
deliver or the 4 700 gps her party has
cut over the last decade and where will
these gp appointments take place well it
certainly won't be in the 330 practices
that have closed since the last general
election alone
the conservatives promising to fix the
crisis in the nhs is like the arsonist
promising to put out the fire they
started
and if that weren't bad enough the
supermassive black hole at the heart of
her plan is the lack of a workforce
strategy
she has no plan to provide the doctors
that our nhs so desperately needs and
despite her sesame street approach to
politics with her abcd plan by the way
last time i checked s was for social
care she's missed the n for nurses well
without a plan to tackle the staffing
crisis i say to the secretary of state
you don't have a plan for the nhs so
what is she going to do about the 132
000 staff shortages in the nhs today
she talks about 500 million pounds to
speed up delayed discharges is that new
investment or a re-announcement she's
right to say that if patients can't get
out the back door of the hospitals
because the care isn't there in the
community we get more patients at the
front door and more ambulances queuing
out the front that's exactly where we
are under the conservatives today but
she misses the crucial point unless the
government acts on the pay and
conditions of care workers employers
will not be able to recruit and retain
the staff they need so what is her plan
to address this
and madame deputy speaker patients will
be concerned to read reports that after
the conservatives failed to to hit the
four-hour a e waiting time targets for
seven years the health secretary is
planning to scrap it together i noticed
she wasn't brave enough to say that
today but i hope she's not going to do
that can she reassure the house and
patients around the country that her
response to the christ in the nhs won't
be to lower standards for patience but
to raise performance instead
and finally madam deputy speaker the
secretary of state is the third health
secretary in less than three months the
faces change but the story remains the
same there is still no plan that comes
close to meeting the scale of the
challenge no plan for staffing no real
plan for the nhs so it is clear the
longer the conservatives are in power
the longer patients will wait as dr dre
might say time for the next episode
[Music]
[Applause]
well thank you madam deputy speaker and
i thank him for his warm welcome to me
and my ministerial team
just two weeks uh it's just been two
weeks uh madden deputy speaker and
they give me they give me forgive me
well in that 12 years there are more
doctors and nurses working in the nhs
working in the nhs than ever before
we have record funding going into the
nhs the money that the government spends
through the department of health and
social care is around 40
of our day-to-day spending and that is
the reality of the conservative party
investing in the long-term health of our
nation now the honorable gentleman
mentioned a variety of things um i can
absolutely say there will be no changes
to the target for for our weight in a e
i believe it matters
i believe it matters and i'll give you a
personal experience recently
just in july i went to a e
i waited nearly nine hours myself to see
a doctor and i still didn't get any
treatment i was asked to go back the
next day so i went to a different
hospital just three miles away and i was
seen and treated appropriately
that's the sort of variation that we are
seeing
um across the nhs and it's why my
approach as we've only just last week
for example from nhs digital started
getting some data about what is
happening practice by practice so we can
start to understand start to use the
experts in the local nhs to really
prioritize
how it is that we're going to help those
patients who are not getting the service
they rightly should expect while at the
same time giving the freedom to those
other gps who are doing a fantastic job
in supporting
patients in their practice
and that is why i'm not intending to be
prescriptive but i'm determined on
behalf of patients to drive up the
performance of those that need that help
to make to do things better
now again madam deputy speaker in terms
of ambulances i'm very conscious of that
as well and the honorable gentleman is
right to say we have been in power for
12 years
and i'm conscious i've been working for
a decade about improving
these sorts of things for my
constituents as well
now particularly focusing on ambulances
i thought it was particularly helpful to
the house to learn the analysis that
we've just done very recently which does
show that 45 percent of the handover
delays are in a concentrated part of the
country but even then i appreciate
that's not good enough
and that i'm also of the understanding
while there's a similar number of
ambulance calls being made actually what
we are seeing is many more um category
one and two calls happening and indeed
our fantastic paramedics are treating
more people at home without needing to
take them into hospital but nevertheless
that brings me the challenge on how we
can do more to particularly help
ambulances get back on the road so they
can treat patients but also to consider
just like many other emergency services
says the extension of using volunteers
potentially through an auxiliary service
or indeed community first responders in
in london alone there are about 120
community first responders i think i
have that the more that more than that
in my constituency in suffolk coastal so
it is about recognizing that people who
that million people who volunteer to
help we can find a way for them to help
us during some of these particularly
challenging times as well as how the
government will work with the nhs to try
and tackle some of the fundamental
issues as well
in terms of about access to gps at all
i'm conscious that the
when labour was in power they introduced
that 48 hours we were actually told by
the nhs and by doctors
of course they met it because i expect
that was a part of their contract but
indeed what it meant was not necessarily
better outcomes for patients in their
practice
and indeed
they got into a practice of not booking
appointments on a more regular basis and
it's important that we do that as well
so one of the things uh madam deputy
speaker i'm very conscious the plan for
patients has only just been published
and i've deliberately tried to make sure
that we've held important aspects today
like the 500 million pound adult
discharge fund for the interest of the
house rather than
saying that before i came here today but
i can assure the honourable gentleman
i'm very happy to continue to work in
partnership with the nhs and keep but
keeping that focus on patients i think
is absolutely critical as well as
building on the existing nhs winter plan
developing that workforce considering
all the different plans and strategies
that we need to
need to be considered carefully as we
set about the long-term improvements
which i think he will enjoy and want me
to champion on behalf of patients too
chair of the health and social care
select committee jeremy hunt thank you
madam deputy speaker and can i welcome
the health secretary to her
role as i know it is the hardest job in
government but she has a zen-like
calmness which means that she is
very well suited to the pressures that
lie ahead and there's much to welcome
today particularly including the pension
rule changes the additional funding for
social care the new powers for
pharmacists but could i ask her to
rethink this new two-week access target
for general practice if targets were the
answer
we would have the best access in the
world in the nhs because we have more
targets than any other healthcare system
in the world
gps alone have 72 targets adding a 73rd
won't help them or their patients
because it's not more targets the nhs
needs it's more doctors
so when it comes to the workforce plan
that she recommitted to and i welcome
her commitment to publishing it
could you tell the house will it have
hard numbers so that we know how many
doctors we're going to need in 10 15 20
years time and whether we're actually
training them and will she publish it
before christmas so that staff can at
least go into winter knowing there's a
plan for the future
so i thank my right honourable friend um
and i remember when i was a backbencher
supporting him from the back benches in
his passion for
the nhs
and i'm absolutely committed to
continuing that in terms of workforce i
think my predecessors may have committed
to publishing aspects or conclusions uh
from the plan but i want to assure him
now i have spent time focusing on the
plan priorities there is already work
ongoing about the workforce plan and i
will be
hoping to make further elements today
working alongside my new ministerial
team so that we can maximize that but to
give you my own right humble friend an
example
one of the key things i want to do is to
make it more straightforward for people
wherever they are in the world as long
as they have sufficient quality to be
able to come and practice in england
it's
frankly i was astonished to learn we
can't even have people who are
accredited in scotland
to come straight away and be doc and be
dentists in england and it's those sorts
of things where we will be laying
regulations the first day we are back
after the recess and that will enable
the general dental council as an example
to accelerate this sort of aspect of
streamlining so we can make sure that
high quality doctors and dentists where
they were accredited in the world we can
take that into account and get them
helping patients in this country more
rapidly
snp spokesperson martin day thank you
madam deputy speaker may i start by
extending my welcome to our new role for
the secretary of state and also to thank
her for advanced site of this statement
today
the nhs in all four nations that there
is absolutely no doubt is facing an
incredibly different winter with
possible rises and covert infections
alongside winter illnesses and increases
in slips and falls all the while
recovering from the dire effects of the
pandemic and now an energy crisis
an inflation busting uplift is vital to
getting our health systems back into
good shape enabling them to get through
this winter and to support those in need
it's been estimated that the cost of
living crisis will add 3.7 billion a
year to the cost of social care alone
with far higher rises across the nhs
generally so how does the minister
justify her government's prioritization
of bankers and tax cuts for the rich
when investing in public services is
more essential than ever and will the
health secretary support the snp's call
for an nhs uplift greater than inflation
well i'd like to thank the honourable
gentleman again for his welcome here and
uh and as an example um i think one of
the benefits of the united kingdom is
that we can learn for each other even
when we have devolved at nhs so for
example i think we are borrowing or
copying the element about pharmacists as
an example and that is what we will be
enacting in this country too um he will
be aware that of course due to the
formula the amount per head of
population is considerably higher uh for
the scottish nhs uh than all health
money passed over but of course it's the
discretion of scottish government on how
they choose to use that money in order
to help patients
in terms of i think other aspects um he
will be aware of our ongoing challenge
that we want to work together as united
kingdom and tackling global pandemics
and i look forward to working in
preparation that he will also be aware
that we accepted the reviews of the
independent pay body in making our pay
recommendations um but i as an example
that he's just highlighted when the
prime minister was on the doorstep of
downing street she did want to talk
about growing the economy because it's
absolutely vital that we don't just
having managed decline because that will
be challenging for the united kingdom as
a whole
secondly
and one of the things that was brought
to me and which i worked on to make sure
obviously the prime minister was already
minded to make sure we had a generous
package and regarding energy bills but
to make sure that was extended to
businesses in the nhs as well and we
have made that happen so one of the
biggest concerns that i was presented
when we arrived is that people not being
able to afford that energy bills would
worsen the situation i'd like to think
we've already addressed that and as
today i've set out why it is important
that we focus on the abcd to make sure
that patients get the service they
deserve as well
thank you madame deputy speaker and can
i really deeply thank my right
honourable friend for such an excellent
statement today uh these are the issues
that are concerning my constituents and
particularly around primary care um and
i very much welcome her approach of not
providing a prescriptive solution to
some of these problems but in making
sure that there is more
access to data on um waiting times
particularly for primary care
appointments will she also look more
carefully at whether uh patients are
allowed to move surgeries if they find
that they are not able to access those
appointments on a timely basis because
otherwise the data she's
producing
will not actually have any actions for
patients themselves
well i thank my right honourable friend
and i agree with her that um access to
the gp is important right now
we're only um the only people obliged to
uh we only publish data when it comes to
the local nhs levels at the icb level
that's why where i want to go further
with the practices i know that my
honorable friend the minister
for first primary care um the honourable
member from colchester uh wants to try
and make it easier for people to move
practice of course where people have
already have choice that may be possible
but um understandably i want to just
make sure right across
the country that we get that
fairly basic standard of provision for
patients to be a very high priority
alison the governor thank you
speaker their new secretary of state had
three paragraphs on care and not a word
about care workers pay and i am
absolutely gobsmacked madam deputy
speaker and i want to ask the secretary
of state if she's read the report by the
government's own migration advisory
committee that says persistent
underfunding of the care sector
underlies almost all of the workforce
problems in social care
and that higher pay is a prerequisite to
attract and retain social care workers
so will she come back to this house with
a workforce plan for care workers that
finally at last gives them a decent pay
packet
speaker the honourable lady will be
aware that of course uh people access
care or work in care industry in
different ways uh that's why i'm very
keen to continue to have a national
recruitment program working with dwp now
in terms of the 500 million pounds i've
announced today um clearly the local nhs
working with local trusts will be in a
position and local councils will be in a
position better to decide in a more
differentiated way the best way to uh
spend that money clearly in terms of
buying packages but also support for the
sector at the same time i'll remind the
honourable lady that since last year we
have changed the taper rate in uh
universal credit so people keep a lot
more of the benefits that they may
receive but i'm also conscious that we
want to continue to try and encourage
people to come into the air care sector
and that is a joint endeavor
jamie green
jackie speaker i i welcome my right
honourable friend both to her new post
and for her statement i particularly
welcome the social care discharge fund
but as she knows the the problems of
under capacity in the care sector which
filter through to the whole nhs are not
just a winter crisis they are a chronic
problem and to that end can i
urge her to take seriously a suggestion
from the leaders of the care sector
which i know is on her desk at the
moment that something equivalent to the
teach first system should be introduced
in social care so that we can get some
of the brightest and best young people
to take up social care as a career in
their in their early
years of work this won't solve the whole
problem by any means but it will be a
significant step forward to raise the
status of the social care profession
well my high school friend is uh correct
to raise this uh as a a strategic
challenge which i'm confident my
honorable friend the minister for care
um
the honourable member for harbor will be
looking at carefully the prime minister
has set out quite clearly she wants to
see a rebalancing of funding within the
health and social care system
recognizing this challenge
and i'm sure that we will be making
progress on how we achieve that
informed actually by how the 500 million
pounds
fund is going to be spent and also the
outcomes it produces
rosie duffield thank you
speaker and i too welcome the secretary
of state to her place and for the abc
four-page statement we've got but there
were two letters really obviously
missing and that's the m and the h
mental health
she's the fifth secretary of state in my
five years in the house in those five
years i've seen hundreds of desperate
families trying to access mental health
services for young people in kent even
an initial assessment can now take
between two and four years to secure
many young people are sent out of kent
to leeds hertfordshire manchester
putting an additional strain on families
already at breaking point
please please please will the new
secretary of state help me and other ken
mps get at least beds or assessments for
our desperate constituents
well thank you madam deputy speaker of
course in a statement and indeed the
plan that's published today builds on
many of the other uh activities already
underway for me it was setting out
priorities
on how i think we can best help the
majority of people in this country i'm
very conscious of the challenges
i'm very conscious of the challenges
about mental health and provision
i've seen that myself locally as a
constituency mp what i will say is that
my honorable friend
from
who will be the care
minister sorry for mental health and
public health uh will be focusing on
this is an important aspect of that
indeed in her local situation i think
it's a case of trying to sort a meeting
with the icb to address how this will be
delivered locally
maggie through
i know my radical friend is committed to
reducing the nhs backlog could be in her
plan
does she agree with me that it's far
better for patients and productivity to
prevent ill health and that robust
policy to tackle obesity a condition
which has proven to increase the chance
of suffering from diabetes
cardiovascular disease and cancer have
an important role to play in addressing
the b of her a b c and d and will she
commit to focusing on prevention as a
key part of her strategy as we move
forward yeah
indeed madame deputy speaker and i want
to pay tribute to my honourable friend
who was uh
successful in being a health minister
i'm conscious that of course abcd is uh
probably uh caught the attention of many
people because i think that's aspects of
real focus but of course prevention is
at the heart of what we do so that
people don't need to turn to the health
service at all for treatment
and that's why we will continue uh with
aspects of the strategy
in order to try and make sure that
people
have better care and have a strength and
resilience in that whether that be
physical health or indeed mental health
as well
so george howard
could i uh madam deputy speaker welcome
the secretary of state to her new
responsibilities which
as she's
pointed out are very challenging
um could i agree with her also that
there are too many dental
deserts
she'll be aware perhaps of recent bbc
research which revealed one of those
dental deserts is the whole of the
liverpool city region
where there is not one dental practice
taking on new nhs patients
can she give me some indication of what
measures she will be taking both short
medium and long term
to address this
disgraceful situation
um
i set out in the plan um today about
what we are seeking to do with dentists
and first of all i think it's the role
of the local nhs the um the icb to be
taking on responsibility um and i expect
them to do so about that sort of
provision i think it's also a case of
making sure that the contract which i
was alluding to earlier we've started to
make some changes admittedly only very
recently where instead of it being
basically more profitable for a dentist
to
do nhs care on things like extraction or
or cleaning of teeth rather than perhaps
some of the more complicated elements we
need to make sure that uh
more dentists are offering that nhs
provision i think there are some further
features that in a dental practice
making sure that people who are
qualified uh to the to use them to the
full extent of their qualification in
order to undertake uh particular sorts
of um procedures so for example you will
have people
who want uh if you like full dentists
but they are dentists who are trained as
technicians and they can are trained to
be able to undertake uh care of children
so there's different levels that we need
to continue to go into detail but i
think practice by practice i'm going to
have to work with the nhs locally a lot
more in order to unveil that opportunity
uh obviously um
we have many colleagues who want to
contribute to this statement and if
we're to get everybody in it requires
brevity please steve bryan
speaker and i warmly welcome her to her
role and i wish all the best with it can
i just touch on cancer with her uh
predecessor talked about a new cancer
agenda
is that in the offing can she give us
any indication about that and will it be
accompanied by a genuine cancer
workforce plan will it involve
um what the former public health
minister rightly mentioned around
prevention in respect to obesity our
second biggest cause of cancer in this
country and obviously smoking our
biggest preventable cause of
death in this country
well i thank my uh honorable friend and
the prime minister said at this patch
box that we will be uh
proceeding with the cancer plan uh the
other plans of course i will be looking
at carefully with my uh colleagues uh
and indeed uh the
my honourable friend has agreed to meet
um my honourable friend uh in order to
talk this through further
so stephen timms
speaker i congratulate the secretary of
state will miss her visit to the working
pension select committee i welcome her
re-commitment
i welcome her recommitment to the
four-hour a e waiting time target i
think she's right about the importance
of that she mentioned in her statement
the nhs forthcoming nhs workforce plan
when does she expect to be able to
publish that plan
as i said tomorrow's honorable friend
and i thank uh the honourable right
honourable gentleman for his warm
welcome um of course i will miss uh uh
the our interaction and uh in dwp um i
think uh as my predecessors have
committed to
conclusions of the plan to be uh
published i am still looking into this
particular matter and we need to still
uh finalize it and develop it
heather wheeler thank you very much much
madame dr speaker i welcome my right
honourable friend to her two new jobs
absolutely excellent um on behalf of the
south derbyshire residents she may not
know but a seventh of all of the new
houses that were built in england were
built in south derbyshire last year can
she please use south derbyshire as a
pilot for rolling out more gp services
and more dental services
well i thank my honourable friend uh and
i appreciate her warm welcome to me in
terms of um i mean the house will be
aware
that in effect gps and indeed dentists
are private they're independent uh
practitioners and but it is important
we've already seen reasonably good
success with the nhs on getting
a primary care in terms of uh um sorry
uh doctors into many of our um uh wider
right across the country i think there's
a lot more to be done on dental care
daisy cooper
deputy speaker this isn't a plan this is
an abc of conservative failures
gps are now seeing almost 12 percent
more patients than they were just five
years ago the gp sector is facing a
retirement time bomb and one in five
patients can only see a gp for less than
five minutes patients need to have more
fully qualified gps the government set
itself a target of 6000 by 2024. has it
now just given up
no
sir edward lee
it's it's not the fault
of successive conservative secretaries
of state but every time they come with a
player forward with a plan the queues
just get longer the nhl nhs ask for more
resources and more people have to be
imported from abroad the fort is with a
system
the last example of collective planning
and socialist central control and ever
more targets like today it simply
doesn't work
well the secretary of state the
conservative secretary of state have an
open mind to looking at the social
insurance systems of france germany and
italy
well they can mock but frankly the
health outcomes in these countries are
far superior than ours
people have fed up with paying all their
life and being the end of the queue it
shouldn't just be the rich who can
access private health care
i understand why my writing will friend
makes the point recognising that many
other countries in europe uh have that
approach however that is not the
approach we are going to take under this
government yeah
jim warren thank you madam deputy
speaker my constituents face intolerable
delays in a e or for an appointment or
referral for mental health treatment for
an ambulance those who work in the nhs
face plummeting morale effective pay
cuts and staff shortages and her
response
is to aspire
to a gp waiting time which is seven
times longer than labour actually
achieved isn't it the case that the nhs
is not has not been and never can be
safe and tory had yeah
i don't agree with the honorable lady at
all
james morris
thank you madam speaker can i welcome
the secretary of state to her place
and as she considers her priorities
would she agree with me that we still
need to focus on early intervention and
particularly commending the program the
start to life program which is designed
to help young mothers in family hubs
that we shouldn't lose sight of that
priority we shouldn't lose sight of that
priority as she tackles the other issues
of the nhs
well i'd like to thank my honourable
friend and indeed for the um what he
undertook as uh minister in the uh
health and social care department
i'm conscious that the important care
and i'd be very happy to
welcome him indeed with my right
honourable friend um uh who has
contacted me today to undertake such a
such a care in order to make sure that
we do have important provisions not just
in the emergency
services that we have but also as he
rightly points out some of the clinical
care which needs
an extended intervention to make sure
that we get proper care overall
karen buck
for some years now and at any given time
my local hospital has the equivalent of
around one ward of patients who cannot
be discharged because of the lack of
social care for them london has the
largest shortfall of care workers of any
region in the country it is september we
are on the edge of winter how will her
plan ensure that local authorities are
able to meet the pay and conditions
expectations in order to fulfill that
shortfall of care workers and get our
hospitals able to concentrate on new
patients as they should
well madam deputy speaker that one of
the reasons i've decided to diagnose and
affect what is happening care by care is
really important um but nevertheless
more generally of course i'll be
inviting the 500 million pound care fund
in order to make sure this uh this
matter happens
um it may be helpful if i explain that
i'm trying to
call people in this statement who
perhaps didn't get in the last statement
first and silane saxby thank you madam
deputy speaker
north devon has a more elderly than
average population with very low
unemployment whilst warmly welcoming my
right honourable friends plan for
patience please can she detail how we
can recruit the numerous vacancies we
have in dentistry pharmacy nursing and
social care especially given the lack of
affordable housing available mostly
driven by the surgeon holiday let's and
second homes
well father thank you madam deputy
speaker and i can assure the honourable
lady that she will be uh hearing from i
see the local nhs in order to make these
functions happen
diane abbott
i'd like to welcome the secretary of
state to her new role i heard the
secretary of state say earlier that she
wants to encourage people to go into
social care does she appreciate that the
main thing discouraging people from
going into social care is the very low
wages and this is a particular issue at
a time of a cost of living crisis
well madame deputy speaker this will
vary according to the provision that's
been there and i'm sure that she will
want to be
careful
um and absolutely um uh considerate in
how she addresses the local nhs in order
to tackling those patients who don't
need to be in hospital today in order to
how we help them uh with some of the uh
features that they enjoy
dr andrew morrison welcome the statement
does but does my right horrible friend
agree with me that they were terribly
grateful to people from overseas who are
among the very best and kindest and most
compassionate of carers we must ensure
that we grow our indigenous workforce
and to do so there has to be financially
competitive for them to work in the care
sector there must be a professional
career structure open to them otherwise
we're not going to make any inroads into
the 13 and a half thousand beds that are
occupied at the moment by people who
must not be in hospital who need to be
in homey settings in the community and
ambulances will continue
to queue round the block and frail
elderly people will not get the care
that they are entitled to
well my right-hand friend is right to
consider this in a broader scale but of
course with the local nhs we will be uh
focusing on that there are certainly
different parts around the country where
there isn't the same provision of where
discharges are not happening to that
capacity meanwhile we have some parts of
the country where they are extraordinary
amounts and that's what we need to focus
on locally
cloud best
thank you madam deputy speaker
yesterday the county council's network
produced a statement which simply said
there is a crisis in social care
uh it echoed the findings of the
leveling up select committee
so the 500 million pound
announcement by secretary is welcome but
all it does is replace the funding
stream that was cut in april to do
exactly the same job yeah so so where
does the secret state go to recognize
the enormous financial gap that councils
are facing and the poverty pay that is
not attracting care workers into the
sector and actually come forward with a
real policy if she wants the money how
not go ahead why not go ahead with the
cut incorporation tax and use that
funding for real benefits for people in
social care yeah
well madame deputy speaker that will
work dependently on local areas and uh
unconscious that he as
as the chair of the select committee to
take a broad brush but i think it's
important that we have a local nhs to
achieve that ruth edwards
you welcome my right honourable friends
statement and it's been great to see how
elective surgery hubs around the country
are helping to tackle the backlog
however we are yet to have one in
nottinghamshire so could i ask my right
honourable friends to look kindly on
nottinghamshire's bid
for a new elective surgery hub and would
she meet with me to hear the many merits
of its case
well my honor friend is right to
appreciate that i think it's fair to say
we haven't um uh responded that um but i
know that my honorable ministers will be
taken advantage of that very nearly soon
judas cummins thank you madam deputy
speaker and can i welcome secretary of
state to her new role
but with nine out of ten dental
practices in england not accepting new
nhs patients and with over 2 000
dentists leaving the nhs in the last
year alone nhs dentistry is in crisis so
whilst today's small changes alongside
the minor tweaks announced back in july
are welcome they are underwhelming given
the scale of the crisis so when will the
secretary of state complete the full
contract reform with prevention at its
heart so my constituents can access an
nhs dentist when they need to here
well the older lady is absolutely right
and i completely agree with her it is a
real problem
um we've started doing some changes
already and we need to do that in more
detail right across the country but my
honourable friend the minister will be
looking into that more intensively
mark harper thank you very much madam
deputy speaker
in gloucestershire uh the lack of
ability to discharge people from
hospital because of inadequate social
care is the primary reason why we have
ambulances queuing so i welcome the
adult social care discharge fund that
the secretary of state has announced can
she set out how the 500 million pounds
is going to be allocated so
gloucestershire's local nhs will know
how much it can expect so that it can
work with gloucestershire county council
to improve matters for my constituents
well my right honourable friend is
correct to raise this i think it's fair
to say uh madame deputy speaker that we
will still be working in detail on where
that will be allocated right across the
country
deputy speaker 41 of my constituents
with a cancer diagnosis are now waiting
for more than two months for their first
treatment for that cancer we know that
every four weeks that people wait with a
diagnosis for treatment they have a 10
reduction in their chance of surviving
it so this is killing my constituents
every single day there are quick fixes
that are sustainable that could make a
difference and one of them is
radiotherapy an investment in
radiotherapy up front now would she
agree to meet with me and the all-party
parliamentary group on radiotherapy and
key clinicians so we can help her to get
to the grips of this problem and save my
constituents lives
well i'd like to thank the honourable
gentleman my um the minister for primary
care my honorable friend will be meeting
you
james cartridge
uh speaker i warmly welcome my
constituency neighbour to her new dual
role uh i'm very great for her statement
and particularly her commitment to work
closely with the independent sector
she'll be aware figures show that as
many as one in 10 adults
in england have used the private sector
in the past 12 months does she agree
without them waiting this will be even
higher and will she therefore consider
the reintroduction of tax relief on
private medical insurance first
introduced by ken clark in 1989 and
scrapped by the party opposite
well my honourable friend this is great
to see him and of course uh we uh across
each other across the river uh revered
eben and uh i will look into that for
him and uh respond to him
kate green
deputy speaker the secretary of state
spoke both about the importance of
prevention and also about the impact of
the cost of living crisis on health and
well-being so will she therefore work
with colleagues across government
including dwp and local authorities to
maximize take-up of healthy start a
scheme that can address both maternal
and child health and well-being and help
families with living costs
of course we will madame thank you
speaker helen waitley thank you mr
speaker can i welcome my right
honourable friend's statement
particularly her focus on access to gps
on tackling ambulance weights and her
recognition the importance of social
care including the 500 million pound
discharge fund could she also assure me
that she will be taking forward our
reforms to social care not only the cap
on social care costs but also increasing
the scrutiny on care at a local level to
drive up quality and make sure care
workers are paid fairly
well i appreciate um the uh requests
from my honourable friend um it is
important that we get through this it
will be done on a local level i cannot
to specifically say when that will be uh
but i know that in kent in particular
there's a lot of work still to be done
iran
two weeks to see your gp frankly madam
deputy speaker
is that a target or a joke and i know
how many of my constituents will see it
surely the health sector will understand
we must first address the
underlying rampant health inequalities
that exist in many of our cities and in
that regard i ask her to therefore lend
her support to bradford's leveling up
bid for 20 million for a grassroots
transformational community-led
health centers that will make sure that
we make a real difference to health
inequalities in our district yeah
well i'm not aware specifically about
bradford itself we're still at a very
early stage of going through that data
and analysis but of course i expect the
local hs to work carefully uh with uh
local gps in order to make sure that we
do get people um who need care to
receive it
andrew salute thank you very much
speaker will the secretary of state meet
with me and other members no doubt
including the member for south
derbyshire who face particular
difficulties over access to general
practice as a result of tens of
thousands of new houses which have been
built with more coming without the
commensurate increase in general
practice capacity
well i'm i know that my honourable
friend has been a concern for this for
some time as i've set out there is a
situation where gps in effect or
independent uh uh employers uh sorry
independent and we cannot force people
to be in a particular part of the
country however i know that the nhs has
been working to try and target and bring
uh doctors into places where there
aren't that many uh
other doctors and i know that my
honourable friend the minister for
primary care would be happy to meet you
paula marcus
thank you madam deputy speaker i think
anyone marking the secretary of state's
abcd homework will give her an f
an f for failing as nothing we have
heard today actually addresses the
biggest threat to our nhs
which is the workforce crisis the
shortage of doctors nurses and care
workers is compromising patient safety
and driving morale through the floor so
can the secretary of state explain why
the government is yet again failing to
address this and why she has said today
she's talked about volunteers and medics
coming out of retirement surely the
government should be investing in a
proper workforce strategy and also
increasing the amount of people going
through training
you already are
rob halford
thank you very much madam deputy speaker
i strongly welcome these statements and
congratulate the
uh the secretary of state
and she will be aware that uh princess
alexandra hospital has amongst the
highest any uh per head in in england
and that we are in the first wave of the
of the new hospital programme and will
she set out the timing of the new
hospital program
um will she meet with me and my
neighbouring mps
um one of them who is in the speaker
speakers chair at the moment
um to discuss the hospital program and
just set out the timetable so she can
assure residents of harlow
well i'm sure that my right humble
friend would be happy to meet on this
particular occasion and to investigate
this but it's important that ministers
get on with the different uh uh creation
of new uh both diagnostic centers and
hospitals and i intend to work frankly
at project speed in order to make sure
we get these uh
these hospitals right across the country
underway
juanira wilson
deputy speaker over the past year
i've witnessed a seven-year-old having
to be locked in a classroom because they
were a danger to other pupils and heard
from the mother of a nine-year-old who
hospitalized their sister
they along with thousands of other
children across the country struggling
with their mental health are languishing
on waiting lists for months if not years
so frankly when secretary of state says
this government will be on your side
when you need care the most
those words are meaningless to the
parents that come to my constituency
surgery week in week out
will she give them hope and make
children young people's mental health a
priority for this government
the prime minister set out uh during the
summer that uh she intends to make sure
that there are mental health uh
practitioners available
both in uh in local gp practices uh
covering that but also in in
schools as well
bob seeley
i welcome the minister's priorities on
gp appointments pharmacies and dentistry
they're important for islanders may i
please make her aware of the specific
needs of what her department calls
unavoidably small hospitals 12 in
england and wales covering 20
constituencies mainly on this side of
the house of which saint mary's is the
most isolated we've done good work on
improving funding but there is more to
be done to ensure fairness and equality
so will she or her ministers meet with
me and other honorable and right
honourable members to discuss what more
can be done to ensure support for these
small hospitals which are so important
for our communities thank you
well madame deputy speaker i think it's
in um the isle of wight where there is a
particularly difficult um
challenge where there are many patients
still in hospital who don't need to be
um i know that the i've asked the local
nhs to start working with the council on
how we can get that discharge going
and i know how important it is to make
sure that the hospital itself can
function uh readily
john trickett thank you very much and
they this year uh i myself and two
members of my family have been in acute
care
in local four great yorkshire hospitals
acute hospitals
in many account encounters with staff
who i thank deeply for the work they've
done
uh it was clear that they are
universally wonderful but that the
system is under stress
and they were emphasizing to me two
basic principles of the nhs first
that
nobody should make a profit from another
person's illness
and secondly the speed of treatment
should be directly related to the
gravity of your illness and not the size
of your wallet will she confirm that she
stands by those two principles and
finally
when will they get a rise
well
gps dentists pharmacists they're all
independent contractors and it's up to
them on how they best manage and help
patients i'm setting clear expectations
on that furthermore when it comes to uh
pay up for people in the nhs i've access
we have accepted as a government the
independent pay review body and that's
what we will be doing
stephen metcalf thank you madam deputy
speaker and can i thank my right
honourable friend for her excellent uh
statement and her focus on the abcd
but none of that will be delivered
without e which is effort and the effort
that our vital nurses put in to keeping
the nhs uh rolling and will be vital in
delivering on her plan will she join me
in thanking them and encourage them to
get behind this plan as soon as possible
well i thank my honourable friend and i
agree and it's uh we will as part of
this national endeavor you know
recognizing that after the pandemic
there's still significant issues to
address we accept that and that's why as
i say the national endeavor is really
important why we want people to help and
also that's why we've extended some of
the measures that we had during covid
we've extended them for a further two
years so that we can make sure people
can come back more readily to help the
nhs and it's important that we restrain
every sinew in order to make it happen
um just before we proceed it will be
obvious to everyone present that uh the
secretary of state has now been at the
dispatch box for an hour
normally uh statements run for an hour
i'm going to let this run a little more
than an hour but i give notice now that
not everybody who wishes to speak is
going to have an opportunity to take
part in this statement it simply isn't
practical so i say two things if you're
not very
enthusiastic then go now and then you'll
save up your brownie points for tomorrow
and the next day um and secondly
the briefer the questions are uh then
the more people will get in and i have
noticed that the secretary of state has
played the game by giving some very
brief answers thank you
um margaret greenwood
thank you very much
speaker i note the secretary of state's
comments about hospital discharge now
through the health and care act 2022 the
government legislated for a process
known as discharge to assess as she'll
know whereby people's social care needs
assessments can take place after they've
been discharged from hospital rather
than before it's a model that's been
going on since uh under the corona virus
act but when i asked the government in
may of last year what assessment they
had made of the number of those patients
who were readmitted within 30 days i was
told that the government didn't hold the
data centrally it's vital the government
understands the clinical outcome of this
policy so will she please commit to
gathering and publishing that data
i hear what the lady says but i'm not
going to be going into specifically more
data i've set out approach that we will
undertake particularly looking at the
local nhs with local councils uh to make
sure we get discharges more effectively
dr ben spencer thank you uh madame
deputy speaker and i welcome the
announcement today for my wife's rumble
friend uh healthcare providers in really
medium weighbridge tell me the biggest
challenge they face recruitment and
attention and driving that is staff
being poached by london london can offer
london waiting yet we face
equal if not sometimes higher living
costs would my rightful friend agree
with me that the nhs needs more
flexibility when setting staff from
immigration and will this form past the
measures she'll announce in the upcoming
expanding workforce plan
well um i thank my honourable friend i
i'm conscious that there is london
waiting um but i think it is up to the
local nhs
to make decisions and nhs trusts on how
they reward and encourage people to be
participating in their hospitals
thank you very much madam deputy speaker
under the last labour government
patients were guaranteed a gp
appointment within 48 hours but the
conservatives came into power and
scrapped that standard i think it's all
part of the managed decline of our nhs
because after 12 years gp numbers are
down more than 300 gp practices have
closed since 2019 alone and many of my
constituents cannot get a gp appointment
when they want one so does the secretary
of state agree with me that the 2019
tory manifesto promise of delivering an
extra 15 million gp appointments and
over 6 000 more gps isn't worth the
paper that it's written on
we're actually on track with the getting
the extra million uh 50 million
appointments already
speaker and i welcome the statement
today um the majority of gps 75 now work
part-time now that's an understandable
choice for them but we need to be honest
about the impact that this is having on
availability of appointments and also on
costs of training will my right friend
look at what she can do to address the
barriers to more gps working full-time
well one of the ways is about um you
know it's a choice for gps on whether
they work part-time or full-time uh but
i'm conscious that some of the different
things that we're doing on changing and
pension flexibilities should help as
well as diverting people requiring them
not to have to go to gp appointments but
could do things whether it's through
pharmacy and other approaches as well
charlotte nichols thank you madam deputy
speaker this morning i met with the
warrington and holton nhs trust
regarding their bid for a new hospital
in warrington which is desperately
overdue
our bid is through to the final stages
of the government's tendering process
but there is concern that timetables are
increasingly slipping putting the bid at
risk and driving delays in treatment due
to facilities that aren't fit for the
need we have locally despite the best
efforts of our nhs staff
can the secretary of state please
therefore confirm that the government
still intends to honor the previous
government's plans for new hospitals and
that these decisions will be made
without further delay
well
deputy speaker of course uh we're still
considering all the proposals coming
through the different business cases and
uh we will respond in two calls
deputy speaker and i welcome the
secretary of state statement the nhs in
cornwall faces a unique set of
circumstances through being a rural
peninsula an aging population but also
the impact of tourism means that in
terms of pressure on the nhs it is
always winter in cornwall can i ask the
secretary of state does she recognize
the unique challenges that we face in
cornwall and would she or one of her
ministers meet with me and other corner
champions at the earliest opportunity to
discuss what support we can give to the
nhs not just to get through this winter
but ahead of the summer season next year
well my um my honourable friend our
right honourable friend the minister for
secondary care will be visiting cornwall
to meet the ambulance trust and indeed
the trust more broadly
last month
my constituent alan suther phone 999 at
seven in the evening
his wife had suffered a stroke
he knew the signs face arm speech
time
the urgency of medical care
that care arrived five hours later at
one o'clock in the morning
the health secretary can make all the
ambitions and expectations and targets
that she likes but does she agree
that she will not have the human
resource to achieve them unless she
addresses the workforce strategy and 132
000 vacancies that currently exist in
the nhs
um i am sad and concerned to hear about
the cases just mentioned it is
unacceptable but i've already set out to
the house today
aspects of how to improve ambulance
responses and it's my intention that
will be delivered right across the
country
dr james davis
i welcome this plan for patients which
recognizes the importance of data within
the nhs in england
my right honourable friend will be aware
of extreme concern over the state of the
nhs in north wales so will she affirm
her commitment to uk wide comparable and
interoperable data within the nhs and
the potential for the data protection
and digital information bill to bring
this about
well my i thank my honorable friend who
is a practicing gp and very committed to
his constituents as the mp as well um i
think it's fair to say he will recognise
that the nhs in wales is run by the
labour government there however he is
right to point out that it's important
that we work across the united kingdom
by sharing information by putting
patients first and we will continue to
work to try and make sure that happens
i was about to draw mattis to
close it being 17 minutes past two but
um i appreciate that the opposition
front bench might point out that the
people for the next debate are not yet
present
so
therefore i will extend the statement
for a very short while while i should
note that it's not very good practice
not to be here
barbara keeley
constituent put it to me and not being
able to get a gp appointment it seems
there are too many patients and not
enough doctors and this has gotten worse
over the last few years now my
constituents can grasp the workforce
issues but not secretary of state it
seems and i agree with my honourable
friend from world south he's deeply
worrying that the new secretary of state
did not mention pay of care stuff when
that is the crucial issue to tackle the
160 000 vacancies in the care sector so
can you tell me why is the government
choosing not to tackle the shortage of
doctors nurses and care staff which is
leading to such long wait times for my
constituents
well we are getting more clinicians
doctors and nurses into the nhs and i
already shared with the house the
approach on care
justin tomlinson
speaker i welcome the greater use of
pharmacists to ease pressure on gps
however for patient safety with ongoing
treatment it is essential gps can see
what has been subscribed to the pharmacy
module on the gp system which at present
community pharmacists do not have access
will the secretary of state unlock this
i thank my honourable friend and yes i
will ask one of my ministers to look
into that particular issue
lisa cameron
thank you madam deputy speaker and i
welcome the health secretary to her
place as chair of the health all-party
parliamentary group i've been hearing
from people right across the united
kingdom that it's face-to-face
appointments with gps that are really
required and being on the telephone
zoom appointments particularly for very
clinically sensitive issues mental
health issues and for people with autism
who find it very difficult to speak
through those modes of communication can
she reassure the house that face-to-face
appointments will be a priority going
forward
well i think the honorable lady but um i
trust
i trust doctors to have that a
relationship with their patients
directly rather than me prescribing or
mandating a particular approach
what i think will happen with the
transparency the publication of what
this data is that gradually more and
more we can see that but it's important
that i don't directly uh say that xyz
has to be seen by a doctor it really
matters for the clinical need
peter oldest thank you very much madam
deputy speaker it is welcome that d is
for dentists and as a constituency
neighbor my right honourable friend is
very much aware that there is a crisis
in nhs dentistry in suffolk there have
been some improvements and it is welcome
as she has mentioned that work has
started on a new nhs dental contract but
can my right honourable friend confirm
she is committed to root and branch
reform that also includes fair funding a
strategic long-term approach to
recruitment and retention a proper
prevention policy and transparent and
full local accountability
well i thank my honorable friend and
he's right and i think in lowestoff in
particular there has been increasing
provision um in his constituency
meanwhile in layston like at the moment
there's not a single uh dental practice
that will take up the opportunity to
provide nhs dental care at the moment so
this does need sorting i accept that
entirely and that's why with the local
nhs we'll be putting the priority on
them um to make sure that we avoid these
dental deserts but in terms of other
aspects of the contract this will
continue to evolve
and now i will draw mattis to a close
with one last question from dan jarvis
thank you very much madam deputy speaker
when someone has cancer every day is an
emergency in western park cancer center
in sheffield do outstanding work
treating patients not just from my
region but from white around the country
i've been grateful for the engagement of
previous secretary of state and other
ministers with regard to skewing the
investment needed for the urgent
refurbishment of western park will the
secretary of state give me an
undertaking that she'll continue along
with her ministers to work with me to do
everything that we can to continue to
support western park in their important
work
well i thank the honorable gentleman i
don't have specific details about that
but i know that my right honourable
friend would be happy to follow up with
him i am very conscious about the impact
of cancer this is one of the reasons why
instead of just having a 48 hour target
which predominantly be predicted by
emergency
diagnosis by gps i want that broader
target so that people who are showing
symptoms want to go and see their doctor
but are concerned about it
do actually have the opportunity that
they can have that assurance that
they'll be seeing their gp so that
diagnosis can start as quickly as
possible particularly on issues like
cancer
thank you that concludes the statement
um
point of order sir william cash thank
you very much indeed madam deputy
speaker
um
madame definitely speaker the order
paper today
specifically stated that the privileges
committee report relating to the opinion
of lord panic qc
in relation to my volatile friend the
member for oxbridge in south reislip
would be published this morning at 11
a.m
mysteriously it is no longer there
it appears that the report will now not
be available until after the house has
risen tomorrow this would mean
that no opportunity
for members to raise questions in the
house on these serious matters
including the resolution of the house of
march 19 of the 19th of march 1997
could be could be raised until the 11th
of october
given that there are president
precedents for chairs of select
committees to answer questions on the
publication of reports would it not be
in order and necessary for the chair of
the public of the privileges committee
to tell the house what is in the report
and that it will be available tomorrow
in good time before the house rises for
the recess
i
thank the honorable gentleman for his
point of order and i'm sure the whole
house understands
and may well share his concern
um as far as the order paper is
concerned
i am
i am reliably informed that there is in
fact an error in the order paper
and
and that there was not in fact an
expectation of the report being
published at 11 am
today
i am also reliably informed that the
report will be published in due course
i appreciate that the honorable
gentleman has made
further points and stated his
opinion on the matter but he will
understand that
that aspect of
the matter that he has raised is not one
for the chair
i'm sure that the report will be
published
in due course
presentation of bill secretary suella
braverman
economic crime and corporate
transparency bill second reading what
day tomorrow
tomorrow
presentation of bill chancellor of
exchequer
formerly
health and social care levy repeal bill
second reading what day tomorrow
tomorrow
presentation of bill mr secretary rhys
mogg
formally
retained eu law revocation and reform
bill second reading what day tomorrow
thank you
business of the house today motion
minister to move amanda the speaker i
beg to move the business of house today
this motion provides with three hours to
debate the situation in ukraine it then
groups a series of procedural motions to
provide time for a debate of up to one
hour i beg to move
the question is the business of the
house today motion as on the order paper
as well as that opinion say i
of the contrary no
i think the eyes have it the eyes
have it
and so we proceed
to the general
debate i know the minister would like to
other work would like to do something
else
no
sorry take two
the
emotion which is being referred to soto
voci on my right here will be taken
later at the appropriate time
and so
we do now come to the general debate
on the situation in ukraine
i call minister
james heapey to move the motion
thank you madam deputy speaker and this
is a timely debate uh since my right
honourable friend the defense secretary
last updated the house on the 5th of
september the ukrainian army's
counter-offensive has made rapid
progress along three axis west north and
east of kereson
enlightening advances through the
eastern region of harkeef the cities of
isiam and malacca have been liberated
in the east of the harkeev oblast
ukraine has now secured bridgeheads on
the east bank of the oskill river where
russia is attempting to consolidate its
defenses
and most recently the ukrainian
authorities report that a village close
to the eastern city of lishyansk has
been recaptured a significant
achievement
since it means russia no longer has full
control of the hansk region the
self-complaint the self-proclaimed
people's republic
so far keeve says as much as six
thousand square kilometers of territory
has been recaptured russia's forces
withdrew from the region in the face of
the ukrainian advance while a
significant number of troops deserted or
surrendered the withdrawal was anything
but orderly with large quantities of
munitions and ammunition and equipment
abandoned
russian airborne forces have also
suffered substantial losses and fear
being cut off from the main russian
force
as the russian army attempts to
consolidate on a new defensive line poor
logistics mean that their troops are
without food and supplies morale
continues to plummet and the kremlin is
worried about how to stop widespread
desertions madame deputy speaker on day
211 of a five-day operation none of
russia's initial objectives have been
achieved
their attempt to take kiev was fought
with their efforts to weaken nato have
backfired indeed with finland and sweden
joining as a direct result of russia's
aggression against its neighbours the
alliance has never been stronger
not only do russian casualties continue
to climb with an estimated 25 000
russian dead but tens of thousands have
been injured and tens of thousands more
have already deserted russia's war
machine is now severely depleted with
more than three thousand armored and
protected vehicles destroyed more than
400 artillery pieces decimated and
scores of fixed-wing aircraft
helicopters and uavs downed
seven months into this conflict russia
lacks sufficient manpower in the field
to achieve any of its objectives and the
mood of moscow is changing quickly
voices from across russian society are
speaking out against the military
command and making barely veil criticism
of putin himself the reality is ukraine
is winning this is the context in which
we should understand putin's latest
escalation of yesterday
over here
i'm very grateful to him for giving way
and he he turned he spoke about the mood
in moscow we saw
president putin's ludicrous recent
announcements
in which he was
saying any areas that he considered to
be
russia now
he will consider any any attacks on
those to be a an attack that could be
met with a nuclear response will the uh
minister reaffirm uh the
conviction of this house uh that we
won't be bullied by uh president putin
that the ukrainians have our complete
support uh and that whilst uh the if
putin wants uh to bring an end to this
violence you can do so at any moment i
think the minister's got it minister
well thank you manager speaker but the
honourable gentleman is absolutely right
nuclear saber rattling and that is what
it is
it's the act of a desperate man who
knows that this is not going his way and
we will not be deterred from doing what
we've done so successfully for the last
nine months the giveaway
clearly there's a great deal of bluff
and threat and he's trying to break the
alliance between kiev and the west
is the government saying that it is its
belief that this is purely bluff
the honourable gentleman more than
anybody in the house perhaps will know
that the government's exact intelligence
assessment is not something to be shared
in the house but as i've just said to
the previous intervention we believe
that it is saber rattling we believe it
is designed to try to put a wedge
amongst the cohesion of the western
alliance and to deter us from supporting
ukraine at the exact moment when
ukrainian troops seem to have the upper
hand i'll give way i'm grateful
for giving way can i just uh pursue that
a little bit further with him um we've
always known that russia has seen what
we used to call tactical nuclear weapons
as war fighting weapons rather than
strategic
although nato has said they won't be
bullied and truth nato isn't directly
involved in this conflict so what does
he think might happen if they were to
use one of those weapons as a way of
deterring it what does that do to the
alliance's position
i hope the right honourable gentleman
will allow but i'm not going to discuss
nuclear doctrine at the dispatch box
anyway i'm most grateful
in response to the intervention
from the opposition benches about not
being bullied
what discussions is the united kingdom
government having with our american
counterparts
who are saying they want a negotiation
but without specifying what the baseline
of the negotiation is
will we be making it clear the baseline
is that russia has to get out of all
occupied ukraine as the basis for the
negotiation
well the right-honorable gentleman i
suspect knows that we're speaking to our
american counterparts hannah ukrainian
counterparts daily at every level from
the military operational level all the
way through to heads of government um i
think that the uk and the us are
entirely aligned in their view
that this ends on president zielenski's
terms it is for him to define what the
end state is and i have heard nothing
from washington to suggest that that's
not their view too
i'll give away one last time
to the minister
nevertheless would he accept and we
unless we're going to defeat russia in
classical terms which is unlikely
undesirable there has to be an off-ramp
to allow putin to construct a narrative
that will be uh go down well amongst his
population and through the media which
of course he controls it's just not
acceptable to say uh that we can't we m
we cannot offer putin something out of
this which will enable him to save face
and therefore get whatever it is through
with his population
i'm not sure i agree with the right home
gentleman entirely i mean i think that
if putin were looking for an off-ramp
he's had plenty of opportunities to
de-escalate and claim victory at some
points along the route and in the 48
hours immediately following a
mobilization of russian society which is
a clear escalation i'm certainly not
representing his majesty's government
going to stand here and say that he
deserves any further opportunities for
an off-ramp when he has made his
decision on what should come next
uh one last time
mr anderson shocking reports of war
crimes and mass graves discovered in
newly liberated areas of ukraine are
further evidence of the appalling
conduct of russian forces and the need
to hold them to account so can the
minister confirm what support is our
government providing to ukrainian
prosecutors and international efforts
through the international criminal court
to document investigate and prosecute
these crimes
um so madam mr speaker from memory uh
it's the uh canadians who have taken the
lead internationally on this but
ministry of justice are engaged in
supporting their efforts and very
obviously as we work with the ukrainians
and we see evidence of these outrages
through the closeness of our
relationship and the way in which we are
sharing information so freely when we're
finding these these the information is
outrageous we're passing them to the
appropriate international bodies to make
sure that they are prosecuted um madame
deputy speaker mr putin vladimir putin
has been forced i would like to make
some progress if i may but i'll come to
amber general later on um madame speaker
president putin has been forced to
announce a pastoral mobilization
breaking his own promises not to
mobilize parts of his population he's
brought in amendments to the criminal
code increasing penalties for desertion
surrender and refusal to fight and he
has agreed to imminent sham referendums
in the donetsk kerason and zapariza
effectively annexing those territories
russia is unlikely to be able to muster
the three hundred thousand mobilized
reservists quickly let alone deploy them
as an effective fighting force indeed
putin's remarks sparked mass panic in
russia yesterday with one-way flights
out of moscow immediately selling out
putin is rattled and his tactics
transparent he is implicitly
acknowledging his heavy losses and his
armed forces inability to achieve any of
their objectives his false narratives
escalatory rhetoric nuclear sable
rattling are all bluntly admissions of
failure
madam deputy speaker it is clear that
putin and his defense minister have
backed themselves into a corner they
have sent tens of thousands of their own
citizens to their deaths ill-equipped
and badly led there now to send hundreds
of thousands more with little training
and no winter uniform into the teeth of
the ukrainian winter against an opponent
that is well motivated well-equipped and
succeeding
neither putin nor shoigu's lies threats
and propaganda can disguise the truth
russian conscripts are going to suffer
horribly for the kremlin's hubris i give
way and then i'll come to you
i thank the minister for giving way uh a
key consideration as russia mobilizes
will be atrocity prevention it will be
essential what will he ask the prime
minister to make atrocity prevention a
matter for the national security
secretariat and ensure that it is at the
very heart of the uk strategy
well
madame speaker i think the the the
straight answer to the onboard lady's
question is that atrocity prevention has
always been at the center of our
strategy by trying to deny the russians
the ability to take ukrainian territory
in order to be able to commit those
atrocities and our priority since
ukrainian territory has been taken is to
give them the means to retake that
territory as quickly as possible so that
they can then get in there and
investigate what's being done we give
way to um gentlemen
uh i'm sure we're getting away and
reinforce uh what the minister has said
i i just want the outlying issue for
human rights as well and all the
atrocities that have taken part in the
occupied territory for instance 400
baptist churches have been destroyed uh
pastors of baptist churches have went
missing they've disappeared they don't
know where they are families have been
displaced
believers have had the move it's an
example of of the
babardi and the violence of the russian
against churches and against the right
to have your freedom of religious belief
as well
so uh madame deputy speaker the old
gentleman is absolutely right and i know
he speaks with real conviction on
matters of freedom of religion um
there is
it is extraordinary to me every day that
we read of a recaptured town or village
to hear what has been happening on our
continent
in 2022 um
it is uh all the motivation we need i
think to keep course and speed and keep
doing what we're doing to support
ukraine so that it can retake its
territory as quickly as possible
i'll give away one last time
to the minister as the kremlin grows
more desperate the disinformation grows
more dishonest
what more can we do to ensure that this
false narrative
which the kremlin is seeking to peddle
namely that there are somehow nato
troops in ukraine that complete
dishonesty that fallacy how can we make
sure that that is
is entirely exposed for the sham that it
is
well madame i think we've been clear
throughout that nato is not an active
participant in this conflict putin tries
to claim that it is daily on russian
television but the reality is that all
that nato has done as an organization
since february is reinforce its eastern
flank in order to guard against
contagion in the conflict um it is
purely a false narrative peddled by
president putin to say anything
otherwise you'll wait for your gentleman
then the honourable lady
will my honorable friend join me in
welcoming the safe return of the
ukrainian prisoners of war including the
five british nationals
we could i absolutely will and i will
place on record uh enormous gratitude to
the ukrainian government for it is they
that negotiated that release um we are
hugely grateful for them to do it to
them for doing so the normal gentleman's
coming as well
um madame deputy speaker in the face
if it's nearly there madam let's figure
i give away one last stop um for that
point on hostages however paul yuri's
family will have found yesterday
incredibly difficult because he did not
come home alive so will he please
reassure me that the government is doing
all they can to hold russian proxies to
account for his murder because it was
exactly that by a state
um madame speaker we certainly are doing
all that we can and if the honourable
lady has any particular concerns i'd be
very happy to meet with her to discuss
them
i'm most grateful just before he winds
up the prime minister
earlier this week reconfirmed the
leadership of the united kingdom across
the western alliance in undertaking that
the british government would maintain
its commitment to supporting ukrainian
government uh with both munitions and
finance is there anything he could add
to her statement to this house before he
finishes to elaborate on what that means
uh madame zika oh that i was approaching
the wind-up of my speech though i will
attempt to accelerate but the detail he
was hoping for is a few pages away we'll
get to it
madam lipsy speaker in the face of such
a responsible language we must show our
resolve ukraine and the international
community will never accept the outcomes
of these referendums the uk alongside
the international community stands
united behind ukraine and will continue
to do all we can to support them russia
must be held to account for its illegal
invasion and continued crimes against
humanity
as we've already discussed madam deputy
speaker the evidence of these crimes
continues to mount within the past week
we've seen the kremlin firing long-range
missiles at harkeef and using missiles
to strike ukraine's second largest
nuclear power power plant at pivden um
yokonensk
we have seen a dam on the inulets river
at crevery attacked on an est for no
ostensible military value and a
psychiatric hospital has been fired on
killing patients and medics in the pine
forests of isian we've once more seen
the appalling evidence of war crimes as
we do seemingly every time russian
troops are driven out of an area
so far the un has verified that at least
5916 civilians have died including sadly
379 children the complete toll is almost
certainly higher and millions more have
been displaced because of putin's
actions meanwhile russia's reckless
behavior around the zaparia nuclear
plant the biggest of its kind in europe
has continued currently all six of the
plants nuclear reactors offline and the
situation remains precarious despite
repair to one of the power plants power
lines which provides vital electricity
to cool the reactors
putin's callous actions are not just
having a devastating effect inside
ukraine russia's weaponization of
ukrainian grain supply has had global
ramifications
undermining food security and causing
rising food prices the brokering of the
black sea grain initiative between the
un and turkey assisted by the uk's
diplomatic efforts is now having an
impact to date some 165 ships bound for
europe the middle east africa and asia
have left ukrainian ports carrying
around 3.7 million tons of food if
you'll forgive i'm going to make
progress um just so i don't test madame
deputy speakers patients this in turn
has precipitated a drop in global food
prices but it is essential that the
current deal is extended beyond its
initial 120 days and it is vital that
russia does not renege on that agreement
unsurprisingly food security is high on
the agenda as world leaders meet at the
united nations general assembly in new
york this week russian aggression is
causing hundreds of millions of people
in the global south to go hungry or even
starve putin must answer for this the
destructive effects of putin's war
underline why it is essential that this
war ends on president zelinski's terms
and why the uk must maintain its
unstinting support the uk is proud to
have been the first european country to
provide weapons to ukraine and to proud
and proud of our efforts to help it
defend itself from land sea and air to
enable our ukrainian friends to better
protect themselves against putin's
brutal use of long-range artillery we
have sent them the multiple launch
rocket system with hundreds of missiles
which can strike targets up to 80
kilometers away with pinpoint accuracy
these continue to have a major impact on
the battlefield and i'd like to place on
record madame deputy speaker uk's thanks
to norway who donated three platforms to
the united kingdom which enabled us to
send more of our own platforms to
ukraine
to date we have also gifted more than 10
000 anti-tank missiles 200 armored
vehicles 2 600 anti-structure munitions
almost a hundred thousand rounds of
artillery ammunition nearly three
million rounds of small arms 28 28 m109
155 millimeter self-propelled artillery
guns 36 l119 105 millimeter light
artillery guns and ammunition 4.5 tons
of plastic explosives maritime brimstone
missiles six stormer air defense armored
fighting vehicles fitted with starstreak
anti-air missiles and hundreds of the
missiles for them and thousands of
integrated air defense systems uncrewed
systems and innovative new electronic
warfare equipment we have also deployed
the british army squadron of challenger
2 tanks to poland to backfill for the
t-72 tanks that poland has donated to
ukraine
the funding i'll make just a little more
progress the funding package we
announced on the 30th of june is being
used to deliver further material
including
more than 100 logistics support vehicles
more armored fighting vehicles a further
600 short range air defense missiles an
additional 30 000 rounds of artillery
ammunition more integrated air defense
systems uncrewed systems and innovative
new electronic warfare equipment and
over 20 000 sets of winter clothing in
all the uk has spent two point three
billion pounds the second largest donor
in the world
there's strong cross-party support for
the assistance which uh the british
government has given
asking now about what the ukrainians
themselves are demanding they're saying
they want longer-range missiles and
they're saying they want more tanks
particularly from germany what is the
government's position on that what uh
what's the government doing to encourage
other countries to respond positively to
these requests
well madame mr speaker uh i speak to my
ukrainian counterpart um each week after
numerous times a week and so too does
the secretary of state and at the
military level they're speaking all the
time we've got a really good
understanding of what the ukrainians and
the reality is it's all of those things
there's a sort of baseline of the
ammunition that keeps them in the fight
tomorrow and the day after and the day
after that and then there's the things
that they need to build a force that's
capable of retaking territory and we're
working on delivering it all not just
ourselves but with our partners around
europe and ukraine will continue to get
all of the support that they need as
they seek to mount their
counter-offensive this autumn and beyond
they give way to the honourable lady
thank the minister it's important to the
war effort in ukraine that ukrainian
culture is seen and appreciated in the
uk it's very very important for them
earlier this year i raised the issue of
the former home secretary of the support
needed to allow musicians from the
ukraine such as the ukrainian freedom
orchestra to perform at the bbc proms
that performance by the musicians that
had fled the war in ukraine was made
possible by a visa fee waiver and
support with visa processing as there is
now uncertainty can the minister discuss
this issue with the home secretary
so that she can confirm that this
essential support will be extended to
other ukrainians looking to enter and
perform in the uk
well matters it's very crime grateful
that the question was we speak to the
home secretary because whilst i've some
expertise in where 152 millimeter
ammunition is manufactured around the
world that is something i hadn't heard
of but i will speak to the home
secretary and come back to her as
quickly as i can
one last
i i thank the minister very much indeed
we all warmly support the
effective military support that's being
given by this country to ukraine but is
the minister addressing the obviously uh
depleting of our own reserves in terms
of missiles that we have available
madam speaker we absolutely are
under the previous prime minister and
under the current one the treasury were
given very clear instructions which
they've been delighted to follow which
is to replace everything that we give on
a new parole deal and we're very
grateful to the chancellors of the
exchequer for agreeing to that
[Music]
provide providing the providing the cash
is very welcome and necessary but isn't
there a fundamental problem with
equipment manufacturer and particularly
supply chain vulnerabilities which
doesn't just apply to the uk and what
steps is the department taking to
mobilize the defense industry and its
supply chain to ensure that those
obstacles are overcome and rapidly for
our to resupply as well as ukraine
so the honourable gentleman is
absolutely right and he's expert in
these matters uh there is certainly the
case that people have depleted their own
stockpiles to support ukraine and as a
result of a profoundly changed global
security situation everybody has
committed more money to defence and that
that whilst great news for the defense
industry in the medium term brings with
it more demand than current
manufacturing capacity can supply but
the former minister for defence
procurement uh who has sadly uh left the
ministry of defense in the latest
reshuffle but is brilliantly replaced um
by the new one is working hard working
hard to make sure that that new uh
was working hard to make sure that that
new uh manufacturing capacity is brought
online as quickly as possible um madame
deputy speaker training is as important
as military hardware here too the uk has
also been in the vanguard busily
establishing a network of camps to train
ten thousand ukrainians this has been
accompanied by specialist armed training
uh across a number of countries in
europe to date we have trained over four
4 700 troops from the armed forces of
ukraine in the uk and our units are
being joined by forces from sweden
finland denmark lithuania canada the
netherlands norway and new zealand our
training offer is already making a
difference to the combat effectiveness
of ukraine and will continue for as long
as ukraine wishes
ukraine has proven its capability to not
just halt the invasion but to roll the
russians back those who contended that
the support provided by the uk and our
international partners were futile have
been proven wrong
but now ukraine needs more support to
get through the winter to push home its
position advantage and recover its
territorial integrity that means helping
ukraine replenish its stockpiles of
equipment and ammunition as well as
servicing its existing kit it means
helping ukraine plug its capabilities
cap and refurbish the equipment captured
in recent offenses it also means making
sure that as temperatures plummet to
minus 20 and below ukrainian soldiers
remain warm well-fed and motivated
whilst russian soldiers freeze without
any concern from their leaders in the
kremlin
at the beginning of august at the
invitation of the danish government the
secretary of state co-chaired a
conference to discuss further support
for ukraine on training equipment and
funding at this conference the defense
secretary announced that the uk would
establish an international fund for
ukraine to ensure the continued supply
of essential military support throughout
2023 last week partner nations met again
to reaffirm our commitment to supporting
ukraine for as long as it takes and to
maintain momentum on planning and
coordinating our continued supports
ukraine throughout the next year in
addition the prime minister speaking at
the un general assembly has pledged that
this government will match or exceed the
2.3 billion support that the uk has
given to ukraine since february this
further cements our leadership
internationally and are resolved to
stand behind ukraine as they retake
their sovereign territory currently
occupied by the russians
so madame deputy speaker it's vital that
we maintain our momentum in support of
ukraine there will be to be those who
given the rising impacts of putin's
weaponization of energy will argue that
we should seek to normalize relations
with the kremlin on putin's terms and
return everything to the way that it was
but we must be honest with the public we
cannot succumb to putin's scare
mongering and the threats of blackmail
this government is doing everything it
can to address the energy crisis and on
wednesday my writing my friend the
business secretary brought forward an
unprecedented package of measures to
address those issues
what we can't do ever
okay
i'm very grateful on that will my uh
right honorable friend make very very
clear that however this war ends that
putin and his henchmen responsible for
this war can never escape from the
sanctions imposed on them personally and
that those responsible for war crimes
however the war ends will be held
responsible for their actions
um i can certainly on the last point
confirm to writer or gentleman that
there is every intention to make sure
that people are held fully to account
for the outrages that they committed or
that were committed in their name and on
his former point around the ongoing
imposition of sanctions against those
who are involved in this happening i
know that colleagues from the foreign
office and the treasury will be keen to
make sure that that is absolutely the
case
what we can't do madame deputy speaker
however is turn back the clock the
consequences of appeasing putin would be
catastrophic not just for ukraine but
for security in the atlantic as a whole
russia would continue to threaten the
prosperity of the uk and its allies and
indeed the entire rules-based
international system nor should we
assume that putin's ambitions would stop
at ukraine if we were to fail to
maintain western resolve putin could
seek to expand his ambitions beyond
ukraine and into nato territory in the
baltics or our other partners and
embolden russia would also mean an
emboldened president xi in china in
other words relaxing our resolve would
make the next 20 years in our planet far
more uncomfortable far more dangerous
and far more expensive
it is therefore to the enormous credit
madam lepty speak of the british public
that in the face of significant personal
financial challenge they continue
overwhelmingly to support the ukrainian
war effort
their support sends a more powerful
message to putin than anything i or any
other minister can say from the dispatch
mocks so make no mistake his majesty's
government will not falter putin's
latest pronouncements will not change
our course we will continue to stand up
for and with ukraine for as long as it
takes we will continue to provide the
ukrainian people with all the support
they need to rid their land of the
russian occupiers
the question is that this house has
considered the situation in ukraine
look pollard
thank you very much madam deputy speaker
and can i start by welcoming the
wonderful news of the release of british
prisoners of war overnight
it is welcome that they are returning
home but we recognize the pain and hurt
of all families involved because not
everyone is returning safely
but can i also welcome the minister's
new job in the cabinet as well uh before
the last reshuffle uh the front bench on
our side said to his that we were hoping
that the defense sector and he would
stay in his positions and they have done
and can i also welcome the new minister
to her place as well um seven months on
from russia's criminal invasion of
ukraine we've now reached a new and
critical phase of the ongoing conflict
we should all be inspired by the
remarkable resilience
of the people of ukraine who have
refused to bow to russia's oppression
and i want to recognize the
extraordinary ukrainian
counter-offensives that have taken place
in recent weeks that the minister has
set out in such detail
madam dr speaker our argument has never
been with the russian people but with
the dictator in the kremlin
overnight we have also seen brave
russian civilians stand up to the
authoritarian state that curbs their
freedom restricts their voice and keeps
the people in poverty while the
oligarchs count their yachts and villas
today there are possibly thousands of
russian civilians in jail
arrested simply for exercising their
human right to protest
just as we have stood with the ukrainian
people against aggression can i make a
special mention of the courage of these
protesters in this house today
i'm dr speaker the horrors of war that
we have seen
in the newly liberated areas remind us
of the atrocities and the pain of which
so many ukrainians have suffered over
the past weeks
i joined the minister in setting out a
very clear determination from this side
of the house that those responsible must
be prosecuted and must be brought to
justice for those hideous war crimes
that we're seeing unfolding
happy too
anyway it's welcome news that a load of
generals and colonels have been
sanctioned and placed in the hague's
waiting room as it were but does he
agree with me we need to go much much
further down the food chain than that
and each and every one of those
individuals involved in these atrocities
need to have their cards marked they
have dishonored the profession of arms
and need to be dealt with sooner or
later
i thank the honourable member for his
intervention and i agree with him i
agree with him anyone who perpetrates
war crimes against civilians must know
that in the 21st century
they will be prosecuted they'll be
followed they will be continued
in the pursuit of justice from the day
they committed that atrocity to the day
they die because we must not leave any
space
any justification or excuse for war
crimes at all anywhere ever and that is
a message that i believe will be sent
felt on both sides of this house for
those people regardless of rank who have
uh persecuted and prosecuted war crimes
against civilians
i'm happy there and i'll come again for
giving way on that point one of my grave
concerns is the prosecution of sexual
violences in conflict and the issue is
that so often you cannot get the
evidence because by the time the
prosecution's come once the shame has
been allowed to be passed open there to
be discussion it is too late to collect
the evidence i'd welcome his thoughts on
a special tribunal formed to collect
evidence and prosecute sexual crimes in
order to ensure that at all conflicts
evidence is collected at the start to
ensure prosecutions at a later stage
well i'm grateful for that intervention
myself and the shadow foreign affairs
minister were in kosovo uh only a few
months ago and witnessed ourselves the
effects of the
horrible
sexual violence that was used as a
weapon of war
and the determination of the
international community then that that
would never be repeated it has been in
conflicts ever since and so we not only
need to make sure that the evidence is
collected
but that those victims are given the
support which they will need for the
rest of their lives in many cases and
that we make clear just as we did make
clear for those people who kill
civilians that using rape and sexual
assault as a weapon of war will not be
uh will not be countenanced and we will
come after those people as well
anyway in the syrian war the russians
and the syrian allies targeted hospitals
as primary targets does he now agree
that it is regrettable at the time we
did not say and do more and that the
international community did not say and
do more to hold responsible those senior
army officers who were responsible for
the deliberate targeting of hospitals
which is one of the most basic breaches
of the geneva conventions
present intervention and i i do tend to
agree with him i think
we as a country
need to take stock of
the freedom that putin has been given
over many years not just in syria not
just in other parts of the country's
bordering his country but in crimea
because the
tactics that they are using
in ukraine now have been perfected over
many years
and the
uh and the space that international
community has given him to do that has
encouraged many of those tactics to be
used so we need to look carefully at how
we stand up for those civilians uh in
the future but we do that by standing
firmly with people of ukraine at this
time i'll make some progress before i
give away again i'm the speaker
i think it is clear that vladimir putin
is a bully
his partial mobilization announcement
along with his sham referendums to
illegally annex large swathes of ukraine
are shameless they're a cynical attempt
to justify a war that has gone badly
wrong for russia we should view partial
mobilization as weakness and attempt to
hide the fact that so far russian
strategy has failed russian weapons have
failed command and control has failed
and none of russia's war objectives have
been met
putin's latest miscalculation will lead
to more russian families
losing their sons
more ukrainians being killed and more
suffering
the mobilized forces sent to ukraine
will be on the receiving end of high-end
western weaponry and a determined and
morally just ukrainian military
defending every inch of their country
in these circumstances the poorly
equipped russian conscripts
facing cold weather is perhaps not
surprising that we are seeing so many
reports of desertion and troops being
willing and willing to fight
and that means putin will our regret
resort to more and more fear to try and
achieve his objectives
cross party support that we're hearing
today for ukraine for the victims of
murder and sexual violence sends a very
powerful message
does he also agree that the next
challenge even though it feels early yet
to be thinking of this is to be
preparing to win the peace
because quite often in the past when
we've left military successes iraq would
be the outstanding example we haven't
laid strong foundations to win the peace
does he agree that we could use our soft
power places like wilton park to hold
conferences with the ukrainians about
what sort of democracy and peace after
this is all over will we be able to help
them create
i thank the all member for his
intervention i agree with him our
commitment has to be long term to the
people of ukraine not only in ensuring
that they win
and putin fails
but making sure that they can rebuild a
nation
that is proudly sovereign proudly
independent safe and secure and able to
stand tall on the international stage
precisely what vladimir putin would fear
the most
and that is what our commitment must be
and i think i share his view that that
is a commitment and a determination that
is cross-party from every single party
in this place
the actions that we are seeing and the
rhetoric we are seeing madame deputy
speaker from vladimir putin are not new
sadly
i agree with the minister when he said
that putin's words on
use of nuclear weapons is saber-rattling
and it is a weakness of his argument
that he is resorting to it
these are the actions of a desperate man
clinging to power
at the helm of a pariah state
his threats should not only be condemned
by every party in our parliament as they
are but by every country and every peace
loving country on this planet his
actions show how desperate he is
he shows how weak he is
and he shows how much he has
miscalculated
and those actions show that he must fail
as well
but speaker we must not downplay the
seriousness of the situation
[Applause]
people at home and abroad having heard
those words are understandably worried
about the gravity of the threats that
have been made by russia
but in this house
we must be careful not to fan the flames
of putin's information war or fake news
i think i speak for everyone in this
place when i say that now is not the
time for the uk to weaken or dilute our
resolve for ukraine but to remember that
at heart putin is a bully and the only
way of standing up to a bully is making
sure that we do so firmly determinely
and that commitment is long-lasting
have you given away that welcome i'm
very grateful to him of course i
completely agree with what he's saying
about ukraine now but of course we could
have been saying this back in 2014
and one of the problems is that we
didn't take this seriously enough in
2014 that emboldened putin and now we
see what we see
but i do worry that sometimes we focus
exclusively on
things that putin says about nuclear
weapons we don't focus enough on the
warfare that he has already engaged in
with this country through cyber
targeting many members of this house and
other and the political establishment in
this country don't we need to do far
more to make sure that we're protecting
ourselves
agree with the uh my honourable friend
and his intervention and i think he has
been a a siren voice that has been
warning this house and warning the
public of putin's actions for a great
many years and what we need to ensure is
that those lessons are learned because
putin has been telling the international
community
what he wants to do for many years
and he has been engaging
in economic warfare
in cyber warfare in disinformation and
political interference for many years
and we need to strengthen all our fronts
if we are to deter that
that type of behavior not only from
russia but from other states that we
should do us harm in the future
the point that my friend from the ronda
made
that that my friend was with me in
kosovo just a couple of months ago where
we heard about a russian disinformation
misinformation hacking center employing
thousands of personnel in serbia do we
not need to also take this fight to
third countries to facilitating russian
uh misinformation distribution hacking
including in ukraine the balkans the
baltics and actually around the world
i think one more friend for that
intervention and he is right the uh the
cyber campaigns against the west against
freedom against democracy are not only
uh contained to bot factories in saint
petersburg they are deliberately being
deployed right around the world through
in many cases attempts to of deniable
cyber warfare but we know that is coming
and we need to make sure that we are
strengthening our own defenses political
military economic and cyber to make sure
that we are doing that because at this
very moment there are probably enormous
numbers of posts and social media feeds
right across britain seeking to spread
misinformation and we must be very alive
to the reasons why they are there
why russia is investing in that
capability and what effect they are
seeking to create in the uh in the uh in
our society
and we must counter it and um i think
that is not only a job for ourselves but
that is also a job for supporting our
allies in doing so as well
um we need a long-term joined up
strategy ma'am deputy speaker because we
know that despite putin's strategic
miscalculation russian aggression will
continue now the government has had
labour's full backing to provide
military support to ukrainian troops and
it will continue to have that we welcome
the new prime minister's confirmation
that this year's military funding for
ukraine will as a minimum be matched
over the next year as well but if i may
we now need to set out a clear strategy
on what the military economic and
diplomatic support for ukraine will be
in the summer the government said that
he would set out a roadmap for do so be
grateful if the minister in concluding
can set out when he expects that to be
published
i appreciate the honourable member
giving way
i wondered if he felt as i do or you
would agree with me that one of the
important aspects of doing that is that
there are great many other eastern
european countries former soviet states
along the russian border who have been
watching very carefully what happens in
ukraine with some trepidation and it's
as important to have a long-term
strategy for ukraine as it is for them
to reassure them of nato's commitment to
to their future
and i'm grateful for intervention and i
agree with the point that she has made
our commitment that we give to our
allies in eastern europe must be
concrete must be long-term and we must
also look at the tactics and the
strategies used by russia in ukraine to
update how we ourselves plan to defend
and deter any aggression because we have
seen with the development of uh pinpoint
accuracy of artillery fire of loitering
munitions that's some of the tactics
that we once thought we would deploy may
need to be updated to make sure that we
can deter any threat and if any threat
pertains into actual military conflict
that we can win in those circumstances
so grateful for her
uh her intervention there
the strategy that i hope the minister
will outline should set up are what i
hope will be a long-term politically
broad support for ukraine in the future
because only a long-term strategy will
reassure our ukrainians and also the
british people that we will stand
unwaveringly with their country but it
will also send that clear message
unmistakable message to the kremlin that
britain will will continue to stand with
ukraine and our nato allies for as long
as it takes to see off russian
aggression not just in ukraine but in
the baltic states in bosnia and kosovo
in the mediterranean and the middle east
in the north atlantic and the high north
and in social media as well and that
does mean that we need to look i think
at the announcement that has been made
by the prime minister in updating the
integrated review
the prime minister's commitment to match
the funding for military assistance to
ukraine next year is welcome but we're
yet to see that action plan that will
give us the detail
but we need to see it in the context of
the uk's wider defense arrangements a
few weeks ago the leader of the
opposition and the shadow defense
secretary visited the british army's
outstanding training program for
ukrainian forces meeting the brave
ukrainian troops who are by now
on the front line fighting in the
donbass having been armed with british
skill
on that training program this is a vital
training program for the ukrainians
which should be expanded extended
throughout next year and beyond if the
ukrainians need it including
cold weather training as well
this week the prime minister also
confirmed the government will update the
integrated review of foreign defence
policy in response to the ongoing
situation in ukraine i welcome this
u-turn this is good news
while labour has been arguing for months
of the need to update our defence plans
20 of our nato allies have already
rebooted their defence plans and
spending since the invasion of ukraine
started in february the decision that
has now been taken
should have been taken based on national
security not based on the conservative
leadership contest but it is a u-turn
that is welcome
labor is ready to contribute and we are
happy supporting the government in
making sure that the next integrated
review corrects the mistakes of the
current one but if we want to pursue the
persistent global engagement that was so
present in the last integrated review
we must not be cutting 10 000 troops
from our army
we must not
and need to look again at scrapping
hercules military transport planes
the plans to cut 10 of the reserves
and a failure to have a war fighting
division able to be contributed to nato
until 2030. an updated integrated review
must also make british industry and our
peacetime defense procurement systems a
major priority
we cannot support ukraine in the long
term or ensure our own uk security when
the mod is on 200 and
of this conflict but has still not yet
proved capable of signing the contract
to produce replacement stocks for the
highly valued n-law anti-tank missiles
the ukrainians are using to defend
against the russians so in summing up
i'll be grateful for the misca set out
when would they expect that contract to
be signed and when will those missiles
be delivered because depleting our
stockpile is not a good strategic answer
i very much agree with what he said but
he also agree with me but it is
absolutely essential but at this crucial
time especially the government does not
make snide remarks about our european
partners because it's very very
important to have a maximum amount of
unity in in opposing what is happening
with regard to russia and ukraine
building our european relations is a key
part of making any integrated foreign
party review work and on this side of
the house we can say very clearly that
our friends across the channel are our
friends they're not our foes there's not
a question mark about it and we stand
with them in the face of russian
aggression
this is not a political game to be
played
when the kremlin can find division
between the allies of the west they will
exploit it and we must stand firmly with
our allies against this
man actually speaker
it would be remiss of me if i did not
mention the armed forces incredible
contribution on display during the lake
queen's state funeral last week and as a
plymouth mp especially i'm proud of the
contribution of forces based across the
south west of england i'd like to put on
record our thanks nissa the house of the
armed forces steadfast dedication to our
country they really have shown the best
of britain and we're incredibly grateful
for the part that they played and
continue to play in supporting ukraine
against russian oppression
and it was an honor today on a
cross-party basis to meet some of the
pool bearers who carried the queen's
coffin finally madam deputy speaker
on this side of the house we are taught
as part of the trade union movement that
unity is strength
that we stand together and we're not
divided
but i would say to the minister on that
side that this is a sentiment that is
now a cross-party one in this place
because it is the strength of
westminster when this party i represent
the government party and every other
party stands together in the face of
such aggression and we will continue to
do so until ukraine is free thank you
boris johnson
[Music]
thank you madam deputy speaker it's
now
seven months since vladimir putin
launched his vile
illegal and unprovoked war against an
innocent european country
and in those seven months his actions
have cost almost as many russian
casualties as was sustained in the whole
10-year russian invasion and occupation
of afghanistan
and if he continues at this rate
it won't be long
or that long before russian losses in
ukraine exceed american losses in the
20-year vietnam conflict and
that is before
we've counted the ukrainian losses
in the last seven months the
catastrophic suffering that putin has
inflicted
on that people the torture systematic
rape mass murder deliberate targeting
time after time
of apartment blocks schools
kindergartens
and hospitals
and in all those seven
months of horror
that this modern moloch has personally
unleashed he has not attained a single
one of his objectives in a war that do
not forget was meant to be over in days
he has not overturned the ukrainian
government
or captured the capital city he hasn't
even secured the donbass
far from it
and instead of coming to terms with the
reality of his mistake i mean his
complete misunderstanding
of what ukraine is and what really
motivates ukrainians which is a simple
love of their country
he's decided to double down
on disaster announced a mobilization of
300 000 more young russians
a move that has caused such panic among
people about to be fed into the meat
grinder of putin's water
that yesterday
in a single day
the price of a one-way air ticket from
moscow
to south africa went up to 50 000
dollars because those potential
conscripts
can see
that what began as a war to rebuild the
soviet empire
has collapsed into a shameful war to
save putin's face
and they have no desire to be sacrificed
on the altar
of his ego at the same time as uh
members from both front ventures have
pointed out he's threatening to hold out
sham that holds sham referendums in
those territories that he has occupied
and then to defend those territories
with every weapon as he says in his
arsenal
in words that he hopes will make our
flesh creep
and we can our resolve
and he will fail in that pitiful blaster
because he can see
and we can see
that he is escalating his rhetoric not
because he's strong as has been said but
because he is weak
he is transparently a problem gambler
who takes more risk not because he is
winning but because he is now terrified
of losing
i'll give way
he did exactly the same of course in
2014 he held a fake referendum in crimea
and unfortunately the will of the west
weakened
how do we make sure that people like
orban in hungary and some of the people
who are preaching
disinformation in italy do not win the
day and we maintain the united strength
of the west in the face of this
uh the right very much for his point and
i will come directly to what happened in
2014 in just a minute but i think he
should not underestimate the continued
unity of the west and i think that is
one of the the signal achievements of
vladimir putin in the last seven months
uh that he has seen a more coherent and
unified uh western light and a stronger
nato uh perhaps than any time in uh in
the last 20 years and if i may just make
some uh some progress madame deputies
because he wanted me to be
within 10 minutes i'll do my best
thanks to the
heroism of the ukrainian armed forces
thanks in part
uh to the uh to the
[Applause]
weapons that
we are
proud to be uh offering i
congratulate my uh right honourable
friend on uh his description of the work
of the uk uh armed forces the the
weapons that we are sending in the the
the huge list
thanks also of course to the
inspirational leadership
of
vladimir putin
as a the interdirectional leadership of
vladimir zolensky uh forgive me uh the
the russian forces have in recent days
been expelled from large parts of the
northeast of the country around kaki
and they are under increasing pressure
in kursan in the south and i have no
doubt
that the
no doubt whatever that the ukrainians
will win
because in the end they have the
inestimable
moral and psychological advantage
of fighting
for their country
in their country
against an enemy that is increasingly
demoralized and confused about what
they're meant to be doing in that
country and what they can hope to
achieve
and at this turning point in the war it
is more vital than ever that we have the
strategic patience to hold our nerve and
ensure that ukrainians succeed
in recapturing uh their territory right
to the borders of february the 24th and
if possible to the
pre-2014 boundaries because that is what
international law demands and uh the
right of gentlemen is correct it was our
collective failure uh to insist on
upholding international law eight years
ago that emboldened putin to launch his
disastrous invasion this year
if putin is going to double down on his
aggression then we must double down in
our defense of the ukrainians and we
must be prepared to give more military
assistance and more economic support and
i
welcome warmly the announcements from
this government uh this week
we must work with our friends and
partners as well as the ukrainians to
ensure that we provide that country with
the long term assurance that they need
on their security and defense that we
have failed so far to provide
in the 31 years since independence
because if anyone has proved the
absolute necessity of those guarantees
it is vladimir putin and his wall
and we must close our ears in the months
ahead to the absolute rubbish he talks
this is not some nuclear standoff
between nato and russia as he seemed to
pretend yesterday this is a war of
aggression by russia
against an innocent neighbor
and we are helping with equipment and
with training as you might help a
neighbor to fight a fire when their
house has been attacked by an arsonist
and we're not nato is not engaged with a
war against russia you were not engaged
in a war
against russia let alone
against the russian people and we're not
concerned here
by the way with regime change in moscow
as
vladimir putin egocentrically likes to
claim
whatever politics may hold for for putin
and may be the subject of an interesting
debate but it is not the issue at stake
there is only one objective and that is
the sovereignty and independence and
freedom of the people of ukraine
that is our objective
and we must acknowledge
that the months ahead will be tough
for ukraine for britain and for the
world
for all the latest
ukrainian successes
putin is still the possessor of almost
20 percent of ukrainian territory
and it may well be
time
time consuming and costly to wiggle him
out
i have no doubt that in the hard winter
months ahead with the price of energy
continuing to inflict hardship on people
in this country and around the world
there will continue to be some
who draw the false conclusion
that the ukrainians must be encouraged
to do a deal to trade
land for peace to
allow russian gas to flow
to europe
even if it were politically possible
for vladimir zelinski or any ukrainian
government
to do such a deal which i very much
doubt
there is absolutely no sign that putin
either wants such a compromise or can be
trusted to deliver it
and
and as i've told that because uh he
would continue to remain in a position
uh when he could uh when he could uh
when he could invade uh that country in
the future as i've told the house many
times before
any such deal or compromise would send a
signal around the world that violence
does pay off the might is right and that
when the going gets tough the great
democracies will not have the stomach to
stick up for freedom
and that is why we have absolutely no
choice but to stay the course
to stay resolute and we should be
confident because
with every week
that goes by our position
gets stronger and putin's position gets
weaker
and though times are tough for families
now we should be in no doubt that this
country has the economic muscle not just
to help people with the cost of energy
caused by putin's war but to put in the
long-term resilience the secure and
independent uk supply including more
nuclear much more uh wind
in the transitional period to use more
of our own hydrocarbons put in water
supply to ensure that we are never
vulnerable to putin's energy blackmail
again
and it's a measure of of of vladimir
putin's gigantic strategic failure
that he's not only united the west
against him
and
the strength of that uh unity is very
very remarkable he and he by the way
encouraged two
hitherto neutral countries sweden and
finland actually to join the nato
alliance which would have been
unthinkable
unthinkable a year ago
he's decisively alienated he's most
valuable western com com customers
from his most important russian exports
oil and gas with incalculable
consequences for his people's economic
future
and if if you
i'll give away thank you for giving away
on this point about economic resilience
does he think that enough was done
during his time as mayor of london and
indeed in this place to deal with the
issue that london has become a
laundromat for dirty russian money
and would he think that there are
lessons that can be learned from that
period that he could share with the
house
i i i'm grateful uh madam deputy speaker
i think you uh the house will agree that
uh since the uh the invasion on february
24th the uk has led the world in
imposing sanctions on
on russia led the world in mobilizing
diplomatic political and military
support uh for the uh for the ukrainians
uh madam deputy speaker and uh i think
that i and i have to say i think that
most most impartial observers and i meet
a lot of them uh around the world uh i
believe that had it not been for the
actions of the uh of the uk government
things might have been uh different and
i think that uh i'm delighted to see uh
the way the uh the the the
administration is continuing uh with the
uh commitments that uh that we began and
i think that the financial commitments
in particular are extremely important
that
if if it if it were not uh
to just to conclude if it were not for
uh putin's
uh inability
to see what is really happening if he
wasn't as it were locked in a in a
windowless uh dungeon uh surrounded by
bodyguards and by
uh and by spies and and sycophants in
the sort of
le bianca of the mind
he would see
the tragedy
that he has unleashed
and he would withdraw from ukraine
before he is pushed out
and he is going to be pushed out madam
deputy speaker
in the last in the last seven months the
sufferings of ukraine have moved the
world
and i know that they've moved everybody
in this house and in this country and we
we grieve for them
and we open our hearts to them
as few other countries have done
we know that thanks to their bravery and
sacrifice their day of freedom is coming
and when that day comes we will rejoice
with ukraine and that rejoicing will
echo
around the world and until that day
comes
this house and this country i am sure
will stand in unshakable support for the
people of ukraine
before i uh call the spokesman for the
snp then uh it will be obvious to the
house that a great many people wish to
speak and we have only two hours left
therefore there will be an immediate
time limit of five minutes on back bench
speeches but not of course for the
spokesman for the snp let's just do up
my dollar yeah i'm grateful i'm grateful
madam deputy speaker i nodded along
in agreement with much of what the
former prime minister had to say
in his speech and i think it's fair to
say that when that february invasion
took place undoubtedly he and his
government in particular
uh the defense administrative defense
team on the front bench today did get
the calls on ukraine right and i think
it's important to acknowledge that i
have to say in his new role as my
warm-up act here in the chamber i think
he'll do well
based on some of those remarks
and i do also want to pay tribute
although i see she's not in her place
right now to the new minister at the
ministry of defence and congratulate
congratulate colleagues who have managed
to stay in position amongst all of the
many changes and wish well the new
security minister
the former chairman of the foreign
affairs committee of which i'm a member
and i think we're in for an addition
various auditions for his replacement as
this debate goes on this afternoon
madame deputy speaker i should also
before i get into the crux of my remarks
draw
the attention of the house to my
register of interests
it was a pleasure just two weeks ago
to be back in ukraine to be back in kiev
with some colleagues whom i hope we will
hear from
uh in the debate this afternoon a
country in a city i've come to know and
love over a few years
now
there this time for
the annual
yes conference yalta european strategy
conference which brings together
civil society political leaders
military leaders academics
people from around europe
to discuss ukrainian and european
security and there were many facets to
that
fascinating set of discussions that we
had
uh over the two days that our delegation
spent there it was also a real pleasure
to be there and meet with members of
ukraine's armed forces who have so
heroically not just fought for their
country
but fought for
what we all stand for and have cherished
since 1945
also and of course the man himself
president vladimir zelinsky who i think
as the former prime minister says
embodies everything that is noble in
europe right now
but here we are seven months on from
this wave of the war which started
in 2014 where we have witnessed a level
of barbarism and butchery
that i think few of us could have
imagined where hospitals
schools
people's homes
have been the targets
we've seen in butcher
and most recently
also some of the most heinous evidence
of some of the most heinous
war crimes
imaginable
i didn't have the opportunity to ask the
former prime minister about his
commitment to treat sexual crimes as war
crimes as any others will he
at least will be across the house um
come together to look at sexual violence
as a war crime like any other
yes we can come together and agree on
that uh madame deputy speaker and i know
that other colleagues will want to touch
on it
i'm sure in great detail but here we are
seven months on from this invasion and
as was mentioned by the former prime
minister much in the world has changed
sweden and finland have
joined nato unity amongst western
countries
is
something like never before and unity in
this house
is something like never before in fact
we can have only partially joked with
our ukrainian counterparts on our recent
visit that supporting ukraine might well
be the only issue that unites this house
and given the
noises coming from the new government i
suspect that will be even more so the
case but it's important that that unity
is maintained and developed in support
of ukraine but back in february the
german federal chancellor olaf schultz
told us
that not just his country but all of
europe
was at a turning point the zeitung
vendor as they say in german and i have
to say that seven months on it feels to
me
less like a turning point
and more like gramski's interregnum
where the old is dying but the new
cannot yet be born we're in a messy flux
at the moment and whilst i think the
unity of purpose that we have
is serving as well to get through the
chum out that we're going through and
that ukraine is going through
i think that there is much of
our own records all of us in this house
and across the west that we need to
assess going back to yes 2014 but also
2008 and i have to say to the former
prime minister also the issue of how
russian money has been treated
in this
country
and i think it takes a lot to admit
where
one gets things wrong and i think it's
only fair that we as
staunch partisans at times give our
opponents the space
to admit that that's easier said than
done
but if the new world that is kind of
incubating in this messy time that we're
living in now
is going to be born then that's the way
in which i think we have to
approach it madame deputy speaker
i think that there's uh
another important point to
make
as the winter bites as energy prices go
through the roof
as what has been called in some quarters
ukraine fatigue perhaps
starts to settle in there is a
particular group of people in society
who i think we need to be mindful of
what the germans call the putin
versteher the putin whisperers those who
would seek to apologize or contextualize
or somehow make excuse for russian
legitimate interests in ukraine they
should be
thoroughly ignored they have been from
the february invasion temporarily
and rather embarrassedly silenced but
undoubtedly undoubtedly they are
starting to rear their heads again
certainly
those people are being fed by putin's
cyber warfare and that we need real
investment from this country and our
allies in counter-offensive material
yes i would agree with that i think the
the right honourable lady is absolutely
spot on
but one of the most insidious messages i
think that comes from that particular
group and they can be found
on the extreme left on the extreme right
they can be found in every country they
can be found in parliaments and national
assemblies they can be found in the
media think tanks and elsewhere but one
of the most insidious things that they
argue is that we should stop arming
ukraine
and i'm sure i speak for everyone who i
was in ukraine with recently
when i say that we could see and hear up
close what a difference arming ukraine
is actually making
and i think that support has to continue
for three main reasons and i'll outline
them and and be as brief as possible
madam deputy speaker
first of all i don't believe it's
possible to negotiate with vladimir
putin i think you can not just look at
his record in ukraine right now but look
at his record in georgia look at his
record in syria
a government that
does such a thing as the double tap
strike the famous double tap strike
where somewhere is hit
and the russian armed forces wait until
the first responders have arrived and
then they hit it
again
i don't think you can negotiate with a
regime
that
carries itself in that way
i think also madam deputy speaker
another important point the former prime
minister says
that
anything that we do going forward has to
be on president zielinski's terms and
he's absolutely right ukrainians don't
want to negotiate with the regime in the
kremlin you only have to look at the
sheer joy on their faces
when ukrainian armed forces turn up in
their towns and in their villages to
liberate them
and save them
from what has been experienced in
butcher or in mario paul
or in her song
the emotional scenes that we have seen
and i'm sure we will continue to see
i think tells us that we've got our
support for ukraine
right and it should put paid to the idea
that we should take these
um
extremists i think that's the only way
to describe them who would seek to divvy
up ukraine on a map
and i would love to hear them tell me
which towns is that they would like to
see handed over to the kremlin
but when we were in ukraine we also met
with a young
a young guy 15 years old and his father
and some of some of you i'm sure will
have some members rather i'm sure will
have read about andrey poxara and his
father who when russians were
surrounding his village
had the bravery and ingenuity to launch
his own drone into the air to take
photographs of russian positions and
send them into the ukrainian armed
forces you can imagine what happened to
those russian positions soon after he's
now back at school studying it was an
honor to meet him but i'd love to see
one of these armchair extremists tell
him
that he should instead have gone out and
negotiated with the russians at the end
of the street imagine what would have
happened had he been caught
they knew the danger but still they did
everything they could to defend not just
their own hometown but their country as
well and lastly
the war isn't just about a war on
territory this is a war on values on
liberalism on democracy and in
sovereignty and on everything that we
have cherished since 1945.
i don't think that's the kind of thing
you can negotiate away lightly so the
putin whisperers must be ignored they
must feel the complete contempt
of those of us who want to see ukraine
win
the war could stop tomorrow if russia
stopped fighting but if ukraine stops
fighting their country will cease to
exist
a russian victory would be a disaster
for everyone in europe and it's
something that we shouldn't even
consider
russian soldiers and now this latest
group of conscripts will be fighting
solely for their wages whilst ukrainian
soldiers fight for their future and for
ours so we do all remain united in this
house ukraine must win we must continue
to support them and it's in that vein i
offer that support to the government
this afternoon
we have an immediate time limit of five
minutes
to buy a sell
thank you very much madam deputy speaker
and can i also pay tribute to our armed
forces and their contribution to those
incredible events that we saw on
television uh play out over the last few
days this is no easy feat and i think we
can salute all our armed forces but also
particularly those paul barrett that did
such a magnificent job
i do believe a worthy way to immortalize
queen elizabeth what she did for our
country our longest service
serving monarch would be to rename all
of our bank holidays the elizabeth day
but that is for another debate another
day but i hope we can return to that can
i say it's an honorable it's a an honor
to uh follow the right on my mortal
friend from uxbridge uh he and i did not
see eye to eye on everything but on the
case
of ukraine
uh i hope
i hope he would recognize that i've
always supported what he has done and
indeed i think the nation can be proud
on all my visits to ukraine the work of
what the britain has done in stepping
forward more so than many other nato
nations is absolutely recognized and
it's thank very much thanks to my right
old friend in leading uh that charge
i want to step back a second from what's
actually happening ukraine and just look
at the bigger picture because we must
ask ourselves a fundamental question i
pose on a regular basis which is
is our world likely to become more
dangerous or less over the next few
years i think the answer is very very
clear it's the former this is not just
about ukraine but a worrying growth in
authoritarianism versus democracy across
the globe and the emergence of a new
alliance it's not so obvious yet but
between russia and china and their
mutual dislike disdain not only for our
international rules based order but for
the west and the united states in
particular they are they are challenging
the status quo that we've enjoyed since
the end of the cold war
we've enjoyed that relative peace if you
like to three decades but we've become
complacent in nurturing our democratic
values and indeed authoritarian states
themselves are becoming bolder
in uh promoting their own agenda more
assertive consequently our world is
becoming more siloed more protectionist
and indeed we've become more risk averse
our actions now
and what we do and how we handle
ukraine given the conflict is now moving
into a darker chapter will determine how
the next decade plays out china is
watching our response very carefully
given that it's got its sights on taiwan
and seven months on from putin's
unprovoked invasion the west i think is
starting to wake up to this reality
state on state aggression is back but
our institutions built to constrain road
act at rogue actors are vulnerable and
new technology has given
autocrats new forms of leverage
the art of conflict itself is
consequently changing not just with
cyber attacks as we mentioned already
but also economic attacks unprecedented
use of international sanctions but all
having global consequences on the way we
do business
do we therefore need to re-look at what
constitutes going to war not least
because we can now destroy other
societies without a single bullet being
fired through the use of cyber for
instance well this is moving into the
area of clout threats of what exactly is
war whether it's simply military on the
battlefield or it's the politics and the
economics and we haven't really woken up
to that because putin is using politics
and economics to harm the rest of europe
with oil and gas and indeed grain and
there's an irony that we have a debate
here uh tomorrow about supporting those
absolutely because of the cost of the
energy crisis that we're facing here
when actually much of the problems that
we have are actually in europe sort
those out and it's a huge step in
helping
us deal with some of the problems loca
local that we're facing here
but i have to say we need to
work more collectively less risk-averse
we get spooked by some of the rhetoric
that comes out from putin and he's done
it again with wanting to go down this
avenue of using nuclear weapons
now i we need to make it very clear and
it's been touched on before russian
doctrine includes includes the use of
tactical nuclear weapons
we need to understand that doctrine the
minister
refused to
answer the question and
others are saying quite right
we need clarity on what our doctrine is
because our doctrine needs to be
confirmed with our allies as well we
could cross a threshold here and
wouldn't necessarily know what to do and
i'm afraid putin has taken advantage of
our risk averseness taken advantage of
the fact that we put red lines in such
as chemical weapons during uh in syria
and we have never not responded now
people can shake their heads as much as
they like this is an awkward
conversation that needs to be had as to
what britain what nato what the united
states will do if a low-yield tactical
nuclear weapon was used in the donbass
region i posed that as a question and we
can take it behind the scenes and not
discuss it and then it'll actually
happen and then we're going to look at
each other and say what do we actually
do
russia needs to know that we are willing
to stand up to what putin is actually
doing otherwise he will continue as will
other adversaries taking advantage of
our collective weakness itself we have
done well to provide the weapons systems
to ukraine to advance in what they're
doing we now need to take further
leverage that ability to push forward as
the right of my moral friend said to
make sure that we can conclude what goes
on in ukraine if we don't put out this
far in ukraine it would spread elsewhere
thank you
stephen
thank you madame deputy speaker i rise
today to pay tribute to the unparalleled
courage and steely determination of the
ukrainian armed forces to condemn the
barbaric imperialism of vladimir putin
and to call on the uk government to go
further and faster in its work to
isolate the kremlin
madam deputy speaker the ukrainian armed
forces have done what nobody thought was
possible their audacious and expertly
executed counter-offensive on the
north-eastern front has seen them take
back in six days what it took russia six
months to conquer and the putin
occupation has become a humiliating
retreat his forces are demoralized and
shambolic
weaknesses that will certainly not be
addressed by calling up a few hundred
thousand extra amateurs
but let's be clear we should never have
allowed things to get to this point for
more than 20 years the west was naive
and complacent in its response to the
authoritarianism and imperialism that
was becoming the dominant worldview in
moscow but the weakness of the reaction
to putin's annexation of crimea in 2014
was particularly unforgivable indeed
it's striking that seven of the russians
who are now subject to british sanctions
were awarded so-called golden visas
after the invasion of crimea
this negligence was based on the deeply
mistaken view that trade should take
precedence over geopolitics and the
utter failure to recognize that if you
give a bully an inch he will always take
a mile
well with a brutal war now taking place
in a country that's just a few hours
from london with our energy bills going
through the roof and with russian
state-sponsored assassinations on the
streets of britain we have truly learned
our lesson the hard way
as director of the british council in
saint petersburg at the time of the
alexander lichinenko poisoning i
witnessed firsthand the iron fist of the
russian federation under putin the
relationship between the uk and russia
had utterly broken down the russian
state had already attempted to close my
office once and my staff were soon being
subjected to terrifying harassment and
intimidation it was utterly chilling but
none of that compares to what our
ukrainian allies are facing now
so whilst it's been heartening to see
the west coming together since the 24th
of february to take a more robust and
resolute position we must go further and
faster more must be done to isolate
russia as this is the only way in which
we'll see the russian people beginning
to turn against the kremlin in
meaningful numbers we must do all that
we can to support those brave anti-war
protesters that we saw on the streets of
moscow and saint petersburg last night
first let's look at the army of lawyers
bankers accountants and estate agents in
london who are doing the kremlin's dirty
work they set up the shell companies
that enable dirty russian money to flow
through our country enriching the
corrupt russian elites who profited
handsomely from the reign of putin and
who are bankrolling his war machine
the government must ensure that the
economic crime bills crime bill closes
these loopholes and closes down the
facilitators who have turned london into
the money laundering capital of the
world
but as the foreign affairs select
committee report of this june pointed
out for sanctions to work enforcement
bodies need teeth currently britain
spends just 0.00 for 2 percent of gdp on
funding economic crime enforcement
bodies so it's unsurprising that money
laundering persecution prosecutions have
dropped by 35 over the past five years
and the british overseas territories are
awash with dirty russian money under the
sanctions and money laundering act 2018
public registers of beneficial ownership
were meant to be in place by the end of
2020
but the new date given is the end of
2023 this is too slow and it is a gift
to putin's cronies
second we were all deeply touched and
inspired by the fact that well over 200
000 households volunteered to host
ukrainians fleeing the horrors of war
but somehow the government managed to
turn this uplifting story of british
generosity into a bureaucratic nightmare
and now as the cost of food and energy
spiral there are real fears that many
ukrainians will be made homeless the
home office and the department for
levelling up must therefore grip this
issue with urgency madam deputy speaker
president zelensky is the leader of the
free world he is on the front line in
the global battle between democracy and
autocracy his people and armed forces
have stood firm and resolute in this
battle and thousands of them have
tragically made the ultimate sacrifice
we owe them a debt of honor and
gratitude that simply must be settled of
course there's an economic cost as putin
will continue to weaponize russia's
energy supplies to europe but you cannot
put a price on freedom
we on these benches that benches
therefore urge the government to
strengthen and intensify its support for
the heroes of ukraine both on and off
the battlefield thank you
dr julian lewis thank you madam deputy
speaker and i begin by congratulating
the three front bench spokesman so far
on the level of eloquence and unanimity
that has been displayed now indeed
studying the depravity of dictators one
quickly understands that
cynicism has no limits and hypocrisy no
boundaries putin likes to draw parallels
with the second world war and there are
indeed parallels to be drawn for example
the false flag operations go back to the
very outbreak of that war on the 31st of
august 1939
hitler would have had it that the war
began because poles attacked a radio
station at glivets on the east german
border they were in fact nazis um
dressed up in polish uniform and they
even left dead bodies of concentration
camp victims as props to that scheme
and it is a sign that uh
these comparisons are insufficiently
accurate or insufficiently
free of hypocrisy that putin doesn't
recognize that what started that war was
stalin's pact with the nazis to divide
up poland between them now this is
necessarily a short debate and it's just
as well because i side with those who do
not think it's a very good idea for us
to be discussing military strategy in an
ongoing campaign on the floor of this
house what we can observe is that a
complicating factor is that in a
dictatorship like putin's russia there
are no mechanisms whereby
a leader who is unethical irresponsible
incompetent and indeed murderous can
constitutionally be removed and that has
to be a factor in our considerations if
it weren't too flippant i'd be tempted
to remark that it's truly a sign of
desperation and indeed substandard
propaganda that a cheerleader for putin
yesterday threatened a nuclear strike on
london if we continue to help ukraine
defend territory that's being illegally
annexed given the extent of the property
portfolios of so many of putin's
oligarchs in the center of this great
city one has to realize that they i
think would have a word or two of
objection to a strategy by russia of
that sort
now
the
beginning of the
invasion
left a few people
thinking that
resistance was likely to be very
successful and indeed resistance
probably would not have been successful
but for the supply of complex weapon
systems which had been done since the
earlier invasion of crimea
as a result we've seen the air arm of
the russians neutralized we've seen the
major surface unit of the russian fleet
in the area sunk we've seen tanks and
other vehicles destroyed and ground
troops decimated the only tactic that
has been left to the russian dictator
has been the physical destruction
usually by long-range artillery of that
territory which they cannot take and
hold
and yes i will of course thank you madam
deputy pick i thank my right honourable
friend
um i totally agree with your comment but
can i i'm quite sure this is happening
but we actually need combat supplies
spare parts
to help to to reinforce because
complex weapon systems
don't they go wrong and yet they need to
be repaired and while we're at it as
we're coming into winter it'll be very
good to provide ukrainian armed forces
with simple little things like face
masks so they can go through the winter
because they probably don't have them
for the first time my right honourable
and gallant friend anticipates my next
but one point so i'll make the next
point first and that is that
the um because the only tactic left is
destruction the area of doubt is how far
putin will go will he simply think that
by escalating destruction suddenly the
ukrainians are going to say we can't
take any more of this we're going to
surrender surely the events of the past
months have shown that any such approach
would be completely
counterproductive the more he behaves
atrociously the stronger the resistance
will be and rightly so
now my right honourable and gallup
friend referred to the supplies that we
give
and of course it is greatly to the
credit of the previous government and
indeed the previous prime minister who
spoke earlier in this debate uh that we
have given such substantial
supplies but in giving those supplies we
have seriously depleted our own stocks
and what i need to hear from the
minister is that a full-scale effort is
being made and will be
increased to ensure that the more we
give
the higher our rate of replacement will
be
because an effort cannot be sustained if
the people who are resisting run out of
supplies finally it would be remiss of
me to conclude any debate about defence
without making a reference to the need
to reach 3
of gdp
we have made progress we now have a
pledge to reach 3
of gdp by 2030.
but
the situation in 2030 is a long way away
and it's longer than the second world
war with which i began we need to reach
it sooner than that
richard ford
thank you madam deputy speaker
the ukrainian liam trotsky said you may
not be interested in war
but war is interested in you leon
trotsky was previously a resident of
mikolayev and odessa
this phrase uttered by trotsky the
communist revolutionary has proven quite
accurate for many people living in these
parts of ukraine in 2022
the liberal democrats must add to the
chorus of condemnation in relation to
putin's nuclear threats
president joe biden said on the eve of
the february invasion
we have no intention of fighting russia
as ukrainian courage and willingness to
resist russia's occupation has grown
so is nato's willingness to supply
materiel to ukraine
and so have ukrainian ambitions grown in
terms of how much of their country can
be de-occupied
putin claimed yesterday that at the
istanbul talks in march this year
ukraine's representatives gave positive
responses to russia's proposals
putin claimed that a peaceful settlement
obviously did not suit the west which is
why after certain compromises were
coordinated kiev was actually ordered to
wreck all these agreements
well we in the uk should state plainly
that kiev's war aims are for keith to
formulate
independent of its friends and allies in
the west
some have said that without nato ukraine
would not prosper militarily in the way
that ukraine appears to be doing
that we in the west need to determine
our own end state our own strategy
and then influence the ukrainians
i would counter that we must make plain
to putin in the wider world that it is
the ukrainian government that is making
all the decisions we need to be
straightforward about the fallacy of
putin's narrative that keeve is
receiving orders from western advisors
as he puts it
putin said yesterday some irresponsible
western politicians are doing more than
just speaking about their plans to
organize the delivery of long-range
offensive weapons to ukraine
he said that washington london and
brussels are openly encouraging kiev to
move the hostilities to our territory
i suggest that it will be simple for the
minister to correct this misinformation
and to state that london has offered our
allies and keeve no encouragement to
strike russia within its own borders
rather we should expose putin's rhetoric
by stating categorically that the uk's
multiple launch rocket system is
supplied on condition that it is not
used to strike anything within russia's
internationally recognized borders
it was mentioned earlier on that uh some
of us from the ukraine all-party
parliamentary group
were hosted in kiev last week by the
yalta european strategy and and i joined
that apbg visit
and like the honourable member for
cardiff south and pennarth and the
honourable member of the isle of wight i
was interviewed on ukrainian television
i offered viewers of preamy tv
reassurance that the change in the uk of
both the head of state and the prime
minister in just a few days
would not disrupt the support that the
uk gives to ukraine
political parties across this house
have united in opposition to putin's
brutal and illegal war of conquest and
the liberal democrats will back those
steps necessary to ensure that the light
of freedom and democracy continues to
burn in kiev
it was striking last week to look into
the eyes of counterpart mps from the
ukrainian parliament the rada
like others on the ukraine appg
i was struck by how those
parliamentarians who we met are fiercely
independent
and would be unwilling to take orders
from anyone whether that be from russia
europe or anywhere else
some members of this house may not be
interested in war
given that war risks being as trotsky
said interested in us i would urge those
colleagues who do have some bearing on
this situation
to stand firm in the face of aggression
and threats
and then
we should hope that ukraine shows
magnanimity in its dealings with russia
so that it may bring this sorry episode
to a close
dr leon fox
deputy speaker
a number of colleagues on both sides
have talked about the seven months of
this conflict in truth it's part of much
longer strategic conflict between putin
and ukraine in fact from 2007 when putin
set out his world view at the munich
security conference we've known roughly
where he's likely to go
from his interference in ukraine in 2004
through the 2008 uh invasion uh of
georgia through the illegal annexation
of crimea this is part of a continuum
i'm afraid a continuum of behavior that
we have for too long overlooked because
it didn't suit us to actually take a
realistic view but this time
as the former prime minister
my right honourable friend so rightly
said putin's aims have completely
clearly explicitly failed and those aims
let's remember were to remove president
zielinski install a puppet government
defeat the ukrainian armed forces and
effectively destroy ukraine as a
functioning state
as a consequence putin is facing
mounting criticism at home and abroad
yesterday alone we saw 1300 arrests in
moscow and we should be giving our
support to those who are willing to make
that protest for their moral courage in
doing so
we've even seen in muscovy consummates
the normally uh placid
news outlet in russia
criticizing what they called the
underestimation of the enemy
that they had suffered a defeat
and that they were
minimizing losses by withdrawing not the
sort of comments we expect to see from
that particular
organ of the state
and the criticism from outside has not
been
confined to the free world
prime minister modi made very clear last
week to putin that this quote is not an
era for war even
the russians themselves had to admit
that the chinese had disquiet about what
was happening in ukraine and little
wonder because what has happened in
ukraine has brought a much more united
west a new focus on areas such as taiwan
which the chinese have certainly not
welcomed and the net result of all this
for putin is that he is cornered
but this is by no means necessarily a
means sell a cause for celebration
in the west
as my honorable friend the member for
isle of wight wrote in a very good
article in the spectator this week which
i would commend to all members
putin makes threats to frighteners
but to minimize the use of a tactical or
strategic nuclear weapon we need to
assume that that threat is in fact real
it may be saber-rattling but it may be
not
we have miscalculated with putin before
we can't afford to miscalculate again he
is a tyrant with a tyrant's behavior
paranoid
petulant and progressively more extreme
he will throw more and more russian
lives into the fire without hesitation
as so many of his predecessors have done
okay which one on the question of
calling up at the reserves does my right
honourable friend think that putin may
now be over extending his support with
the russian people
well madame duffy he may he may be but
we would be foolish to assume that and
yes public opinion even in places like
russia under a regime like putin can
turn yes internal forces can produce a
change
in both the personnel and the nature of
the government but it can take a very
long time if ever and we should not be
calculating on that coming through many
lives may be lost in the interim so as
many members have already said we must
continue to support ukraine and its
government and its people
with moral and political support as the
prime minister set out in new york
provide weapons to the ukraine as long
as they are required and at whatever
cost needs to be paid and we must
maintain a united front with other
allied nations in the free world
especially in our efforts to stop
russia's war machine being funded
through the sale of fossil fuels
and while madam deputy speaker we deal
with ukraine war we must continue to
focus on other threats that are being
posed around the region
we don't have the luxury in security and
foreign policy to choose to focus on one
conflict alone
and i would very briefly point to two
the first is in the balkans where russia
and china have been heavily arming
serbia and where the threat of renewed
conflict
with all the horrors that we saw before
in the ethnic wars there are very real
um and something that we must be alive
to him the second is the involvement of
iran
iran's supply of weapons of drones of
political support to russia at a time
when few other countries have been
willing to do so a country that's trying
to develop its own nuclear weapon and we
have seen
and we've been discussing in this debate
today what nuclear blackmail can look
like does anyone seriously believe that
the world would be a safer place where
iran to become a nuclear weapon state or
that it would be able to disrupt global
fossil fuel supplies any less than
russia would uh madam deputy speaker
in many the common thread running
through much of this is that we have
collectively allowed wishful thinking to
replace critical analysis on far too
many occasions the safety of our world
requires us to do much better in the
future
make quickly
thank you very much yeah madame dr
speaker
i will begin by joining previous
speakers in applauding the harrows and
the sacrifice of ukrainian forces who in
just a few short weeks have liberated
fast ways at saddestly previously
occupied by russia we cannot yet
comprehend the scale of the suffering
that has taken place in russian occupied
ukraine but the widespread reports of
war crimes and crimes against humanity
that are emerging from the liberated
territory serve as a potent reminder of
why putin must not be allowed to succeed
in this criminal endeavor
i also want to pay tribute to the
immense bravery of the thousands of
russian citizens who took to the streets
yesterday in protest of the partial
mobilization of the army reserves yeah
they did so in full knowledge that they
would define the decrees of a regime
that tolerates no descent and i'm sure
that those the thoughts of the whole
house are with those who've been taken
into custody as a as a new and far more
dangerous phrase as the war begins the
uk must remain steadfast in its support
for the struggle of the
ukrainian people but with putin once
again forcing the world to reckon with
the spectator of nuclear war we must
also remain ever vigilant to the dangers
of this conflict conflict escalating as
president biden told the human general
assembly yesterday a nuclear war cannot
be won and must ever be fought and
whilst i welcome the government's
continued commitment to providing
military aid to ukraine i must tell
ministers that their responsibilities to
ukrainian people extend far beyond the
battlefield in the early months and
weeks of the war the government refused
to follow the lead of our european
friends and neighbours and waive visa
requirements for refugees fleeing the
onslaught now
ukrainians who will promise safety and
security in britain are facing an
uncertain future
across the country as many as 50 000
ukrainians could be homeless in the new
year as a result of ministers woeful
failure to bring forward additional
support or even the most basic
clarifier ahead of the initial six-month
sponsorship coming to an end
i've had the great a very very great
privilege of meeting with ukrainian
refugees now living in my constituency
and the families who have opened up
their homes and hearts of them but with
the cost of living crisis hitting hard
i'm afraid that many of these
sponsorships will simply not be
sustainable without additional support
indeed
some local authorities a few down a
quarter of the house are now in position
to extend their guest state beyond the
first six months
councils across the country and i'm
warning that the situation is reaching
breaking points
this was an entire an entirely
foreseeable crisis and it's frankly
unforgivable that ministers have yet to
come forward with a credible plan for
what happens when a refugee initial
six-month stay comes to an end but it's
not too late to act
and so i asked the government to take
whatever steps are necessary to ensure
that in situations where the
relationship between hosts and guests
remain viable that these sponsorships
can that those sponsorships can continue
that must mean greatly increasing
financial support
for hosts as the former refugees
minister lord havington recommended last
month
the governments also need to acknowledge
that the community sponsorship was only
ever intended as a short-term solution
to an immediate crisis to give ukrainian
refugees the longer term support they
need we need to ensure that financial
and logistical support is in place for
the insanity of the three years for
which they receive permission to stay
we also need to do more to support
ukrainian refugees and finding homes of
their own far too many
ukrainian refugees have been left to
fend for themselves in the cruel and
uncaring world of the private rented
sector too many landlords have been
allowed to refuse ukrainian tennessee's
simply because of where they have come
from
unlike many millions of uk residents
before the refugees who have farmed work
are finding that they simply cannot
afford ripoff rents in the areas that i
hope to call home it's time for the
government to equip local authorities
with the financial resources and power
that they need to act as guarantors for
refugees searching for accommodation
madam deputy speaker members on the
government spencer speak regularly on
the pride that's taking the support that
the uk has offered to you off of ukraine
as so adequately demonstrated here
across this house but i warned that
their model obligations will never be
truly fulfilled
unless they can guarantee that not a
single refugee is left without to home
this winter
thank you very much
syrian duncan smith i'm turkey speaker
um i recognize others come speak and
i'll try to be as brief as possible can
i say that first of all that
this
debate today is a very simple debate in
a way because it is ultimately about
the sovereignty independent
and self-determination of the ukrainian
people all else is but a support to that
simple position that we must take and
everything else we do is about that and
the reality is i think as we face it now
back in the 19th century ironically
gladstone made a very simple statement
you should underwrite all that we do in
this when he was speaking about the
attack of then the turkish empire on
moldavia and wallachia he said that
there is no greater bulwark for freedom
than the breasts of free men and women
and that is the truth of where we are
today and what we see with ukraine is
that is happening free men and women
fighting in their homeland for the
defense of their families and of that
freedom that we take for granted and
that freedom is not free and deputy
speaker it comes at a huge price
it comes at a huge price in terms of the
violence and the desperate depredations
that come from war brought about by the
despot putin but it also comes at a huge
price to us
it comes at a price in terms of our
ability to readjust our thinking about
defense spending so that we have the
right equipment in future to be able to
support people doing the same thing it
comes at a big price for us as we face
it now as we go into the winter months
and this has been said previously right
now
president putin is facing uh a disaster
yet in his head and in his actions it's
true that he still believes that he has
one card up his sleeve and that is to be
able to split the alliance as we get
towards winter and it's interesting even
though as india moves away from him and
china is indifferent in a way to where
he is that we have a condemnation of the
un general assembly the other day
he still thinks that if he puts the
pressure on
the west will begin to break now there
is some indication of politicians around
the west feeding this i noticed the
other day senior politicians in italy
talking about why we should reduce the
sanctions because they were hurting us
more than they were hurting him
and there's been talk has been mentioned
in other some eastern european countries
as well he thinks this is working and he
wants to double down then i will make
one small criticism here
i noticed that the ambassador to the un
the u.s ambassador to the u.n linda
thomas
still in her remarks talked about
getting to a process where they can be
negotiation a negotiated settlement i
think that is quite wrong i think any
talk about negotiation feeds putin's
view that he will split the alliance and
i would like to hear from the government
that we categorically believe that the
only person that is capable of ever
talking about that
is in fact vladimir zelinski and not any
of us in any country in the alliance
because all we do is we help putin
and that is the key to all that we do at
the moment
and to get us through and to make sure
that we're stronger surely all of us in
the west united should talk to our own
public about the difficulties that they
are going to face as a result of this
war in the ukraine and our need to
support them despite those difficulties
the cost of living and we're trying to
intervene on at the moment the problems
over energy costs and spikes and the
difficulties they may see with higher
food prices as well we need to be honest
with them and the second bit of honesty
i would say to my right old friend
earlier on i spoke they intervened on
the basis of recognizing and uh my
vulnerable friend mentioned this point
too in his
intervention russia sees
uh nuclear weapons tactical nuclear
weapons as war fighting weapons it's
always been part of their principal view
so instead of dancing around it
sometimes and saying well we're not
going to be scared by rhetoric it's not
rhetoric
because they do believe that to be the
case the question is will they decide to
do it and will the military do it what
we have to recognize our answer to that
is that united we must say
if he ever does that we will continue
regardless to bear down on him
and use the ukraine and just give the
ukraine the equipment and tools that
they deserve if we are clear about that
and clear about the possibilities i
think the public will be with us it's
when we surprise them by trying to say
there's no threat when there is a major
threat that is critical and i think
being honest in this and finally
china is watching
china invaded the south china seas
and not a single thing was done about it
they've militarized it and very little
has been done about it and they're
brutal at home to their own people and
we have done very little about it i
simply say
the rules and the lessons that we learn
from ukraine we should have learned in
the 1930s if you appease dictators who
are hell bent on invasion and
destruction
then you lose the freedoms that we
actually fought for and that is what
this is all about
alan smith
thank you madam deputy speaker uh it's a
pleasure to discuss in this debate and
i've been struck by the thoughtfulness
and decency of a number of comments from
across the house on this point and i'm
proud of the snp's role in these
discussions i'm proud of the fact that
despite our domestic priorities despite
our political differences we have been
able to work with the government and i
would commend the minister when he's
opening speech and i commend the
ministers on their openness and the way
they've worked across the house that's
genuine from our part and damn sure the
snp is part of the international
coalition in defense of ukraine
we believe in freedom we believe in
democracy we believe in human rights and
we believe that we should be good
neighbors who shouldn't live in fear of
bigger powers so of course we are part
of that and where we've agreed with the
uk government we have agreed as a good
friend from glasgow south said on his
contribution on military support and on
sanctions we have been vocal in our
support of the uk government's position
often urging greater efforts than we've
seen but we have supported
the only big difference between our
position and that of the uk government
is on refugees
we would have liked to have seen the uk
emulate the eu's approach of waving
visas for three years we think that
would have been proportionate and fair
instead we saw a system which we have
made work in scotland the scottish
government has made the home office
system work and i would pay tribute to
the many big hearted people across
sterling scotland and the uk have opened
not just their hearts but their homes
to the people of ukraine who really
needed that support at that time
i was in killing just a few weeks back
and i was really struck by the care and
the affection that locals had for the
people who are
guests in our community and i do commend
them on their efforts so it's right
today that we take due stock of events
in ukraine because as we've heard the
conflict is at a pivotal moment
ukraine is winning and the kremlin is
losing
we take no pleasure in that fact but
there is a justice to that aggression is
not successful has not been the results
that the kremlin was hoping for
president putin's statement uh overnight
uh came from a position of weaknesses
with hard his nuclear blackmail his
activation of the reservists promise
breaking a promise that he made comes
from a position of weakness not strength
and we must be vigilant to the true
risks that are presented by the
kremlin's aggression not just against
ukraine but against the liberal
international order
but we must be steadfast in our support
of the ukrainians themselves we need to
redouble our efforts they're winning
but they have not won yet
and i fear there's an awful lot of
heartache ahead of the ukrainians before
we see a resolution to this
so i'm glad to hear as we heard from the
minister that uh military training and
the supply of material and intelligence
support will continue that does so with
snp support wholeheartedly we may have
points of difference and we'll seek
greater information on points but we do
support that very strongly
i'm glad also to hear that the eventual
negotiated outcome because there will be
an eventual negotiated outcome there
always is to every conflict
but i'm glad it's going to be on
ukrainian terms and as a prerequisite
for any talks which as we've heard must
be set from keeve not from anywhere else
the prerequisite must be withdrawal of
all russian occupying forces from all
sovereign ukrainian territory including
of course crimea
so where i say the conflict is far from
over there are a few points which i
would suggest to the government that we
do need to continue and take forward
because we can't take our fruit off the
pedal
we've heard mentioned already ukraine
fatigue amongst the general population
amongst the media as well
we must make sure that we're not
succumbing to it as well ukraine
continues to need our support
so we need to keep sanctions under
review now i'll be taking part for the
smp in this the next coming session
where we'll revisit sanctions but we do
need to keep them under review we do
need to make sure that loopholes are
closed because loopholes are being
exploited and we do need to make sure
that any opportunity to raise pressure
on the kleptocrats is taken so that's an
evolving situation
we also need to be honest and we need to
guard against the influence of dirty
money at home here now
the uk is vulnerable to this and we've
seen a belated start on this from the uk
government with our support but we need
to see much more of it
our financial and property systems are
nowhere near as transparent as they need
to be they are vulnerable to dirty money
the overseas territories are playing a
role that needs greater scrutiny than
they have had and we need to continue
those efforts
so we've seen a related start to that
but we need to see more and i'm looking
after refugees here i mentioned earlier
that people have opened not just their
hearts but their homes they need more
support
we've seen a paper chase of a system
that i don't believe was fit for purpose
but largely people have now negotiated
through that but what we now see is
where we've seen too much paper chase
we're now seeing too little money
and we do strongly support and really
would urge the government to take
forward doubling the payment monthly to
700 pounds a month because energy costs
and the increased cost of having guests
is hurting people and does need to be
taken care of
very helpful
just to pick up on the uh
comments from my vital friend for
training for woodford green
there is a cost to this to the to the uk
people and he was right that we have to
be honest about that and i think the
honourable member is also making that
point but i think we also need to also
reinforce the point there is a cost
there is also a bigger cost to our
constituents if we do nothing and would
he agree with me on that point that we
really need to ensure that people see
that we're doing this for a really for a
much greater reason all these points is
making about refugees are absolutely
right but we're trying to prevent
something much wider and much more
destructive
intervention um we are on time limit so
it does prevent other people from having
their allocation um and if interventions
are taken it would be good if people
could still stick to the five minutes
alan smith
i thought it was an excellent
intervention personally and i'd agree
with it strongly so i'm very very very
grateful for it we do need to make the
case on an ongoing basis of the support
that we're having for ukraine because
it's not just their freedom it's ours
and i think that that is an important
point the gentleman makes but to close
modern secretary speaker on
accountability
we do need to see more and i pay tribute
to the support that the uk has given to
the international court and the canadian
coordination of these efforts but we
need to make war criminals and potential
war criminals aware that there will be
no amnesty there will be no hiding place
and the uk can do more with that the uk
has a developed legal system a number of
practitioners are very active in this
field so we do need to put more
resources into that so the snp is part
of this coalition
i'm proud that we've been able to work
together on this point because this
transcends boundaries this transcends
politics and that support will continue
speaker
the world has just witnessed ukraine
pull up a stunning counter-offensive
around kharkiv they liberated thousands
of miles of territory in what was an
incredible feat of military planning
months of distraction around cousin were
put in place absolute radio silence
around what they were doing around
kharkiv and it was something that
brought the world with them and showed
that yes they will be victorious if we
stand by them
this victory was not just thousands of
miles of territory but it hit russian
logistics it liberated major
administrative and rail hubs that the
russians have been using and it will
castrate their ability to do what they
need and rely on those rail logistics
throughout
as a result we've seen a panicked
response from the kremlin
sham referendum and a partial
mobilization of three hundred thousand
men
now much has been made of this
mobilization the point i would make
though is that you cannot magically
muster kit
strategy or skilled soldiers and we have
to be careful we challenge these
arguments when we hear these big
announcements from putin that do not
actually tantamount change the situation
on the ground
now these performative referendums
should be called hostage referendums
because that is what they are and it is
vital that the world rejects them and
i'm confident we will but it is years
ago when we did not reject them that we
saw putin emboldened to do what he's
doing today
now ukrainian gains are also shown the
scale of atrocities being committed by
russian troops it's really vital that we
look at how we can support those so as
ever i would like to focus madame deputy
speaker on recommendations what the
government should be doing
the first is that our international
justice infrastructure is not sufficient
the icc cannot prosecute in this
situation and we need to be convening as
one of the foremost powers when it comes
to security and justice are planned for
how we will hold people to account
who've committed atrocities at all
levels
secondly the point i made earlier about
creating a specific
court or tribunal for sexual violence
and rape that it gets stood up at the
start of conflicts rather than just at
the end when it is too late to collect
evidence
one of the things we must also do is
learn how we share intelligence back in
september last year this time last year
britain and the america and britain
america went around and told our allies
that putin was going to invade we had
the intelligence we were sure of it and
our allies didn't believe us
the french said it just wouldn't happen
but had too good of a relationship with
putin the germans said that wasn't what
their intelligence showed when i asked
european ambassadors why they didn't
believe us
they say it's because of iraq
now that is greatly concerned to me that
they are making intelligence decisions
based on what happened so many decades
ago when i was only a child but it shows
also that we have manifestly failed to
make what was the most important
intelligence analysis and argument that
we needed to of the last decade
now putin is no master strategist he's a
gambler he gambles in 2014 that would
turn a blind eye to the invasion of
crimea he gambled in syria where we
turned our backs and he gambled in
february that we would be too divided
now he was wrong on that but putin bases
these decisions on a critical assumption
that we have not adapted for 21st
century hybrid warfare because we've
spent the last two decades focused on
terrorists that behave like states but
between now and 2050 it'll be states
that behave like terrorists that we must
adapt to
and to do that we need whole of state
resilience which is not easy it's not
sexy and it will take decades to put in
place but that is how we protect
ourselves and our allies in the long
term
and that uncovers everything from
investment and supply chains to
defending our multilaterals and the rule
of law up holding human rights the
independence our education institutions
our culture and our digital security
we must recalibrate technology and the
democratization of information have
fundamentally changed geopolitics we are
at war at all times the best enemies are
the ones that we do not know that they
are there we do not know we are at war
with them bullets as early as being made
the point conversations could be taking
place people radicalized and recruited
that a single word being spoken aloud we
are not ready whether it is energy and
food sources whether it is business
culture finance military hostile states
are infiltrating us at all levels and we
have to tackle this and we as britain
can convene our allies because that is
one of our greatest strengths our
ability to convene partners we can
convene and work together towards a more
resilient society because if we don't
double down if we don't defend and stop
neglecting our international
institutions we will further embolden
russia and this is our responsibility if
we want fair play if we want respect for
the rules based order
the lessons from ukraine so far very
happily
i'm grateful for the intervention she's
making a powerful speech would she agree
with me that on cyber resilience
especially there is a lot of good work
to build on but it needs more resource
without question my friend is absolutely
right and within the military we are
building these capabilities but they
need to be cross-forced but they also
need to bring in the civilians whether
based in the foreign office back in 2016
i was in ukraine training the ukrainians
how to do counter disinformation
operations how to integrate it with
cyber and we've seen that pay off that
work look at what they did over the last
few weeks
but the lessons madame deputy speaker
are clear the decisions and defenses and
resilience that we implement now is what
will defend us over the next 20 years
and we need to make ourselves and our
alliance as an international more
resilient because only in that way will
we protect ourselves will we return to
moral leadership on the world stage will
we stop atrocities and we will be able
to take a stand and protect ourselves in
those hostile states who will spend the
next 20 years using their whole state
effort to undermine us and to hurt us
order i would just urge those who have
already
spoken to perhaps think twice about
intervening again flair anderson thank
you madam deputy speaker
i visited
two weeks ago as a member of the first
cross party delegation of mp since the
war began which has been mentioned by
other members and many of us are here
today we were a group of seven mps from
four parties it was a long journey there
and back as there are no flights but we
were absolutely determined to go
together to show solidarity
and support for the ukrainian government
for the armed forces and for the
sovereignty of ukraine and for the
people of ukraine
i congratulate the ukrainian armed
forces on their victories of the past 10
days it was an exciting weekend to be
there as they were announced
and i'm proud of the welcome given by
people in putney south fields and
northampton and across this country for
by so many families to welcome people
from ukraine many of whom i have met
but i would echo the concerns raised by
other members about what will happen at
that six months cliff edge of support
for the most families who are saying we
would like to be able to support you but
we just can't and those ukrainians who
want to stay can't go back yet
and yet can't don't have a guarantor
don't have the credit history um
necessary to have private accommodation
what will happen there it will really
undermine everything all the good words
that we say here in this house and the
good support that we are providing for
ukrainians if we don't provide that well
that longer term welcome that is needed
as we've reflected on her majesty's
reign in the past week there is a
striking contrast between the transition
away from the british empire during her
reign
with putin's aggressive dominating
barbaric empire building that has
ukraine in its sights right now but
could extend much further including to
the balkans where there is a election in
bosnia in just 10 days time it is vital
to stand up to the aggression of
aggression of putin and his regime and
that we join with our allies in
supporting ukraine and look to building
a peaceful future together at the same
time as supporting the deoccupation
as the delegation of mps we met with
president zielenski and his head of
office with the minister for defence and
deputy presidents with mps human rights
activists soldiers and with the staff of
the depaul
depaul aid agency who are providing
psychological counselling and aid
the reports coming from butcher from
mario paul and from the de-occupied
regions are shocking shocking torture
mass graves rape used as a weapon of war
war crimes by the russian army
and as co-chair of the all-party
parliamentary group on the prevention of
genocide and crimes against humanity i
know that we mean never again when we
say it in this house every year we mean
never again when we remember past
atrocities but now is the time to put
flesh on those words and to act against
atrocities that we know are happening
now and that's why we are proud as the
british people to be supporting the
people of ukraine
maybe it is the only issue that unites
us across the house but we have been
unequivocal supporters of ukraine from
the outset
the increase of energy prices
may be a factor in what people are
calling potential ukrainian fatigue but
i know that the british people
understand that the link but there
between the increase in energy prices is
another reason why we must support
ukraine and stop
putin black bailing us over energy we
need to end that war decisively and as
soon as possible so that it doesn't cost
even more
and the needs are clear for air defenses
for military equipment support for
heating system support as backups during
the winter the return of prisoners the
return of the forcibly adopted ukrainian
children a scandal that i don't have
time to say more about but is really
shocking support for the rebuilding and
reparations and support for justice
and especially a special international
tribunal to try putin for the crime of
aggression
the international criminal court is a
parallel process but it's one that will
not deliver enough justice and fast
enough and therefore i think as britain
we can lead in calling for that
international special tribunal and
finally support for civil society
humanitarian aid and peace building for
long-term peace-building to be built
into the process it's not enough just to
have military and diplomatic and then
legal support we must have that fourth
essential element of civil society this
is how a whole government
support for ukraine can be delivered
because i want to because kiev is a
beautiful city ukraine is a beautiful
country and i want to return to a free
and victorious ukraine which will not
fear future aggression we can see that
when we stand together thank you
speaker and i was also very pleased to
join the all-party trip to kiev uh a
week ago and this will soon be uh
represented in my register of interest
if a deal involving peace for land was
ever possible now ukrainians will not
start to negotiate until all of their
land is free from russia and that
includes donbass and crimea this was the
firm view of every politician soldier
and citizen that i had the opportunity
to meet in ukraine
and one can see why as the vile outcome
of russian occupation is revealed in
territory retaken by the heroic actions
of the ukrainian military
sadly the horrors of butcher are not a
horrific isolated incident
indeed it's becoming clear that looting
torture murder rape and intimidation is
a standard practice for the russian
occupiers
horribly russia has deported tens of
thousands of ukrainian children
including 2 300 orphans to russia
these crimes must never be forgotten or
overlooked and i was very pleased to
hear of how uk prosecutors have been
helping local agencies with evidence
collection and advice
this war is more than just about helping
a freedom-loving people fight against a
bullying aggressor as others have said
russian aggression has been used time
and time again under putin right from
the invasion of georgia in 2008. there
is nothing to show that russia would
unless stop stop at ukraine to that
extent ukrainians are also fighting the
war on behalf of all of us who refuse to
accept a europe where barbarity and
violence are going to call the shots
and with that in mind i think we should
now consider russia to constitute a spot
a state sponsor of terrorism and that as
such it would be equitable for frozen
russian state and state-linked assets
including frozen sanctioned individual
assets
to be seized for payment to ukraine for
its reconstruction
this would require legislation uh but
similar to that passed by canada only in
june
i will
i i thank you for giving away is he
aware that we have just heard news that
a young woman was killed in moscow by
the russian police for participating in
the anti-war demonstrations and and will
he would he also condemn that
and the many other deaths that we're
hearing about all the time coming out of
russia the question recently came up as
to whether individual oligarchs should
be able to buy their way out of
sanctions
i'm personally doubtful that this could
work without the international sanction
system being held under the water line
however
if any deal should be co it is
considered it has to be coordinated and
approved by ukraine
not just the sanctioning country and the
restitution money involved should go to
ukraine in that way any decisions on
release of assets would be properly
coordinated
over recent months there have been many
pictures of russian tourists swarming
around europe as though nothing is
happening in ukraine this should stop
and we should now ban russian visas to
the uk other than for exceptional
circumstances certainly at the very
least we should not allow into the uk
any member of putin's united party of
russia
sanctions are a slow burn approach but
increasingly effective but there are the
so-called holes in the holes in the
bucket turkey comes to mind
and there are others could the minister
please advise what efforts are being
made to isolate such countries
but battlefield victories are
accentuating the size of the challenges
yet to be faced firstly military
speaking russia still maintains a
powerful and vicious threat putin is an
unpredictable enemy and wounded and
concerned to protect his crimea legacy
to russia
he may yet become even less principled
over civilian rights indeed only
yesterday he upped the ante by calling
out russia's reserves
secondly retaking occupied territory is
one thing but holding it is another
police court schools and civil society
all have to be reestablished war crimes
and collaborators have to be prosecuted
infrastructure has to be rebuilt the
costs and administrative challenges
involved are enormous and urgent
thirdly the military requirements are
changing
in the early days of the war basic
equipment for soldiers and defensive
weapons such as anti-tank missiles were
priority
then longer-range artillery to break
down russian defenses was and still is
required to enable offensive operations
but then following rapture patient the
priorities change again and the need for
anti-missile defense systems are now
coming to the floor and were very much
highlighted during our visit
if ukraine is going to encourage its
over 10 million internally displaced
systems and millions of foreign-based
refugees to return to their homes in
ukraine then security from air attack
becomes key to restoring defense
confidence
this point was very much reinforced by
russian retaliation against the lost
ground taking the countly form of
missile attacks against civilian targets
electricity and water infrastructure has
already been bombed and a cold winter is
approaching
so the challenges here are immense
but one thing is for sure and came
across very strongly during my time in
queue
namely
ukrainian recognition of british support
and the gratitude that was shown by
everyone we met ukrainians feel that the
uk is in this battle with them for the
long term and that we were the first to
speak up for them in the international
community
also that we then back that up with
money arms and valuable advice
the government and virtually all members
of all parties of this house are to be
commended for their support history is
on our side i was left with a strong
impression that out of this war out of
this horror and barbarity will develop
an immensely strong and lasting
relationship between our two countries
in the meantime we must redouble our
efforts to ensure a speedy victory for
ukraine as soon as possible and enable
its restoration towards the modern
democratic country that i know it has
the potential to be
[Music]
i'm sorry but many of the speakers
recently have been um six minutes so i'm
going to have to reduce the time limit
um immediately to
four minutes and it may have to go down
beyond that
hop house
deputy speaker i wholeheartedly join
into the cross party support for ukraine
but i want to touch on an issue that has
been touched upon but less debated this
afternoon
women are casualty of war and conflict
but they are very often overlooked women
including those who fight alongside men
suffer in a uniquely gendered way
ukrainian women have displayed an
incredible strength in defending their
country and their families both on and
off the battlefield
as more ukrainian territories are
liberated more terrible stories emerge
of atrocities committed against women
by june the un human rights monitoring
team had received reports of 124 alleged
incidents of sexual violence
the secretary general special
representatives has warned that reports
are rising fast
wartime sexual violence is one of the
oldest crimes known to people
it has long time implications on
individuals and communities
long
after the war has ended the government
recognizes the problem of wartime sexual
violence but it must be fully matched
with support for women on the ground too
often war crime of all time sexual
violence is viewed as inevitable as part
of war this is totally unacceptable the
sexualized threats faced by women and
girls must be confronted head on and
must be prosecuted like any other war
crime and i'm grateful for the
recommendation of the honourable member
for rootland and melton the government
along along with the international
community needs to aid ukraine to ensure
a robust response to gender-based
violence that must include post-rape
care access to abortion and mental
health support our human response
demands that we make sexual reproductive
and maternal health care a priority
perpetrators must be vigorously
investigated and adequately punished and
the uk must help by providing ukraine to
do this
providing support for ukraine to do this
the majority of those fleeing ukraine
are women and children the response from
communities in bordering countries and
the uk has been incredibly powerful but
we shouldn't be blind to the ongoing
risk to women and girls we know that
female refugees have always faced
disproportionate risks especially if
they're traveling alone many of my
constituents have contacted me on behalf
of ukrainians stuck in dangerous places
waiting for visas why their weight their
funds run low and their place at grace
their risk of
trafficking and abuse
refugees are safest when they have
options they need full legal protection
the right papers and have to be totally
aware of their rights the government
must equal the outpouring of compassion
shown by the british public and allow
ukrainian refugees to come to the uk
without the unacceptable bureaucratic
delays otherwise we are driving
vulnerable women and girls into the arms
of opportunistic abusers it is a matter
of basic safety as the war continues and
shows no signs to be resolved the
british government must do better when
it comes to protecting women and girls i
am sure many of my colleagues across the
house share my admiration for the
courage of the women of ukraine we must
match it with action
while we hope the war might be over soon
it probably won't just as important as
speeding up the process now is making
sure that the support for our
ukrainian refugees will be sustained
what are the government's plans in six
months time and beyond
how are we going to help families find
long-term accommodation jobs and
financial report
support you shouldn't underestimate the
substantial trauma that women and
children will have suffered especially
if they have experienced sexual violence
support services will need funding
beyond this year to rebuild lives in the
long term this government will have to
show that it has a long breath not just
in providing military help but
humanitarian help to deal with the human
tragedy beyond the here and now
i'm going to have to be really strict
with people
i'm sorry but i can't get everybody in
unless i reduce the time limit even more
so after the next speaker it will be
three minutes jeffrey clifton brown
dear to your three-minute rule uh
the message from this debate should go
out to vladimir zelinsky and the ukraine
and the ukrainian people that we salute
their bravery they have suffered
grievously
this has become in just seven months one
of the biggest refugee
catastrophes that the world has seen
since the second world war
over seven million people to place
displaced within ukraine and seven
million people to the rest of europe
over fourteen thousand people dead or
wounded
hundreds of people grievously suffered
from war crimes of torture
of sexual crimes as the honourable lady
has just made clear and as my honourable
friend said the kidnapping of hundreds
of innocent children
quite simply
we have to help
the ukrainian people win this conflict
because if they don't drive succeed in
driving the russians out of ukraine
no country in europe will be safe
and therefore i congratulate my
government on the support and help that
they are giving to ukraine as outlined
in the very comprehensive statement made
by the armed forces minister today
and i am delighted that the new prime
minister has made it very clear
that we will stick by ukraine for as
long as it takes
and contrary to what some speakers have
said today
i do not think necessarily that this is
going to be a quick end to this conflict
i think there's all sorts of twists and
turns that could happen
and as others have said although we hope
vladimir
putin's threat of a tactical nuclear
weapons is just that we cannot be sure
so we are absolutely right to give that
help and i understand the british people
are suffering through their cost of
living grievously from the cost of
energy and also the cost of food but we
must point out to them as their
politicians that if we don't continue to
support ukraine throughout this this
conflict they will suffer even more
finally the really issue that i want to
talk about is brain
we haven't heard anything about grain in
this debate
at long last the united nations food
programme has with our help with the
united kingdom's diplomatic help has
negotiated some grain shipments to cross
the black sea out through the
dardanelles and into some of the most
vulnerable and poorest people in africa
we must make sure that that program
continues it is absolutely vital for
some of the poorest people in the world
and we must do all we can to prevent the
russians stopping that program
so i just say to all my constituents
who have so generously hosted the
ukrainian people and then i've met some
of them uh had a meeting with them
please continue to do that i know it's
difficult in some cases but please
continue your generosity and for the
british people please bear with the
privations you've got caused by this war
it's going to be difficult this winter
our government will do what it can but
eventually i'm sure right will come
through and the russians will be driven
out of ukraine
vladimir putin has called upon an
additional 300 000 reservists on the
face of it it seems
a huge large number of reinforcements
yet the reality is that most of these
men have completed a fraction of the
training that a nato member would
require when this war first began
russia was sending in transcripts that
had only had a few days basic training
it appears that putin has not learned
his lesson or perhaps he has and simply
does not care true putin his own people
are canon body they are being sent to
the front lines due to his personal
delusions of grandeur
the reality is that the latest
reinforcements will likely suffer a
worse fate than the original battle
groups due to the failure of the russian
army and more importantly the success of
the ukrainians there is much less
equipment for these reinforcements in
russia's recent disorganised retreat
from haku region substantial amounts of
russian equipment was destroyed or
captured this is a testimony to the
bravery skilled and tactical prowess of
the ukrainians
what is interesting is how the people of
russia have reacted to putin's
mobilization announcement almost as soon
as putin finished how to leave russia
topped the google trends in russia
flights leaving russia either sold out
or skyrocketed
more than a thousand people were
arrested on the streets who were
objecting protesting against
reinforcements putin is pushing his old
people to the edge yet putin has a huge
security apparatus protecting him and
his cronies in russia his grip on power
is strong yet expecting putin to no
longer be in control or to suddenly do
the right thing will not happen
that is why support for ukrainian must
not wader ukrainians have shown russia
and the world that they are fully
capable of fighting the force government
must do all it can to continue our
support that includes looking at steps
that contain taking hit against putin
supporters there is still far too much
dirty money rushing around our country
particularly in london there is much
more we can do on that the pressure on
putin supporters needs to be tightened
there is only one acceptable way this
war can end and that is why democratic
ukraine having control over all of its
own territory now is the time for us to
double down as i said months ago this
conflict started this war is our war
ukrainian ukrainians are fighting it on
behalf of all of us we must give
ukrainians what they need and the
government must do our bit at home in
particular i would emphasize the
comments made by my honorable friends
from birkenhead and the member from
putnik about the refugees we must do
much more we cannot let these people
down please please listen to them and
also thank the member from putney for
bringing her news here to us and thank
you so much for going across
here
bob seeley
um it was a pleasure to believe the
delegation last week for anyone who's
interested i will be hopefully taking
another one and organizing another one
for later in the year it'll be lovely to
see colleagues uh on that um when we
were there it was quite clear that
actually
that weekend that we were there heralded
a new phase in the war
whilst there is still far to go
there is now a sense in ukraine of a
pathway to ukrainian victory and russian
military defeat probably within the next
three to 18 months
secondly the partial collapse of russian
forces will commit
it to commit reserves that it would have
wanted to build up
until spring for the chance of a spring
offensive so therefore from now on
russia's war will almost certainly
become a defensive war of digging in and
holding on
it is clear madam deputy speaker that
russia's weaknesses on the battlefield
however ukraines are economic and
political they have a near total
dependency economically on the west and
they have a dependency on our arms
supply it is quite clear that brute and
putin will try to break this alliance
and gain a political victory where he
cannot seize a military one
in military terms the umbilical cord
between us and kiev becomes the center
of gravity for the russians to attack
this explains in part putin's decision
to threaten the use of nuclear weapons
to annex territory in russia under
mobilization
is nuclear weapon use likely
not by any means but i think that we
should speak with a sense of care and
proportion and on this and that one
minute i have i'll try to explain a
slight difference with the government
to minimize the chances of nuclear use
tactical or strategic we have to assume
that that threat is real and that at
some point probably as russian troops
face collapse in the south putin will
have
again military term a decision point to
either use or not tactical weapons we
have to assume that he may well use them
so that we can plan that is the purpose
of assuming use so we can plan to say he
is bluffing means that we don't have a
plan and we will again as we've been
doing since 2007 be playing catch up
with a disastrous situation with a
fascistic russian state
hope is not a strategy keeping your
fingers crossed is not a policy
at every point putin has chosen to
escalate and increase risk there is no
sign that he will do anything different
now
in short we need to maximize the chance
of avoiding tactical news
that will tactical use that will kill
thousands by planning for it now i will
write for i've run out of time i will
write further on this and what the
ukrainians told us in due
course for years countries in eastern
europe such as poland and the baltic
states have been warning about russia
under putin we absolutely must recognize
the gravity scale and multifaceted
nature of the threat and the lands that
putin may go to now whilst we have some
encouraging bits of news tyrion retaken
in eastern ukraine we must not
underestimate the scale of the challenge
still left extensive terrain still to
reconquer the toll of war efforts taking
on both military and civilians the
efforts have put into so alienation and
to give false legitimacy to his invasion
through the so-called referenda
and the huge efforts required to rebuild
ruined towns and devastated communities
putin's clear aim is to divide and
conquer so whilst the world is looking
at the physical the ground war the
threat of nuclear weapons all the time
there's the huge propaganda war
sometimes more subtle sometimes less
subtle trying to undermine the west
unity and resolve the bombarding of
internet users with very clever false
messages masquerading is the truth so
i'd like to stress again to the minister
how important it is for the uk and
allies to invest in
combating this internet warfare and
mounting counter-offensives
we need renewed efforts at diplomacy and
fostering unity it's very important that
we are putting money where our mouth is
and supporting our efforts in ukraine
and absolutely vitally stand firm on
cyclones but we must foster the most
positive and unified response from other
countries
and that includes of course investing
foreign office expertise but it's not
just about europe and nato in the wider
world how do we maintain world peace and
deal with the bullies first of all we
need to be strong and show strength
appeasement does not work
in 2014 after the invasion of crimea the
lack of action by the west was a
monumental failure we need to stand
strong in the face of aggression and for
all their imperfections we need to
rebuild our respect for international
organizations such as the united nations
repair the damage caused by trump when
he belittled international organizations
tore up treaties and cut funding to
important international programmes
an important part of that international
work is also tackling the gap between
the rich and the poorer nations
nations across the globe need reason to
buy into international organizations and
feel that they're being listened to
coronavirus has taught us how
interconnected we are but it's also true
in respect of security we need to build
up resilience and prosperity in
developing nations to stop them being
used and manipulated by the world's
tyrants so whilst uh continuing our
direct support for ukraine we must also
focus on fostering unity amongst our
allies and taking a lead in world
organizations to stand firm against
putin
my appreciation for the british troops
based in my constituency of divisors for
the
work that they have done in in training
our allies in ukraine
on salisbury plain
but most of all my appreciation for
ukraine for her leadership her army and
her people they have resisted putin they
have fought back and they are winning
so the question now is what next and
members might be familiar with the
famous story in his memoir of vladimir
putin as a young boy chasing a rat with
a stick which then he got into a corner
and it turned on him and attacked
and putin himself is now that rat driven
into a corner by the heroic ukrainians
and the risk is that the rat now turns
that he does what he said he'd do
uh and launches a nuclear strike on
ukraine
uh on on a nato country or even even
including the uk
and the lesson from the story of putin
and the rat is not that we don't corner
him
there is no escape route for him that we
can offer except his defeat and
humiliation
the lesson we must learn is that we must
be ready for the rats to turn
and i i don't doubt ukraine's
determination to stand whatever happens
and i don't doubt the commitment of the
british government or indeed the wider
alliance to stand with
the ukrainians my concerns with our own
preparedness in the event of a nuclear
strike either in europe or here and i
know ministers didn't like it when the
chairman of the defense let committee
raised this point earlier and i don't
expect them to say anything other than
our defenses and our doctrine uh in the
event of a nuclear strike are entirely
up to date and ready my concern is with
our wider resilience not just in the
event of a nuclear strike but the wider
economic uh and military pressures that
we might be under so i'm concerned to
see that on our conventional defenses
are as strong as possible we have
learned the critical importance of men
and armor in this war and i'd like to
see our army grow we need to be
concerned with our economic security and
also our social resilience and i echo
the point made by my honourable friend
the member for rutland and melton
earlier when she talked about the need
for a whole estate
approach there's talk of a new
integrated
uh review and i would echo the calls for
that and i hope that it would include
not just whole estate our resilience but
the whole of society as well thank you
martial hughes
speaker only as a member of western
marcher but when you come from a place
like clay bank i'm keenly aware of what
it's like
growing up in a place like the worst
aerial bombardment in these islands
during the second world war to play in
the ruins and also to play in uh bomb
craters so that's why it's clear to me
that just uh as planning for a new
social settlement for people in these
islands began right in the middle of the
last great war as we would call it
though not exactly a perfect settlement
it's something we must now do to help
ukraine build itself a prosperous and
sustainable peace integrated as they
wish into the european union and the
mainstream of a free europe now the
challenge madam deputy speaker is stark
the kiev school of economics has
reported a 33 drop in gdp something that
will need to be in mind and also the 200
billion bill to repair the damage done
by the russian federation
that requires commitments not only from
this government but from other allies as
well commitments not only financial the
design scale has not been measured in
weeks but i'm afraid in decades and
while i know there is as we've heard a
lot of support across the house for such
measures we need to hear a lot more from
the treasury ministers about what they
plan to do it's also something
philosophical challenge for the
government madam deputy speaker ukraine
is now a candidate country for the
european union and contrary to the way
things have often worked in terms of
military planning long-term economic and
social change will be delivered through
its gradual and deepening alignment with
the rest of europe i would hope that
there would be nothing to stop this
government ensuring that ukraine is able
to do that in the fullest possible
extent so let me bring my this matters
to a conclusion by urging ministers
opposite if they've not already done so
is to begin the essential planning that
will be required for what will be needed
in ukraine when it wins the war a very
modern martial plan i think is required
now i'm glad to know in regular debates
it's become customary for many to repeat
the couple of slava ukraine the roman
slava glory to ukraine glory to the
heroes but i'm mindful of the old gaelic
proverb martin deputy speaker which
translates to a man prepared for war
peace is assured now ukraine is prepared
and peace can be assured madam deputy
speaker but its continued existence as a
sovereign state requires more than
heroic platitudes and i'm afraid even
proverbs uttered on the floor of the
house of commons
david simmons thank you
speaker um i'd like to start by placing
on my record uh placing on record my
thanks to my two local authorities for
the work that they've done
in supporting and resettling uh
ukrainians who've had to flee the war
and find a new home in the united
kingdom
it's fantastic the work the government's
done to support them and i have good
reports that the financial support in
particular to be made available has been
enormously helpful and whilst there is
clearly a little bit more work to do
for those who are going to be settling
in the uk long term to ensure that
access to education healthcare and other
services continues to be available for
the time that they're here it is a
success story despite some of the
concerns that were raised at the time
i'd like to focus on two particular
points which i think emerged from what
is happening in ukraine at the moment
and which arise from some of the points
made by a number of members about how we
prepare for the future
before being elected to this house i was
a member of one of the constituent
bodies of the council of europe
and the meetings were always challenging
given that at that time we had ukraine
which had been invaded in the center
that crimea by russia and russia in the
same room debating their supposed mutual
respect for human rights and the rule of
law
but it is clear that with proposals like
that of the new european political
community that there is an opportunity
for the united kingdom and other
countries that do respect the rule of
law to bolster the position of
politicians civil society organizations
leaders in russia who do not condone the
actions of vladimir putin putin is by no
means the only politician in russia and
many of us who've been engaged in any
sense in those international operations
will know that there is internal
opposition to him in that country that
we hope if the work that is being done
by uh ukrainians succeeds and the
pressure brought to bear by the
international community succeeds then
we'll have an opportunity in the future
to foster a relationship with a much
more positive russian government than
the one that we have at the moment and
it seems to me it will both bolster the
efforts that we are putting in to
support ukraine at the moment we can
strengthen the hand of those who are
critics of putin at home and it will lay
the groundwork for that more
constructive relationship in the future
that will be particularly important for
the reconstruction of ukraine
and then finally just to touch on the
point about cyber i had the opportunity
to be a witness at the home affairs
select committee before being elected
here
and prior to my session there was a
witness who was there from gchq who was
asked the question at the height of the
brexit debates
do the russians want the uk to leave
european union and the answer was very
informative which was that what the
russians were seeking was not a
particular outcome but division in the
west they wanted us in this house they
wanted the west to be arguing amongst
ourselves about what was happening i
think that really goes to the heart of
the points made by so many members of
one which i would like to echo that the
unity and consistency of purpose across
the allies is so vital to the long-term
outcomes for ukraine
all right man i'm deputy speaker and i'm
very pleased to be calling us i was
moved the other day when i watched the
the uh very solomon dignified meeting
between our own princess of wales and
orlando solanska the wife of the
ukrainian president then which was clear
it was the united kingdom and
and
ukraine standing together
at that level with with the ladies very
much to the fore
i want to uh
just continue to to do the right thing
for the people of ukraine and continue
to stand with them and their darkest
arms i'm very minded as well i want to
say a big thanks to all of those who
have who and my constituency uh talus in
east belfast uh um makes the what they
refer to the next generation light early
tank weapons um
and
i understand the workforce from the
management tell me that most of those
those people who work there come from my
constituents i want to say a big thanks
to them for all that they've done for
those there get made the turning point
for money in the in their korean uh um
uh conflict
there's no difference in the many ways
in which your kinions are presently
suffering as they continue to have their
home run invaded by putin i'm very
grateful to other members for
highlighting such atrocities i'd like to
draw attention if i can to the way to
which freedom of religion or belief
is travelled on during the present
crisis especially given as i've had said
many times religious freedoms are
bellwether human right word is protected
other human rights tend to be secure too
so i want to ask if i can and just this
year uh the executive director of the
institute for religious freedom said the
russian attacks on religious freedoms in
ukraine have never been as cruel as they
are now he said of russian invaders
previously expelled believers from
ukrainian churches and from their prayer
houses they are now destroying them with
bombs and missile strikes
they should have remembered
international attacks against religious
sites can constitute war crimes
according to the international
humanitarian law and the damage to
freedom of religion or belief does not
stop there the president of the
ukrainian baptist theological seminar
said that in six months of the war
around 400 baptist churches have been
forced to close pastures have been of
the churches have been kidnapped have
went missing uh and and some of the uh
the parishioners as well so many corners
of ukraine feed the ripples of war and
while war rages basic uh human needs
cannot be met
so no doubt at the conclusion of the war
the psychological and spiritual distress
caused by the war will remain the dom
pass and the ghance regions are the ones
where it's happening most just want to
say and finally concluding northern is
no verse giving spread that many of our
churches across all denominations of
this financial support to churches in
the ukraine to purchase food and
clothing but with those churches closing
the support revenues in the don pass and
the laganza regions are no longer a safe
place to be
a place of comfort or a place to get
food these avenues of support were
essential for people in ukraine we have
a duty of care to those people to ensure
that they can survive this war but
everybody's mentioned with the
atrocities and the important uh support
that we have given and yet i came to the
ukraine i think it's also important we
underline the despicable things that
happen with human rights and and those
who have uh lost their right to uh for
freedom of religious belief
just to say the
front bench have very kindly agreed to
shorten their contributions in order to
assist me in getting everybody in
shadow minister stephen downs um thank
you madam deputy speaker i'd like to
thank colleagues from across the house
for their valued contributions to
today's debate and first he also wanted
to add uh my
views that it's absolutely fantastic
we've seen the release of uh a number of
britain's and others um it's absolutely
wonderful news but also to recognize
that there are others who are still
being held or who have not made it
safely home i also want to welcome the
new minister to his place and look
forward to working constructively with
him over the weeks and months to come
but man deputy speaker i think the
attendance and the comments made today
on all sides show that the resolve of
this house has clearly never been
stronger and our continued commitment to
the freedom of ukraine and our
opposition to putin's illegal and
barbaric invasion is palpable and indeed
uh madame deputy speaker um i also
joined the recent cross-party delegation
to ukraine and kiev and will draw
attention to my declaration of interest
to the table in g course as guests of
yards european strategy and i was able
to convey that cross-party support
personally to president zielenski and i
think it's worth saying madam deputy
speaker that on meeting uh that
remarkable uh president what he's doing
and the effort he is leading his first
comments were to offer his sincere
condolences to all of us on the loss of
her late majesty uh the queen um and
also to make clear um his absolute uh
thanks and gratitude to the british
people to this house to the government
to all parties for the continued and
resolute support that we have provided
and indeed those tributes from him were
echoed by ukrainians who are leaving
flowers at the uh
ambassador's residence indeed the
british embassy in kiev um i was left
with three main reflections from that
visit madam deputy speaker firstly the
brutality of the russian invasion we saw
with our own eyes the scenes in
bucharest urpin and hostimel we saw
residential buildings that had been
rocketed uh we saw uh areas where there
were
terrible terrible atrocities committed
um and it's very very clear the types of
tactics that the russians are using and
of course that has been exposed even
greater detail in horrifying detail in
recent days from isiam it's absolutely
clear we have to work with them to bring
those who have committed those acts at
all levels to justice and indeed we saw
the holocaust memorial at babanya which
of course um recognizes the horrific
slaughter of 34 000 jews by the nazis in
1941 the same memorial that was then
damaged um and indeed the tv tower
nearby that was damaged and civilians
killed by a russian attack uh just
months ago um absolutely extraordinary
and we saw the shrapnel from that from
that attack the second thing was the
resolution of ukrainians at every level
to fight for the freedom of their
country individual soldiers that we met
individual citizens that we met members
of parliament we met and of course the
government um uh you know mps who are
going and taking resources to soldiers
from their areas to support them while
their parliament is sandbagged can we
imagine this parliament with sandbags in
the windows
holes to defend democracy that is what
ukrainians are doing um they're also
clearly a western european ambitious
young
dynamic country with no affection or
affiliation for putin's regime or his
agenda is very clear where they want to
stand and we stand with them in that the
third thing i was left with was the
absolute criticality of western and
european and indeed united kingdom unity
and support for the ukrainians and their
efforts on all levels militarily
economically and otherwise our support
our military support
and our economic support is crucial to
the uh successes that we've seen in
recent days into the defense of ukraine
and our economic support more broadly
will be critical going forward and we
have to show resolve in supporting
ukraine through what is going to be a
difficult few months for this winter
we've already seen the russians
attacking critical national
infrastructure just on one of the nights
we were there in response to the
ukrainian successes they took out the
electricity and water supplies to
millions of people in the east of the
country and that is what they are
willing to attack civilian
infrastructure in response um let's be
clear man deputy speaker for ukraine
this is a war of necessity and uh
survival of national unity but to putin
this is one of choice one of aggression
it is an imperial war of attempted
colonisation and annexation
and that must be clear in the message
that we share around the world with our
partners and that we must make clear in
our diplomatic efforts in the global
south in south asia and elsewhere we
need to work with ukrainians to make
clear what russia is doing what their
agenda is and how they are prosecuting
this war in the most barbarous and
inhumane
way possible and although putin's war
machine in recent days has stalled the
consequences the war will sadly
reverberate for years the destruction it
has already brought to towns and
villages across ukraine as well as uh
the damage to critical infrastructure
have the capacity to set the country
back decades and we saw uh bridges
civilian infrastructure other places
that had been damaged and destroyed and
that's why it's crucial that we not only
provide ukraine with financial and
economic support to get them through
this winter but also in the long term to
be providing the trade and investment
links to sustain it through the period
of rebuilding which must come when they
are victorious um i was a little
disappointed ma'am deaf speaker to have
concerns raised with me about um the
fact that uk trade envoy um although
having been imposed for some years
hadn't in fact visited ukraine and also
concerns about uh the uk ukrainian
chamber of commerce um not having enough
activities going on we need to be
looking to the long term we need to be
providing hope for ukrainians um for
their future when this war is over um
and i hope that the minister will be
able to comment on uh that um ma'am
deputy speaker uh has been made clear by
my honorable friend um at the opening of
this debate in terms of military support
labour continues to fully support the
government's position to provide the
necessary military assistance for the
defense of ukraine and indeed i remain
humbled and moved by the uk's training
program for new ukrainian recruits as
well as the material support we are
providing and i want to thank all of
those who are continuing to play this
critical supporting role putin expected
this war to be over in days but in part
thanks to our support the people of
ukraine are resisting and fighting back
seven months down the line and i'm
confident but in the end freedom and
liberty will triumph but dark days do
lie ahead we have heard many worrying
comments in the debate today and indeed
the speech that putin made yesterday was
meant to frighten and intimidate the
international community into withdrawing
support to fracture our alliance we must
not let him succeed in that the estonian
prime minister khalas put it
fantastically when saying that
threatening nuclear threatening nukes
belongs to the arsenal of a pariah state
and that is absolutely right now is not
the time to withdraw support or to cow
to putin's distortions and threats and
in particular we need to work with
governments across europe in the months
to come we've heard worrying comments
about the situation in italy some
comments being made in hungary and
elsewhere to ensure that we stay unified
and resolute in our support for ukraine
um that is the moment where our words
and our deeds will count for the most
the government will continue to have the
opposition support in the agenda that
we've set out that we've followed
through the last seven months um and i
know they can also count on the support
of people in cardiff and panath who have
come out in the streets on ukrainian
independence day um and other events
recently um the services proceedings
today have made real service to the
immense sacrifices ukraine continues to
make for their own country but for
europe as a whole for the values we all
share and i know in the end they are the
ones that will prevail
thank you very much indeed madam deputy
speaker i'm very very grateful for the
contributions of all members
today in this extremely useful debate
and the constructive and positive tone
expressed by the opposition uh front
bench um madame deck speaker the
honourable member for plymouth uh sutton
and devonport pointed out correctly that
this is putin's war this is not russia's
war this is putin's war and he is to
blame not the russian people all right
we are in agreement
in that he pointed out that the peril
the grave peril facing putin's army this
winter which will really test them and
manage that speaker i'm pleased to
confirm that we do indeed have a
long-term strategy
uh the tone of that i think has been set
up uh again by the prime minister in new
york and uh our collective institutional
efforts will be uh working in alliance
with that the integrated review will of
course will evolve it's a working
document and is inherently correct but
it will evolve
as time passes and there are robust
plans in place management to ensure that
the supply of end laws and other
munitions both in terms of what we give
you our ukrainian allies and what we
need for ourselves are energetically
being put in place i'm pleased to see
the new mr fence procurement uh joining
me on the front bench this afternoon um
the uh the honourable uh gentleman for
cardiff south and pennath gave some
moving reflections on his recent visit
to ukraine and i think uh usefully
pointed out about the remarkable resolve
of the ukrainian force and i think that
word resolve has expressed all you need
to know really about ukrainian
capability we are in absolute agreement
with that uh on that he mentioned some
issues with the trade i will write to me
on those but i do believe those are
important uh issues in in the broader
picture madam dex speaker we were
honored to have uh the our former prime
minister the writing will member for
uxbridge and south reislip uh speak to
us i know he's not in this place because
of a former uh uh
an appointment but he was right to point
out that this war is a shameful war of
conquest and russia's youth management
is being sacrificed on the altar of uh
putin's ego uh he pointed out that
putin's rhetoric is
pu because he's weak not because he's
strong and his singular achievement his
singular achievement putin's singular
achievement in ukraine has been to unify
the west you mentioned the leadership of
uh president zielinski i think we've all
been moved by that and the recent images
of madame zelenska coming over for state
funeral last week and i think we're all
grateful for uh the uh the bomb formed
by our former prime minister and uh the
presidency which is now being taken up
by our new prime minister the great
democracies uh the honorable gentleman
said must have the stomach to stand up
to tyranny this winter and i know uh
madame jet speaker uh we all we all
agree with that and our new prime
minister has been very clear about that
in new york in her speech last night
resolve is what we will all show
uh madam next week the honorable
gentleman for glasgow south gave some
very useful reflections on his recent
visit
and he warned us about we he warned that
we should be aware of the putin
whisperers which i thought was a very
very useful lens through which to see
this he pointed out that the war could
stop tomorrow if russia just stopped
attacking but of course if ukrainians
stopped defending ukraine would cease to
exist i thought that was a very useful
lens through which to see this uh
situation and we are in agreement uh on
this and we're grateful for the support
the continued support of his party uh
the honourable gentleman for bournemouth
gave some interesting reflections on
grain uh and uh the weaponization of
food and energy by president putin and
the and the broader strategic issues at
stake uh the honourable member for
abraham gave some personal reflections
on his time in the british council in in
in russia and used that as an important
lens through which we can see the sheer
bravery of those protesting against
uh putin's war machine and it seems man
black speaker that since yesterday
they're more likely to imprison more
people than they can actually draft as
new members of their own forces at this
rate uh the right honourable uh
gentleman uh for new force he's the
chair of the uh the security committee
uh pointed out that uh when it comes to
tyrants like putin cynicism has no
limits and hypocrisy has no boundaries
and i thought that was extremely useful
historical context but i can assure him
that we are energetically um making
plans to ensure that the the provision
of munitions for ukraine as well as
ourselves is sufficient as and i know
that collectively we all hate to see
three percent spent on our own domestic
defense sooner rather than later but i
think the government has very
commendable plans in place uh the
honourable uh gentleman for tibetan
again put it in historical concept by
reminding us that even if we're not
interested in war war is certainly
interested in us and he he called out
putin's lies and i joined him in that
calling out and he gave some interesting
reflections on his meetings in ukraine
with ukrainian mps and i think they have
been a model of courage and resolve and
i salute him in his reference to those
uh gannon uh friends uh the honourable
the right on wolf gentleman for north
somerset um gave a very useful
description of the arc of putin's
aggression over the years of course this
war is not seven months old madame takes
speaker this war started many years ago
it started with putin's statement at the
munich security conference 2007 the
invasion of georgia in 2008 and the
illegal annexation of crimea in 2014 so
um that was a very useful context in
which to to see this uh challenge and he
also gave some interesting thoughts on
the broader strategic situation with
regard to
the challenge by russia in the balkans
and malign activity in the balkans and
of course also the malign influence and
the supply of drone munitions by iran
the honourable gentleman for chingford
and woodford green who is i think on his
way back
gave some gladstone context of the
debate
pointing out that freedom has no greater
bulwark
than the breasts of free men and women
freedom is not free monetary speaker
and we are all facing the price
individually uh in houses up down the
country this winter because of the the
sharp rise in energy prices uh he
pointed out that president putin thinks
he can split us but of course i would
offer him reassurance that we are
resolute and of course he made some
interesting uh strategic remarks about
the relationship between this uh
conflict and china china is watching and
when it comes in this new era of global
competition uh we are essentially
deterring china in europe and that's
important to remember the honourable
general
for sterling um
reiterated his the support of his party
for which i was most grateful uh made
some interesting comments about
sanctions my honourable friend from
rutland and melton made some good points
about war crimes and preventing sexual
violence in conflict i am pleased to
confirm that we have established with
our partners
the atrocity crimes action group and we
will be hosting a conference in november
on preventing sexual violence and
conflict uh in which i know she will be
interested
the honourable
lady from putney reflects on her own
personal experiences in ukraine and
as did the general general huntington
my friend from the isle of wight i
regret had very little time to give some
of his expertise but we we do treat uh
these issues very safely and he referred
to the umbilical cord
between
our ukrainian allies and ourselves and
i'm grateful for his contribution many
other members made contributions which i
haven't got time to cover from
birkenhead cotswolds and hell in the
south glen ethnic devises western
berkshire rise lip and pinna and
strangford but in conclusion uh madam
deputy speaker i would say that we
his our government remains absolutely
committed uh to continuing our support
for ukraine
as winter approaches uh ukraine's
resolve will be tested and our resolve
will be tested uh this war and the
humanitarian damage it is inflicting on
ukraine remains very very grim the
global economic consequences most
pressingly on energy and food prices
affect all of us so as the prime
minister made clear last night in new
york madam deputy speaker we must
remember that as we support ukraine we
are indeed defending our own way of life
we are standing for freedom for
democracy and the sovereignty of nations
and madam deputy speaker we will not be
deterred
before i put the question i i do want to
emphasize that it is important that
those who have spoken in the debate do
come back for the
wind-ups and come back in good time for
the wind-ups as well the question is
that this house has considered the
situation in ukraine as many as our of
that opinion say i
of the country no
i think the eyes have it the eyes have
it
we must now take the motion relating to
deferred divisions uh minister whit
moves
the question is the motion relating to
deferred divisions as many as our of
that opinion say aye
the country no
i think the eyes have it the eyes have
it
we now come to um motion number three on
sanctions
and i believe it may be convenient
to debate motions number three to six
together is the will of the house that
the motions be debated together
excellent
i call the minister to move motion
number three and speak to motions number
three to six
at the end of the debate i will put the
question on motion number three and then
ask the minister to move motions number
four to six formally i call minister
jesse norman to move notion number three
yes thank you very much indeed uh madam
deputy speaker i beg to move that this
house has considered the russia
sanctions eu exit amendment number 11
regulations
2022 a copy of which was laid before
this house on the 14th of july
the instruments before us
were laid
between the 14th and the 20th of july
and the powers provided by the sanctions
and anti-money laundering act 2018 and
make amendments to the russia sanctions
eu exit regulations 2019.
madam deputy speaker as you will know
and as the last debate has demonstrated
this house stands absolutely resolute in
its opposition to this illegal
aggressive invasion of ukraine by russia
in coordination
with our allies the united kingdom
continues to play a leading role in
introducing the largest and most severe
economic sanctions package that russia
has ever faced
the measures we are debating today are
designed to isolate russia's economy
still further and to target key
industries supporting
president putin's illegal war in ukraine
they are somewhat technical i hope the
house will forgive me if i go through
them in a little detail the first set of
regulations i will cover are the number
11 regulations they ban the export of
goods and technologies related to the
defense security and maritime sectors
they also prohibit the export of jet
fuel maritime goods and technology
certain energy related goods plus
sterling and european union bank notes
in addition these regulations ban the
import of goods such as fertilizer
metals chemicals and wood depriving
russia of a key export market together
these markets were worth some
585 million pounds last year
if i may add a further point the joint
committee on statutory instruments
concluded that three provisions in the
tenth amendment to the regulations went
beyond the powers conferred by the
sanctions act
madison's government has resolved this
by revoking the 10th amendment and
replacing it with the 11th i wish to
thank
the joint committee on statutory
instruments for their continued
engagement as we introduce further
secondary legislation rapidly in
response to this abhorrent war
i now turn to the number 12 regulations
which place fresh restrictions on
investments and services in russia these
are designed to hit revenue streams of
critical importance to the russian
economy the new measures prohibit
persons from being involved directly or
indirectly in acquiring land and
entities with a place of business in
russia in establishing joint ventures
with persons and entities connected with
russia and in opening representative
offices or establishing branches or
subsidiaries in russia the measures also
restrict the provision of investment
services related to these activities
there are some exceptions to the
provisions to prevent overlap with
existing regulations as well as
licensing and enforcement powers
yes of course
i'll ask the honourable general i thank
him for giving way um
is the he's talking about the services
now is there going to be further action
taken by her majesty's government to
prevent russian state entities like
gazprom and vt bank and the legal firms
that support them in this country to
continue to use the uk courts i've
written to the secretary of state
justice about such a matter because
there is a long list of cases that the
russian state and russian proxy entities
are using in the uk are taking in the uk
courts and that money ends up back in
the coffers of the russian government
i'm extremely grateful to my honorable
friend for his question and the house
recognizes his great expertise
in this area he will understand that i
am not going to comment on future
sanctions policy of this government but
he can take it as read that we are
looking extremely closely not just at
ways in which this escalating program of
sanctions that has
elaborated itself over the last few
months can be further extended but also
closing some of the loopholes that may
have been
directed if he wishes i will make
certain that my officials have sight of
that letter he's written and will write
to him on the matter specifically
if i may proceed now to turn to the
number 13 regulations these widen the
definition of scope of activities which
a person can now be designated
massive government has expanded the
definition of destabilizing undermining
or threatening the ukraine at ukraine
and supporting or obtaining a benefit
from the russian regime this brings into
scope many individuals and entities the
russian government's agencies and its
armed forces the number 13 regulations
make minor amendments the definition of
being involved in obtaining a benefit
from or supporting the government of
russia
these have the effect of broadening the
interpretation of being associated with
a designated person to include immediate
family members who may often and often
do hold assets on their behalf they also
provide an exception from trade
sanctions for humanitarian assistance
actively delivered in
non-government-controlled areas of the
donetsk and luhansk oblasts finally they
expand the definition of ownership in
relation to ships and aircraft and
correct errors and emissions in previous
regulation i'm happy to give away i'm
very grateful and i welcome to his place
um
he mentions family members that are
associated with sanctioned individuals
he will probably be aware of the case
but probably won't be able to comment on
it alisha usmanov who is attention by
the uk eu and the us
but has basically passed on
all his wealth some of it anyway 2.1
billion i think to his sister
who is outside the scope of the of our
current sanctions regimes will his
tightening up of sanctions which i
welcome
basically
mean that we can go after people like
his sister as well and hurt the assets
he holds on his behalf
as he has as he has brilliantly
anticipated i'm not in a position to
comment on any individual case but what
i can say is that these powers of
designation as to travel bans and asset
freezes now have a significantly wider
scope to include family members and i
take the point he has made in
in relation to that specific individual
i'm sure my officials will have noted it
and i thank him for his intervention the
fourth and final set of regulations
madame baker speaker is amendment number
14. these regulations introduce further
trade sector instrument number 14. these
regulations introduce further trade
sanctions the regulations prohibit the
export supply delivery and making
available of a comprehensive list of
critical goods energy related goods and
related ancillary services services on
which russia had relied on g7 nations
for their supply these goods had a
combined market value to russia of 365
million pounds last year the instrument
also bans the import acquisition supply
and delivery of russian coal entering
into force on the 10th of august this is
on top of prohibitions on the import
acquisition supply and delivery of
russian oil which will come into force
before the end of this year and at the
import of gold that directly or
indirectly originates in russia which
ended in force on the 21st of july
ancillary products and services on coal
oil and gold exported from russia are
also prohibited a further ban covers the
provision of business and management
consulting services public relations and
accounting services to persons connected
with russia madam deputy speaker these
hard-hitting new measures continue the
government's project of ratcheting up
the pressure on russia we will continue
to do this in close concert with our
allies until putin ends his illegal
invasion of ukraine and i commend these
regulations to the house
the question is number motion number
three as on the order paper shadow
minister stephen dowd
um thank you uh madam deputy speaker and
um indeed i'd like to welcome the new
other minister uh to his place for the
first time and i look forward to working
with him on these issues of sanctions
that i have done with um his many
predecessors and i welcome
the opportunity that we are discussing
um sanctions on russia once again um and
i'm pleased to see such a wide range of
issues being covered in today's measures
um which are mainly amendments but i did
have to ask madam deputy speaker the
first question why so many amendments
were needed the minister has answered uh
some of that and indeed the explanatory
notes do but you know i do note and i i
don't want to be seen in any way as a
criticism of the officials so i know do
incredibly hard work in putting these
together but there are an extraordinary
number of errors and emissions that
appear to be made and indeed the
minister has just confirmed and i think
it really does underlie the point have
made in many of these previous debates
on sanctions about the resourcing
and the assistance has been given to
these critical units in the fcdo and
elsewhere and whether that is enough i
know it's been expanded i know that
there are more officials um but really
we do need to have the the support in
the system to make sure we get these
things right first time because uh putin
and his cronies will be seeking every
single loophole and a mission and error
to try and circumvent these we
absolutely know they are doing that and
we'll try and do that and we must not
allow them to do so so i hope and i'll
come on some comments about that in
gcourse i hope the minister can um
explain that in his further remarks at
the end of this debate um obviously
ma'am deputy speaker over the last few
weeks we've seen remarkable progress by
ukrainian forces
in the east of the country and in the
south in an incredible counter-offensive
um and indeed ukrainians have shown
extraordinary courage strength and
ingenuity in the face of russian
aggression and those efforts uh thanks
also to our support and others and are
thankfully uh bearing uh fruit um but as
we enter a new phase of the conflict
it's more important than ever that we
show our firm resolve to stand behind
ukraine in every way not only in the
military
domain but also politically economically
uh diplomatically and crucially in terms
of the consequences that putin and his
cronies must face for their illegal and
barbara's actions um indeed as i
mentioned in the previous uh debate i've
just returned personally from a trip to
kiev and the areas around it and again
refer again to my um impending
declaration of interest as a guest of
yalta european strategy
but i was deeply deeply moved by the
spirit courage and bravery shown not
only by president zelinski but by all of
his ministers all of his officials
members of parliament and members of
civil society and every ukrainian
citizen
but i returned with a deep sense of
urgency
and a commitment personally
and a solemn duty to do everything that
we can
to end this egregious display of
aggression violence and cruelty by
president putin and we've seen that
sadly
so brutally in the scenes from israel
the mass graves um the torture the
stories coming out of there we heard in
the previous debate about sexual
violence uh we heard some truly horrific
things on our visit too and we saw for
our own eyes and the destruction of
civilian infrastructure um so the former
uh minister uh now uh foreign secretary
informed me back in may that um there
were 150 individuals working full-time
in the sanctions task force in the fcdo
and that the ofs i had at least double
in size but i've tried to get some
further clarity about the resourcing
going in and i asked it in the last two
debates i was promised a letter back
from the ministers i haven't had that i
really do hope that the new minister can
chase up and get some answers because
you know we support these sanctions we
support these measures but it's only
right that we as the opposition are able
to scrutinize and understand whether the
government is properly uh resourcing
this and i also want to ask what extra
financial resources have been given to
those bodies and what conversations the
minister has had with the national crime
agency to ensure the proper enforcement
um on those who breach the sanctions
regime and indeed i asked in the last
debate on sanctions um questions about
the potential circumvention of uh
sanctions there have been numerous
allegations that have been put to me um
in a range of industries and others
where russia is attempting to use third
countries it's been suggested to me for
example in the steel industry um we've
discussed measures and there are
measures contained in here on on those
sorts of products where it's using third
countries um to potentially uh uh export
steel and other key products and some of
which are ending up in the uk and
elsewhere across the west in countries
that are imposing these sanctions that
is an absurd situation man deputy
speaker and i do hope the minister can
provide more information on that on what
we are doing to close these loopholes um
which they are attempting to use because
we can have the toughest regime on paper
but if practically they're finding ways
around it that is not acceptable
i was also struck on the visit to kiev
about uh the importance of ratcheting
the sanctions up and indeed many of the
measures uh proposed today in these
orders um are about expanding uh the
sanctions that is that is a good thing
um but it's crucial that we are working
with some of the best minds around the
world to look at other areas where we
can bring pressure and indeed um mcfall
the former um us ambassador to uh
to russia and also um others including
in the ukrainian government there is a
working group looking at additional ways
that they can expand these sanctions and
make them tougher i was concerned to be
told that apparently there's no uk
representative on that group and i
wondered if the minister could clarify
why that's the case and if it isn't the
case that we have a member on that group
we need to have somebody on there
because we need to be uh leading there
with the united states and others um
with our friends and allies in the
european union to ensure that we have
the toughest broadest and deepest regime
and that we think about innovative ways
in which we can really hit those people
around putin
who are providing uh the backing
financially and otherwise for his
actions in ukraine
in the detail of the sanctions packages
being announced today there are many
welcome things prohibiting the import of
oil coal gold and the export to russia
of maritime equipment oil refining
technology jet fuel other materials
absolutely critical and obviously the
labour party welcomes the government's
movement on those um but one area um did
raise some concerns for me was the
prohibition on the export of goods and i
quote um from the the documents um have
uh potential use for internal oppression
now obviously
that is a good thing that that's
including these packages but i do have
to ask madame deputy speaker
why there was any possibility that uk
public or private bodies were ever
providing russia with materials that
might be used for internal oppression in
the first place and i hope that the
minister can explain to us uh what kind
of exports have been going on in that
matters you know this this war didn't
start uh just a few seven months ago um
it started 2014 and far beyond that and
we know of putin's internal repression
against democratic composition and
others um for years i seriously hope
that we have not been providing uh
supports them that could have been used
to quash uh that uh internal opposition
in russia
and indeed um the expansion also refers
to microorganisms and
toxins um again i would want to
understand what assessment has been made
of the volumes of any such material that
have made its way from the uk to russia
and why that change had not been brought
to the house
sooner um you know these are very very
serious uh matters you know things can
be used you know particularly given
russia's record um in using uh weapons
of mass destruction including in this
country um i seriously hope we have not
or any uk company been exporting any
materials that have got to russia in
this way so the designations in
amendment 792 again are welcome but i
come back to the issue of swiftness and
uh responsiveness and why seven months
into this phase of the war we're only
designate we're only debating this
designation uh today um
i want to ask the minister as well
whether the government and i've asked
this in all the previous debates on on
sanctions has any further specific
proposals to not only freeze assets but
also to confiscate and sequester those
assets rather than just freezing them um
not least because of the huge costs that
are involved in continuing to support
ukraine which absolutely we must do
but also the clear costs that there are
going to be in reconstruction um in
making sure that ukraine can develop and
survive
after this war is over and indeed this
request was made to us by many of the
ukrainian government and other officials
members of parliament from many many
parties while we were there in kiev just
weeks ago
they want to see that done and it's been
done in a number of other countries and
other countries are looking at how they
can sequester and use assets further i
know this isn't straightforward i know
that it would potentially require
further alleged change but can the
minister give some clarity on that
we also have the issue raised about
travel by individuals that are under
these sanctions regimes um
designated
the issue of the issuing of tourist
visas um to russians and whether that
should be allowed i certainly don't
think it should be um and also the
question was raised with is about
designating um uh putin's united russia
party as a state sponsor of uh terrorism
or as a terrorist organization just as
the way that we have done uh with
hezbollah hamas and other
parties in other locations that are
sponsoring terrible and heinous acts of
aggression and crimes against humanity
what are the government's thoughts on
those proposals um
the uh the scope of these sanctions
measures of course is is wide and i
think i think shows the uh uh the the
resolve that we do have um to tackle
those
who are backing uh putin um but we must
deal with that wider ecosystem around
those who are backing him and i know
we've had the economic crime bill
published today um we've got to tackle
that whole ecosystem of the london lord
dramat all of those individuals who have
been backing and sustaining his regime
and i certainly hope that in the debates
to come we will see some tough action
taken in that regard but overall madden
deputy speaker um labour wholeheartedly
supports the measures outlined today but
i hope the ms will be able to answer
some of the detailed questions that i
have asked our sanctions regime is
integral to britain's role in supporting
ukraine and holding putin's regime
accountable for the act of violence it
continues to perpetrate against the
civilians across ukraine this winter the
people of ukraine are going to weather
the storm even more
a difficult storm of the brutal
egregious and unconscionable war of
aggression that they've faced and we
need to back their bravery by being
brave and bold in the sanctions and not
providing sucker for any of those who
are supporting this aggression
eastwood
speaker i would like to join the
honourable member for first good moulton
in welcoming the minister to his place
i also find myself in the strange
position of thanking the opposition
minister for raising the issue of
loopholes and
this is something that is specific to my
constituency and relates to a business
within my constituency that's been
affected potentially by loopholes so um
really i wanted to speak on behalf of a
company called jd hellunite systems and
i'd also like to clarify that i will be
supporting the sanctions and not be
calling the division i'm sure there's a
relief all around on that one but
there is an issue with one of the
companies in my constituency alienet
systems they're a group of companies
based in juicebreak
which sells a wide variety of metal
based products
including aluminium steel and iron based
garage doors
before the invasion
jd uk only not revenue was 30 million
pounds
it's now reduced to 20 million pounds
per annum
they employed a hundred people now that
has reduced to 70 people and this could
be down to a potential loophole in
amendment number 11 which should relate
to what actually should be on an equal
level with um the same schedule to be on
the belarus sanctions uh without trying
to obviously confuse everybody on this
one
uh they're pro the the company's
previous belarusian supplier how you
tech supplied aluminium and sectional
garage jaw that does has found a
potential loophole to avoid the impact
of sanctions on the import of products
containing steel and iron from belarus
and russia
the belarusian company has entered the
uk market directly after jd uk sees
trees trading with them
belarusians have claimed about 30
percent
of jd uk's iron and steel customers and
about 15 of their aluminium customers
through price dumping
this is a loss of about 10 million
pounds in revenue from a british
business and a business based in my
constituency
amendments schedule of schedule 2b the
republic of belarus sanctions
regulations 2022
banned the import of iron and steel
consigned from or originating in belarus
applying to all commodity codes
starting 72 or 73.
chapter 7 of the russian sanctions eu
exit amendment number 11 which is what
i'm referring to
covers iron and steel imports and
acquisitions under schedule 3b
however this not does not seem to extend
to the same range as noted for belarus
only including some elements of the 72
and 73 codes but not all one of jd uk's
products sectional garage doors which
contains steel and has a commodity code
starting
7308
is banned under the belarus amendment
but is still available to import if the
components are russian
i am sure the minister would agree that
the difference in sanctioned goods has a
significant potential to threaten jd
uk's business sales and encourages
alutec to export via russian
subsidiaries instead of belarus
this is an unintended consequence in
drafting the sanctions
currently there are no sanctions in
place regarding exports of aluminium
from belarus again with belarus and
company contacting several of my
constituents major customers
offering to supply them aluminium
profile
direct from their belarus factory
the lack of sanctions and or high enough
tariffs against aluminium exports could
again allow the belarusians to threaten
my constituents business sales within
the uk
with the current tariff regime on
belarus with the 35
made it unviable for my constituency to
continue
conducting business with belarus for
aluminium products but alitech in
belarus is diverting material through
russia and continuing to sell at very
attractive prices making more profit
than selling through my constituents
this my business suggests how you all
your nets suggest that unless the
loophole closes they're likely revenue
from aluminium could fall by another 10
million which would make the business
unviable
they also suggest that the tariff is
increased
and one minister considers to 100
against russia and belarus to make it
more consistent so i have
some questions for the minister and i
hope he's able to respond to this
first question is how will the
government make this position unviable
for russian and belarusian companies
that exploit these anomalies loopholes
whatever you want to refer to
and
will he support to support british
businesses please could he clarify
whether why there are such differences
between the belarusian and russian
sanctions and outline what would be done
to protect our markets the uk markets
and could he also and in summary give
reassurance that the business industry
only net um that he will take into
consideration so we can protect a
business that employs so many people in
my constituency thank you
snp spokesperson alan smith
thank you madam deputy speaker i always
remember that nobody criticizes a speech
for being too short but i think i can
excel myself today on this one
we support these measures we've called
for many of the measures that are in
them if they came to a vote which i
trust they won't we'd support three we'd
abstain on the fourth a couple of
general comments and i was very glad of
the outlining of the detail of them from
the minister we warmly welcome the
expansion of the definition of
associated with that has been abused
we're dealing with some of the
slipperiest people some of the best
advised people in the world and this is
an evolving situation so we're glad to
see that evolve with that
the further restriction on land interest
that's a key relevance to scotland and
we're glad to see that also the
tightening of energy sanctions is also
very significant for us given our energy
footprint and we won't really warmly
welcome the tightening of those
sanctions
i would though raise also my concern as
a more general point about the use of
third countries and brokers in
effectively laundering
russian energy assets we we have seen
this we've seen reports of india
particularly refining
various products and being sold on so we
do think that needs further attention
going forward i'd also be welcome it
would welcome a reassurance as i've
asked for before that the overseas
territories are properly tracked through
with all of these measures
because we are as i say
all of us tackling deeply slippery
people who are good at exploiting
loopholes we need to make sure that what
we do doesn't accidentally create
loopholes in the overseas territories
should be part of our effort
so we support these measures but i am
conscious of the hurt to the uk economy
as well under the impact assessments
we're looking at the best part of half a
billion pounds worth of hurt to the uk
economy and there's a number of uk
companies who are suffering from these
measures
who've acted in good faith through no
fault of their own so i think there
should be some greater consideration of
uk government support for those
companies on a case-by-case basis
clearly but a number of companies are
suffering through this and need greater
support than they've seen
more generally we will come back to
these these are not the the last sis
that we've seen on this subject
but i would like also a discussion about
what we're going to do with the assets
so seized and the money so sequestered
we've heard previously about calls for a
marshall plan to aid the reconstruction
of ukraine that is not legally easy i
acknowledge that fully and it's out with
the scope of these sanctions but i think
having a purpose for what we're going to
put these funds to would give urgency
and legitimacy to these sanctions and
would also give a bit of urgency about
where the actual destination point is
which is the reconstruction of a whole
and sovereign ukraine but we support
these measures thank you
absolutely very much madam deputy
speaker um
i'm again just going to make a few brief
points to the minister and come up with
some specifics uh like my honourable
friend just did but it's quite clear
that russia is is actively now trying to
get around sanctions on an industrial
scale we're seeing it in its use of tech
and microchips we're seeing it in
potentially selling
raw steel products to third parties
which then get re-exported back into
europe and we're seeing it as a minister
i'm sure will know in the passing of
assets to wives and kids and families
and you know in-laws and various types
along with the honourable uh honourable
gentleman from cardiff south in panama i
was also in that in care for that
delegation
likewise guest of the uh yorkshire
economic summit obviously declaring that
uh in due course but when we met folks
in kiev
there was a sense of urgency that as
well as doing all the great stuff we're
doing we need to be helping them to shut
down russia's ability to maintain a
multi-billion dollar monthly war effort
and therefore the sanctions regime was
absolutely vital in achieving that and
actually when it comes to specifics of
the oligarchs what they wanted was that
money going back to ukraine in war
war reparations coming to specific
elements and i mentioned this in my
question but i'd just like to build on
it for a couple of minutes
in uk courts russian state parties are
still bringing cases
is this right if successful those cases
the winnings from those cases go back
via russian proxies to the russian state
where they are used to continue to fund
the illegal invasion of ukraine as i
said i wrote to the honourable secretary
of state for justice and there are
another 10 members of parliament from
both sides of the house who have
co-signed that letter the 12th amendment
to the russian sanctions regulations
2019 act has already established that it
is a criminal offence to knowingly
provide the russian state and other
entities with funds or economic revolt
resources
what i'm asking is for the government to
look at whether this provision can be
imply it can be applied to the legal
winnings from ongoing litigation in uk
courts
i along with other signatories uh
10 of us i'm asking the government to
look to prevent russian state entities
gazprom vtb bank from using the legal
system to effectively conduct a form of
lawful against ukrainians as people may
know this is something that's been quite
close to my heart um this sort of amoral
offering of services to highly dubious
characters this is less revolting than
some of the intimidation they've done to
journalism campaigners but now because
of the situation with the war i think it
should be coming under the scope of of
government action
and we're asking specifically for um
for the following the introduction of
further sanctions against british law
firms and banks which do not comply with
existing sanctions regimes and an
amendment to hold managing partners
accountable for their work should they
be violating sanctions secondly the
direct prohibition for uk-based law
firms to represent entities controlled
by the government of the russian
federation including the bank of russia
and entities in which the the russian
state has a significant or controlling
interest
thirdly we're asking for her majesty's
treasury ministry of justice to address
and tell us what they're going to do
about ongoing litigation cases of which
there are at least half a dozen in
english and welsh courts to ensure that
the
russian federation is not evading the
sanctions regime and is not profiting
from winning those court cases and i
have a list of about eight of them and
the the big law firms includes fresh
fields vtb bank europe uh pcp bern
steptoe and johnson um a number of
russian state entities as well which is
in the letter that in the last few
minutes i have pinged to the honorable
gentleman so i would be most grateful if
the government could give a considered
response to those three points but also
on those current litigations as they are
going through the uk courts thank
you
oh
rich ford
thank you very much um just very briefly
the liberal democrats would very much
like to support uh these sis and um so
my comments are are brief
firstly i heard also the
proposal that
members of the united russia party be
considered
subject to to sanctions so this is
something that was proposed i think back
in the spring by the president of the
european parliament and i think is
something that could be considered for
any future sis
and one further point the the minister
will know uh because of his involvement
in the
higher education freedom of speech bill
that the that in base the research
collaboration advice team has been
really very useful to the higher
education sector in enabling
universities to support enforcement
around sanctions and around export
control and i would hope that um
in any slimming of the civil service
that happens in future months we hear
about the uh the purported cuts of 91
000 that the research collaboration
advice team in bays is is not hacked
back because they're doing some crucial
work in the enforcement of these
sanctions thank you
kevin hollywood uh thank you member to
speaker i won't turn the house too long
at all um i very much welcome these
measures and the uh and the reasons for
them as it says in the briefing the
measures were currently imposed in terms
of sanctions are insufficient so far we
need to get go further they are
effective though the evidence we've had
to the treasury select committee is
these sanctions are very effective
they're putting further pressure on
putin it's clearly hugely under pressure
at the moment right now anyway
but they are a dimmer switch rather than
a traditional light switch so it's very
important we
improve the efficacy of that dimmer
switch
i did raise the case earlier of alicia
usmanov and then because i think it's a
case in point not because i wanted a
direct answer that particular case but
um
what of course people look to these are
clever people with
very large resources and they can employ
the best people to help them to try and
evade sanctions there's two ways
principal ways they look to do that is
either use associates relatives and the
rest and it's good to hear the
provisions within this legislation that
there's tying up in this area in terms
of family members i'll follow that with
interest to see if it whether it works
with mr usmanov
the other way they do it is by using
very complex corporate vehicles of
course and again the
government's intending to legislate in
this area to try and improve
transparency around companies um if you
look at mr usmanov particularly he's got
a six hundred million pound yacht
that's something officers 600 million
yacht uh which is currently uh moored in
hamburg and the german authorities can't
identify they know it's his they can't
identify the uh his direct linkage to
the ownership of that yacht so they
can't impound it which is disappointing
the italians have
taken his villa away from in the italian
riviera but we can't identify who
exactly his direct connection with that
yacht
so we need to tighten up in the various
different areas as well to make it
easier a couple of measures i would just
uh suggest to the minister and whose
officials have sat there hopefully
listening to this um
is really something that actually bill
browder who's a name many of us are
familiar familiar many of us in this
debate who's been a fantastic champion
for to tackle dirty money around the
world he suggested something is um
clearly following the money is so
difficult these people are very clever
and use very clever advisors to hide the
money so falling is very difficult
if we brought forward legislation to say
that
where there was a sanctioned individual
all uk professional advisers who have
dealt with that individual have to open
their books to the authorities
so it would make it much easier then to
track that money through those very
complex shell companies and the like to
try and identify something follow the
money and then we can properly sanction
these people it would also potentially
deter some of our professional advisors
in this country from dealing with these
kind of uh highly suspect characters in
the first place so i think that's
something we should certainly hopefully
the minister will certainly consider
i will say i'm also very concerned in
terms of following the money by our
current current push uh from the
treasury we've seen or we have seen that
from the treasury in the past to make
the uk a crypto international crypto hub
a world leading hub for crypto
one thing we know about crypto it's
designed not to be regulated although
they will tell you that money is a
there's a log so it can tell you what if
there's a trail an audit trail for all
the money the regulators can't see it
and that's how it's designed so our
regulators in my view we'll never be
able to track this stuff through crypto
yet we we seem to be saying we want
uk to be a crypto leading crypto uh
finance center and i think that's
something we should reconsider
another measure the eu has recently
added the magnitsky act which the eu has
and the uk has as two although
that i can't call it now but um
but currently that only covers human
rights the eu is adding corruption to
those uh measures too so somebody who is
guilty of corruption or even suspected
of corruption we could then uh
do asset freezes and travel restrictions
um
the shadow minister and friend of the
member
for the isle of wight mentioned about
sequestering assets confiscating them
redistributing them it's a really
interesting point one thing we
absolutely believe in in this house or
most of us do uh property rights so this
is pretty tricky stuff just taking
assets off people and giving them to
somebody else so we've got a we can't
undermine our own values in the in the
uh
in the quite right the the uh you know
our attempts to try and use some of that
money to appear reparations to ukraine
one thing we could do much more easily
we hold about 30 billion pounds of
russian foreign currency reserves which
is currently seized
um that's protected the moment by uh
sovereign immunity
we could change those rules pretty
quickly it's not difficult for us to
identify or establish criteria around
which we can set aside those measures
and i think clearly russia is guilty in
international law it's illegal invasion
of ukraine it cannot be difficult for us
to be able to say in this basis then
those that 30 billion pounds of assets
can go toward to help ukraine instead of
british taxpayers having to fund
the the help we're providing ukraine
um and finally just in terms of economic
crime
legislation is coming through i think
second reading on the 12th of october
some other measures in that that's
missing currently that would have a
profound effect on this stuff
we know that
all the money that came out of russia
that's flowed into these oligarchs back
pockets went through some of our some
leading banks around the world some of
the major banks around the world not
least dansky bank through its uh
division in estonia 200 billion pounds
of money laundering went through that
division of that bank the bank must have
known the bank the the people who run
that bank must have known its return on
capital employed in that branch in
estonia
was uh normal returning capital employed
by bank is around 20 return on capital
employed was 426
that must have stood out pretty clearly
to the to the people who run those banks
and uh if we have brought introduced
measures within the economic crime
bill part two to say if you fail to
prevent money laundering or fraud or
false accounting for example then you as
a corporate but also as an individual
could be held to account that would have
a profound effect on the people that are
facilitating this stuff in terms of
clamping down on it stopping it
happening that so i know there's not one
for the minister on duty today but
certainly something i'll be mentioning
mentioning on the 12th of october i
thank you for your time i'm mr speaker
minister
very much indeed uh speak i thank
everyone who's uh
spoken in this very interesting debate
it is testimony
to the
intense interest and passion that the
question of the russian invasion of
ukraine has raised in this house
that even on topics as apparently
technical as this we can have such a
vigorous and energetic debate i think
everyone who's
spoken
i would say let me let me
pick up all of the points or as many of
the points i possibly can that have been
raised the owner of thirskan morton
who's just spoken um spoke truly when he
talked about the highly effective nature
of the sanctions so far as evidenced by
the treasury uh select committee i would
say it is more like turning off a light
the danger is that the light may be the
dimmer switch may be activated the other
way that's one of the things that we are
constantly having to deal with and this
i'm going to talk a little bit about
more generally it's a response in part
to the honourable member for speaking to
vote for the opposition uh because this
is an evolving situation he's mentioned
bill browder very interesting and
brilliant man who i've i've met and the
idea of opening books i think that's a
very interesting idea we've had a lot of
interesting ideas in this house and one
of the strengths of this open
parliamentary debate that makes our
system so much stronger than the russian
alternative is that we are willing to
evolve our own response rapidly in
response to public opinion and
suggestions like that i thank him for
that he makes a point about crypto
i think that's right i think it's
important to say that crypto assets are
treated exactly the same way as any
financial asset and therefore we would
expect these uh uh measures to be as uh
as as human as as um uh widely respected
by those entities even if the
enforcement proves to be something that
requires further work
giving way but
i've just noticed that we're going to be
debating a whole
more set of amendment regulations to
sanctions not only against russia but
against a whole bunch of other regimes
on the 11th of october to deal with the
very fact that crypto assets are not
treated in the same way as other
financial assets for sanctions at the
moment in fact actually there appears to
be a whole series of loopholes which the
government's only getting around to
dealing with on the 11th of october we
really need to move a lot faster on this
and we need to be up to speed with what
is actually happening and how people are
using these markets
i don't think you can move faster than
having a debate within two days in fact
one and a half days of parliament
resuming after the uh interval of uh uh
hermes of the queen's uh uh uh
unfortunate passing uh uh the the rules
apply and of course there will be and
it's a further rebuttal to the point he
made that somehow the suggestion that um
you can make uh something uh a perfect
uh uh as it were as though it was set in
stone forever of course not this is a
rapidly evolving situation where we
talked about law fair is exactly right
we have some very well healed
well-resourced individuals using all of
their resources to try to thwart this as
corporates and as individuals and that's
why the response must continue to evolve
and it will continue
to do so let me mention the point about
uh raised by the owner of tibetan and
honeyton um he should know that the uh
uh office for sanctuary uh offsea the
office which enforces financial
sanctions implementation in the treasury
has
more than doubled this financial year
and the response that is being made is
being taken very seriously and there is
a continuous effort to
build the sanctions capability across
government and i take the point he makes
about advice in higher education sector
i can also tell him that there's very
effective team assisting businesses in
this country dealing with this uh in the
dit and we take this issue extremely
seriously i remember um the isle of
wight raised the point about
uh lawfare and mentioned the name of
freshfields i was sorry to hear that
name mentioned uh given the respect to
which that firm is held across this
country but that's interesting you
should do so i wish it weren't true i
hope it isn't but it's interesting that
he mentions it
i actually rather not i've got little
time but let me just say this uh he
talks about the extension of designation
and of course this makes the point about
the evolving nature of the threat it's
important to get the sanctions in
quickly but as the
uh uh as the responsible so we must uh
evolve it and of course that's what
we've done uh being associated with a
designated person uh now
includes uh obtaining a financial
benefit or other material benefit or
being an immediate family member that
means a wife a husband a civil partner a
parent or step parent a child or step
child a step sibling or step sibling a
niece or nephew an aunt uncle a
grandparent and a grandchild so that is
an example of evolving the response as
he would have wished
the honourable member for sterling uh uh
uh absolutely rightly pointed out the
slippery nature of what we are dealing
with and i've been highlighting that in
my response he talked about
the danger of laundering
energy and uh of course there is there
are
technically difficult questions to be
addressed as to how that is to be
characterized and especially when uh as
it were forms of energy or changed he
talked about property tracking through
the uh overseas territories he'll be
aware that this rule these rules apply
in the overseas territories by rural
council uh in the same way that we would
apply them here and i thank him for the
uh response i do think he heard slightly
in talking about the sanctions the
legitimacy of sanctions in part uh
depending on the asset seized the
legitimacy of sanctions lies in the fact
that we are fighting a
a a an aggressive nation that is seeking
to overturn our way of life and the
foundations of liberal democracy i don't
think any further legitimacy is required
for that to be a worthwhile thing for us
to do my honourable friend the memphis
dewsbury uh raised the very important
issue of alumet in his constituency i
thank him very much for that i thank him
for writing to me in advance uh with the
the detail i understand the sense of a
the loss they've actually appeared to
have incurred and also the sense of
concern they have and i will be writing
to him specifically on this issue and i
thank him for raising it in this debate
um let me come to the questions raised
by the member for carter south and
panath um
a question he asked was why why so many
uh as it were changes and moments needed
well of course because the first
instinct in a war situation is to get
these sanctions on the books as quickly
as possible we know they've been
affected because the treasury committee
have reminded us of that i have we have
plenty of other evidence that should be
the case but as the response evolves so
we need to evolve it and as the concerns
about humanitarian impact about
unfairness evolves so inevitably the
sanctions picture becomes not merely
more widespread and more expensive but
more complex and that's right that it
should be
so uh we um he raised the question about
a letter uh that he had written to i
will ensure that that letter is sent
obviously it's been disturbed by the
advance of government and uh the funeral
of her majesty but i will ensure that
that letter is sent he talked about
resourcing i've talked about the
increase in the size of offsea and
that is matched by the seriousness with
which this issue is taken across
government
he talked he raised a whole series of
other more technical issues and i'm
happy to write to him uh in more detail
to respond to those but with that i will
invite the house to support these
amendments
the question is motion number three as
on the order paper as many as our of
that opinion say and
of the country no i think the eyes have
it the eyes have it
um with the um leave of the house
i will put motions number four five and
six together
um
so
motions number four five and six on
sanctions minister to move formally
the question is motions number four
number five and number six as on the
order paper as many as our of that
opinion say i
of the country no
i think the eyes have it the eyes have
it
we now come to motions number seven to
16 on business of the house i call the
uh
deputy leader of the house to move
motion number seven and speak to motions
number seven to sixteen
mission mandate speaker i move those
formally if there are anything that
comes up in the debate perhaps i can
deal with that in a wind-up
the question is motion number seven as
on the order paper
the question is motion number seven as
on the order paper as many as are of
that opinion say i
the country no i think the eyes have it
the eyes have it we now come to motion
number eight on
sittings in westminster hall 11th of
october minister to move formally
the question is motion number eight on
as on the order paper as many as are of
that opinion say aye
the country no
i think the eyes have it the eyes have
it we now come to motion number nine on
election of select committee chairs
notice of election and deadline for
nominations minister to move forward
the question is not emotion number nine
as on the order paper as many as of that
opinion say aye
the country no i think the eyes have it
the eyes have it we now come to motion
number ten on the national security bill
program number two uh minister to move
forward
the question is no uh motion number ten
as on the order paper as many as our of
that opinion say aye
the country no i think the eyes have it
the eyes have it we now come to motion
number 11 on leveling up and
regeneration bill program number two
minister move forward the question is
motion number 11 as on the order paper
as many as our of that opinion say i
the country no i think the eyes have it
the eyes have it we now come to motion
number 12 on trade australia and new
zealand bill
motion number two minister to move
formally
[Music]
the question is motion number 12 as on
the order paper as many as our other
means say i
the country no i think the eyes have it
the eyes have it we now come to motion
number 13 on financial services and
markets bill program number two minister
to move formally
the question is motion number
13 as on the order paper as many as are
that opinions say
the country no i think the eyes have it
the eyes have it we now come to motion
number 14 on business of the house
private members bills minister to move
formally
the question is no motion number 14 as
on the order paper as many as our of
that opinion say i
the country no i think the eyes have it
the eyes have it we now come to motion
number 15 on 10-minute rule motions
minister to move formally
the question is motion number 15 as on
the order paper as many as our of that
opinion say aye
the country no i think the eyes have it
the eyes have it
we now come to motion number 16 on
business of the house health and social
care levy repeal bill minister to move
formally
the question is motion number 16 as on
the order paper as many as are of that
opinion say i
the contrary no i think the eyes have it
the eyes have it we now come to motion
number 17 on adjournment conference
recess minister to move formally
the question is as on the
order paper as many as our that opinion
say i
of the country no
i think the eyes have it
the eyes have it
we now come to motion number 18 on
electricity uh minister to move formally
the question is as on the order paper as
many as our vatican say i
the country no i think the eyes have it
the eyes have it we now come to motion
number 19 on environmental protection
minister to move formally
the question is as on the order paper as
many as our of that opinion say i
of the country no i think the eyes have
it the eyes have it
i can now announce the new arrangements
that mr speaker has determined for the
elections of the chairs of the science
and technology and foreign affairs
committees
nominations for both elections will
close at 3 30 pm
on tuesday the 11th of october if there
is more than one candidate for either
election the ballot will take place on
wednesday the 12th of october between 11
a.m and 2 30 p.m in the i division lobby
a note with more detail about these
arrangements and the nomination process
will be made available in the vote
office
petition and mclaughlin
thank you madam deputy speaker small and
medium-sized businesses are the
lifeblood of our local economies but
energy price increases threaten to
[ __ ] them in addition when times are
tough is the public sector and the third
sector our communities turn to whether
it's the warm banks that glasgow city
council is having to open up so everyone
has a warm place to go if they cannot
heat their homes or youth centres like
the brunswick which welcomes around 20
60 young people every night where they
learn have fun stay safe and warm
they each provide a vital lifeline for
people to provide that lifeline they
need certainty our businesses need
certainty the petitioners therefore
request that the house of commons urges
the government to match the energy price
guarantee period for domestic consumers
of two years for small and medium-sized
businesses public sector organizations
and charities allowing certainty and
stability in their dealings and further
urges the government to extend the
eligibility criteria to allow access to
the scheme for businesses public sector
organizations and charities who may may
have agreed their energy contracts prior
to the first of april 2022 and the
petitioners remain etcetera
petition energy crisis support for small
and medium-sized businesses the public
sector and charities
i beg to move that this house do no job
the question is that this house do now
adjourn mr robin walker
thank you madam deputy speaker and it's
great honor to secure this debate on an
issue very dear to my heart i think in
recent weeks warriors fans have grown
accustomed to the odds delay and i
apologize to all those who may have
tuned in
at five or five thirty um but i i hope
i'm able to um evoke their concerns
during the course of this debate i'm
very grateful uh to my honourable friend
for tudzi for taking up his role and i
look forward to his response i'm
grateful for clarks in the table office
for accommodating me at the first
possible opportunity after the period of
mourning sadly this is debate which is
all too urgent and timely worcester
warriors are a rugby club which has been
at the heart of our county and community
for decades and they follow in the
footsteps of the worcester rugby
football club which has played rugby
union in worcester for over 150 years
in the era of professional rugby which
roughly coincides with my adult lifetime
the club has been based at six ways and
throughout my adult life i've been a
supporter the first game of professional
rugby i ever watched was in worcester
then in north midlands division two and
although never a player myself i've worn
the club colours of golden blue ever
since when i gave worcester rugby shirts
to my two nephews then aged four and
eight they described them as their uncle
robin's suits as they had to often see
me wearing mine as for so many other
local folk the club has provided a forum
for intergenerational bonding an arena
for local pride in the gathering space
for pressure at special events the rise
and rise of worcester who subsequently
became the warriors was no accident but
the result of the vision and drive of
one man worcester's most successful 20th
century entrepreneur and philanthropist
for late great cecil duckworth it isn't
possible to overstate cecil's
contribution to our city the boiler he
first made in his garage became the
prototype of the modern combi boiler and
the basis for worcester heat systems now
known as worcester bosch the biggest
private sector employer in my
constituency his endowment of the
duckworth worcestershire trust continues
to make an enormous contribution to our
local environment and his generous
support for acorns children's hospice
made their worcester hospice a reality
his greatest and most prominent local
legacy however was the rise of the
warriors i was privileged long before i
became worcester's mp to know cecil and
his family and to be able to watch rugby
at six ways with him i recall watching a
pre-season friendly between worcester
and oxford university while i was a
student there and learning that even
great figures such as cecil and his
opposite number at the university rugby
team who happened to be a former head of
the civil service and distinguished
member of the other place were capable
of colourful language when the referee's
decision went against their team
i celebrated with him an astonishing six
successive league wins and promotions as
with his support the warriors as they
became in 2002 moved all the way up from
north midland division two to national
league one the league just beneath the
rugby premiership and i will remember
the ecstatic feeling when our team
unbeaten after 26 wins in 26 matches
first one promotion to the top flight in
the 2003 full season like so many fans i
experienced the pain of relegation in
2009 followed by joy at return to the
top flight in my first year as
worcester's mp
all of this was masterminded by cecil
and his passion to see the club not just
achieve but cement their position at the
top of english rugby when i first
attended six ways there was one stand
with capacity of around two thousand
today we have a twelve thousand capacity
stadium which is not only one of the
best equipped professional rugby
stadiums in the country but also a venue
for low key local cultural events from
concerts to the trooping of the mercian
regiment's colour quite rightly a bust
of cecil adorns the warrior stadium and
he was named life president of the club
before his sad death from cancer in 2020
while some might say this is just a
sports club in worcester we know it's
much more than that so many fans have
spoken out about what the club means to
them and the staff and heads of
department as well as the players have
shown a spirit of togetherness in the
toughest of times of which settle
himself would be proud i don't have time
to echo all the sentiments of fans in
this short debate but so many have
expressed what the club means to them
movingly and with real passion i would
commend to the house looking at the
hashtags together we are warriors and
save our warriors on social media
the club is also home to one of the most
effective and successful community
foundations in the rugby world a key
part of settle's vision and the
foundation reaches more than fifteen
thousand deprived and vulnerable people
across the west midlands championing
accessible rugby delivering innovative
and inspiring lessons in schools
including special schools and
alternative provision using the power of
rugby to build confidence and unlock
opportunity i've lost count of the
number of times i've been downstairs in
this place to congratulate the
foundation on winning awards at the
premier rugby community awards sadly all
of this is now at risk
the current owners of the club have
brought it to the brink of financial
collapse and for all that they claim
that this is the impact of the pandemic
they have failed to maintain the trust
of their employees keep their promises
to local stakeholders or set out clear
plans to reassure their many creditors
their background in property development
and the various complex transactions
through which they have maneuvered parts
of the club and its land have raised
serious doubts about their genuine
commitment to keeping professional rugby
at six ways the news was on 17th of
august they were served with a winding
up notice by hmrc led dozens of my
constituents to contact me with their
concerns about the future of the club on
the 26th of august i convened a meeting
of local mps with council leaders from
all three southwestern councils and the
county to discuss the concerns about the
possibility of development land being
separated from the club and risks of a
viability of the stadium and the team
we agreed a joint statement including
crucially the leaders of which haven
council the planning authority and
worcestershire county council with its
responsibilities for economic
development and that read we will do all
we can to
retain professional elite rugby at six
ways and protect the extraordinary
legacy of the late cecil duckworth and
his family we jointly call on the
worcester warriors owners to act in the
best interests of the club the players
the staff the fans and the community
served by the club including the
warriors community foundation we think
it is essential that the club and all of
its property assets remain linked whilst
we recognize that there are significant
opportunities for development of the
six-way site we believe that these need
to be utilized for the purposes of
sustaining the rugby club and the wider
ambitions of the local sporting
community we are all very clear we are
prepared to work supportively with
potential investors to find a positive
outcome for the future of worcester
warriors
since that statement was published i'm
grateful to have messages of support
from worcester's labour mayor city
councillors the supporters trust and the
president of the amateur side wrfc i'm
also grateful for the close attention
that has been paid to the situation by
the rfu premier rugby limited and dcms
over recent weeks and particularly for
the patients of the current secretary of
state with the bombardment of messages
i've been sending her ever since her
appointment her predecessor set out to
me that the sole focus of the department
has been in trying to protect the club
and future of professional rugby at six
ways amen to that
following our statement local mps were
invited to meet with the current owners
and hear their plans we accepted
assurances that they were negotiating to
sell the whole of the club together and
but whatever formal structures were in
place around the land there was no
intent to separate or sell parts of it
to the document detriment of the club we
were told that the club was in
negotiations with a number of parties
and that payroll would certainly be made
the following week
the following week the owners failed to
make payroll staff were not paid at all
on the day their wages were due and
players did not receive their pay on
time this triggered players at the club
to serve 14 days notice that their
contracts had been breached posing an
existential threat to the continuation
of the team and professional rugby at
six ways on the same day mobile phones
and management at the club stopped
working as the bills hadn't been paid
and cars were taken away from players
because leases had not been maintained
academy players were reportedly made
homeless as they lost access to their
accommodation
in the days of confusion and deep
concern that followed the players were
eventually paid late and sometimes
irregularly but together selflessly they
decided to withdraw their notice and
return to being in contract the staff of
whom around 200 of permanent full-time
staff and a further 200 part-time were
offered 65 of their wages with the rest
to follow once the deal had been secured
this has so far not been forthcoming and
i'm told there are still a number of
staff who've received no pay at all
it was at this stage that the five
worcester mps who were free to do so put
out our joint statement calling for the
club to be taken into administration i
know all six of us were there in spirit
the owners fired back an angry release
but stressed all the risks of
administration and stated that they had
to have no offers of help from mps or
councils prior to our statement the
latter i have to say is simply a
provable lie
their case against administration was
four-fold but it would reduce the value
of the club's p share its share of
proceeds from premiership television and
marketing rights due to a call option
being available to prl to buy it back in
the event of administration but it would
leave local creditors out of pocket but
it would lead to automatic relegation
from the premiership and that it would
lead season tax ticket holders without
the value of their tickets each of these
assertions is challengeable and from my
own conversations with prl and the rfu i
know that neither triggering the call
option on the p-share nor relegation
should be considered a certainty
i urge them to do all they can in the
event of an orderly administration to
enable warriors to stay in the
premiership with a point deduction if
necessary and to ensure that any new
management and investors taking the club
on have access to its pshare there is no
reason why an administrator or new
investor should not be able to honor
season tickets and local suppliers who
from bitter experience have no trust in
the current owners to pay their bills
may stand a greater chance of recouping
some of what they're owed through an
orderly process
through continued uncertainty and
disorder
since that time i'm afraid the season
the situation off the pitch has not
improved players have gone above and
beyond to turn out and play for the club
despite the problems with their pay
staff have moved heaven and earth to
ensure that games can go ahead meeting
the challenges set by the rfu and prl
even after wi-fi and internal emails
went down with no support from their
directors and owners but worcester
warriors players have scored tries
against london irish exeter chiefs and
gloucester is a remarkable achievement
in these most difficult possible
circumstances and the solidarity that's
been shown by each of those clubs
reflects the desire of all rugby fans to
see the warriors survive but the
university of worcester warriors the
lady team ladies team actually won their
alliance cups fixture against harlequins
is truly spectacular the heroic efforts
of underpaid or unpaid staff have been
praised by fans of clubs across the
country but they have barely been
acknowledged by the current owners
instead we've had reports of staff
facing disciplinary action for daring to
point out the string of broken promises
that have been made to them and of key
people being mysteriously unavailable
when legal or insurance documentation
needed to be signed
through all of this the team under the
tutelage of steve diamond has maintained
a spirit of unity that is admirable in
the extreme
the owners told local mps last week that
they were on the brink of a deal to sell
85 percent of the club's equity and that
there would be new money to repay staff
the proportion of wages owing and secure
all the commitments to a premiership
before the end of last week they
promised staff and fans an announcement
within 48 hours of the match on sunday
neither of these promises have been kept
staff fans and players at the club are
left with the lingering doubt that the
owners might prefer the club to default
on its rugby commitments so that
expulsion from the premiership makes it
easier to focus on developing property
assets away from the rugby such an
outcome would risk making not only the
warriors but the community foundation
the academy the amateur club wrfc and
the worcester raiders football club
homeless it will be a disaster for sport
in our county and a huge blow which
either i nor my fellow worcestershire mp
are prepared to accept
even after staff went above and beyond
the gain to secure this weekend's
matches
another deadline has understandably been
set by the rugby authorities for monday
and i know that staff players and the
exhausted heads of department of the
club will do all they can to meet it but
i cannot be certain that they will be
able to without the support of the
directors or new finance if the process
gives way i will give back i'm very
grateful my honorable friend from
worcester making fantastic case the
importance of rugby in his city as in
mine gloucester and can i just share
with him the solidarity that everybody
at king's home in gloucester rugby feels
for the club we want to see the warriors
back on great form and we want to see
these financial problems resolved he has
our full support in gloucester i'm
extremely grateful to my honourable
friend for gloucester and i have to say
as the son of a former gloucester player
it made me very proud and
impressed when when gloucester offered
free tickets uh to that game um
just the other day um to the staff and
those players of worcester warriors who
weren't playing i think that was a great
gesture of solidarity and it was
enormously
appreciated if if the protestations of
the current owners are true that they
have the best interests of the club at
heart then surely even at this stage
they should be calling in the
administrators however whilst any doubt
persists about their motivation i now
urge dcms as the largest creditor and
the department responsible for
safeguarding the interests of sport to
step in and do so before monday i know
of at least two significant interested
parties one of whom is the party with
whom owners claim to be about to strike
a deal last week who have said they are
interested in stepping in with new
finance to support the club but only
through a process of administration
i say to my honourable friend the
minister that this now seems the only
way forward before he responds i do just
want to address two further points that
have been brought to my attention by the
press firstly there is a suggestion from
one creditor of the club that sport
england have somehow unwittingly
assisted in the separation of assets
from the club or made it easier for
property to be alienated from it i hope
my honourable friend can assure me this
is not the case
in doing so i would urge him not simply
to reiterate that there's already been a
formal separation of the stadium from
other land before the sport england loan
was negotiated we all know that but it's
not the point the concern is that the
new lease that was negotiated at sport
england's behest changed the terms on
which the rugby trading company held use
of the stadium and reduced its access to
non-rugby income and the proceeds of any
events other than those related to the
game itself the accounts show that prior
to this the book value of the lease held
by the trading company was 16 million
pounds can wearable thing confirm that
this book value still sits with the club
and the assets over which the dcms has a
call and if not i hope you can reassure
me that any process of administration
will take into account of all uses of
public funding and where any of this has
been used to pay property debt or secure
other assets for the owners or their
holding companies mq property limited
six ways property limited and bond group
property limited six ways these can be
brought into scope of any administration
process
i do not believe for a moment that sport
england or anyone at the department wish
to reduce the income available to a
sports club but i do think it's vital we
ensure that no inadvertent harm is done
through the complex processes the club
has gone through under departmental
supervision finally
and most damningly in the eyes of most
worcester folk is the report in today's
mail that the owners borrowed money from
the family of the late cecil duckworth
and have failed to repay it i cannot
stress enough how upsetting and
appalling this is one senior player has
described the suggestion as
heartbreaking
what is also striking having now
discussed the matter with beatrice
cecil's widow is that the money was
borrowed in january 2020 before any
impact of the pandemic and long before
the owners admitted to the currently
financial woes of the club with the
express intention of making payroll
within a few years of taking control of
the club and after one of their original
investors pulled out they went to the
great founder and benefactor of
warrior's success and borrowed half a
million pounds
since his death they refused to
communicate with his widow or her
lawyers to give an update as to the
status of this debt or confirm when and
how it might be repaid they have
asserted that half the money is not owed
as a promise was made on the basis of a
handshake for cell to cover the costs of
employing the then manager of the club
allen sonomas and although there is no
documentary evidence to back this claim
the family have accepted that they will
not contest it
even after this there has been no
further engagement with the duckworth
family on the remaining money i cannot
express in parliamentary terms my
personal revulsion at the way in which
those charged with protecting cecil
duckworth's legacy have behaved and
seemingly continue to behave
as i'm told the loan doesn't appear
anywhere in the published accounts of
the club all the holding companies it
also begs questions as to how they are
meeting their legal responsibilities as
directors and what other uncle
undeclared debts they may have taken on
no wonder one potential buyer has this
week called for administration to
include quote a forensic investigation
of financial activities
my request to the minister is therefore
simple two weeks ago i and my fellow
worcestershire colleagues spoke out with
one voice to call on the dcms to step in
and take the warriors into
administration in order that their
future can be secured that call is now
more urgent than ever nothing in the
experience of the last two weeks has
given us any greater confidence that the
current directors can or will deliver
the patience of staff players and fans
is being stretched beyond endurance
investors are waiting in the wings with
serious offers backed by serious local
business people and serious rugby folk
to take the club out of administration
and set it on a secure footing securing
their support is vital i urge the rfu
and prl to continue to show the
forbearance and understanding that
they've shown to date and to listen to
the calls from across the rugby world
for the way be found to allow the
warriors to continue to play in the top
flight i urge dcms to delay no longer
further and to formally trigger a
process of administration to secure the
club and all the property assets
associated with it before monday's
deadline i urge them to ensure there are
directors in charge of the warriors who
are fit and proper in short minister
please save our warriors
thank you very much indeed madam deputy
speaker and i'm pleased to respond to
this debate and i'm grateful to my
honorable friend for worcester for
securing uh for securing this debate the
interest shown i think this afternoon is
testament to the important
importance that this club represents to
the local community and to the sport of
rugby as a whole and i pay tribute for
the work that he has done and can i also
offer
my
thanks at also to my honourable friend
the member for mid worcestershire who um
did this job extremely well and i know
that i've got very big shoes to fill so
i
and i know that he has taken is now able
to take keen interest in this
issue as we've heard today
the club has had many different forms
but can date back to worcester rugby
football club which was first
established in 1871 it was a long and
eventful journey to the club's debut in
the men's top flight in 2004 under the
stewardship of john brain and cecil
duckworth who he's talked so movingly
about today both of whom have had a
lasting impact on the club and the local
community the club has gone from
strength to strength and seen its talent
recognized at an international level
with multiple players including current
captain ted hill being capped for
england the dramatic extra time the
premiership cup win against london irish
in may provided an unforgettable moment
for all involved with the club
the success is not just limited though
to the men's team however with the
worcester
ladies team winning their inaugural
premiership title in 2013 before
becoming part of warriors group in 2016.
the success has continued since then
with laura keats and lydia thompson both
being named for the england women's
world cup squad this week
and off the pitch the warriors community
foundation makes a significant impact
around the local area providing vital
services including a positive and safe
learning environment for some of the
hardest to reach young people
for all these reasons i was pleased that
the government was able to support the
club to survive the challenges of the
kobit 19 pandemic through the sport
survival package like many other sectors
the sports sector suffered as a result
of the essential restrictions we all
lived under during the pandemic the
government was proactive in taking
action to protect the sector through the
600 million pound sport survival package
the package was set up to ensure as many
sport clubs
reliant on spectators survive the period
of restrictions during the pandemic
whilst also seeking to minimise the
potential long-term damage to sport with
a particular focus on the importance of
grassroots activity and women's sport
this intervention was essential in
maintaining professional sport in this
country through such a very difficult
period
however as the nation recovers and the
crowds return to stadiums it is right
that the government takes a step back
from providing direct financial support
the support survival package was
administered by sport